GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
AND WELCOME THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING- WHILE WE'RE WAITING
MORE MEMBERS I THINK OF THE
MIDDLE EAST BEGIN WITH SOME OF
THE PREAMBLE TO OUR MEETINGS
NOWADAYS THAT WE HAVE TO DO. TO
MAKE SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
HOW CAN OPERATE- WILL CONTINUE
TO PRACTICE FISCAL DISINFECTED
LOADINGS WERE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRED THE MASTERY WORN IN
FISCAL DISCIPLINE BE MAINTAINED
BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR THE BEDROOM VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASS WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. I'M STILL
HERE. TODAY IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN MAKING OUT OF IT AS I
MENTIONED CAN ONLY COME IN A
MINIMAL. CONTINGENT OF FOLKS SO
THAT MEANS A MINIMAL
CONTENTIOUS AFTER A LIMITED
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA.
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACING. THEY'RE ALSO STRICT
FISCAL DISCIPLINE PROTOCOLS FOR
THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE
THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
IN THE ROOM. IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
PUSH TO MAKE FUN OF THE PERFECT
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR TURN
YOUR SEATS. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVERS CRITICIZING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL. WE DO HAVE
ONE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION IN
CAPITOL PARK. IN ADDITION-
REPURPOSE ORDINARILY THE CASE
HAVE- DIALING WITNESSES AS WELL.
AND SO- WE'RE GONNA BE USING A
MODERATE TOLD US TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CONTEST FINAL BILL. IF
YOU'RE CALLING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ASK THAT YOU
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. THE CALL NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
LABOR COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE WHICH
IS A L. B. R. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT GOV. A. L. B. R. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT G. O. V. AS
WELL AS ENERGY WE SCREAM.
YOU'LL SEE THE SUN THAT THE
NUMBER TO CALL AND- IF YOU ARE
CALLING EMPLOYEE PLAN PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON
HIS BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACING QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL.
FOR CALLING EMPLOYEES LIMIT ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCASTS ON YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED IF YOU'RE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL. YOU WERE A
MAN ON A LIVE LINE IT WILL NEED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. FOR HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATOR
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMEDIAN NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE ONE. MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. I ALSO WANT TO KNOW WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
TO THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE
ALSO HAVE AN EMAIL ADDRESS SET
UP AND YOU CAN USE TO EMAIL%
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THAT EMAIL IS
A L. B. R. DOT COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT G. O. V.
AGAIN IT'S A L. B. R. DOT
COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
G. O. V. THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO BEAR WITH US AS
WE IF MY MATH IS TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHILE ALSO BEING MINDFUL
RESPECT FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. SO AS WE
AWAIT MORE MEMBERS- I'M GONNA
OPENS BEGAN AS A COMMITTEE THE
WHOLE AS A BEACON. YES UP THE
MIDDLE MANAGEMENT. IT'S IS SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE IT BEGIN AND
SHOW RESPECT OR SENATOR LIZ
HERE ON TIME AND- EXCERPTED WE
CAN START BY HAVING- SB. THREE
TWENTY ONE. SENATOR THE
LAWSUIT. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
TAKE YOUR TIME AND TO APPEAR IN
A YOU HAVE A FEW BILLS WITH US
THIS. AFTERNOON AND I BELIEVE
THAT'S THE FIRST ONE WILL BE
STARTING WITH. IS THREE TWO ONE
YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER YOU MAY BEGIN. IT'S BEEN
ACTING REALLY. MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS THERE ARE MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND WORDS IN
CALIFORNIA. MORE THAN TWO
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS DEPEND ON
THEIR LABOR TO CARE FOR THEIR
AND OUR FAMILIES. DOMESTIC
WORKERS WHO ARE PRIMARILY
IMMIGRANT WORKER ESSENTIAL TO
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY THEY
ALLOW THE REST OF US TO DO
CARRY ON WITH OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES THEY DESERVE
CONSIDERATION FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUES JUST LIKE ANY
OTHER WORKING PERSON. WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO INCLUDE THIS GROUP
OF WORKERS FROM BASIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS. NOT
DURING THIS HEALTH PANDEMIC NOT
DURING WILDFIRES THAT BURNED
THROUGH OUR STATE NOT IN THE
EVERYDAY WORK THAT PUTS THEIR
HEALTH AND WELL BEING ON THE
LINE. IN THE END MANY OF US
HAVE OR WILL DEPEND ON SOMEONE
TO CLEAN OUR HOMES TAKE CARE OF
OUR ELDERLY OR DISABLED HOME
SHOULD BE SAFE FOR THEM TO
CARRY OUT THEIR DUTIES. DURING
THE WILDFIRES THAT DEVASTATED
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEES. WERE ASKED
TO STAY BEHIND TO SPRAY DOWN
PROPERTIES OF WATER GUARD HOMES
FOR PETS WORKING SMOKY
CONDITIONS AND CLEAN UP TOXIC
ASH THEY WERE ALSO SOMETIMES
NOT TOLD THAT THE HOMES THAT
THEY WERE WORKING THAT WERE
UNDER MANDATORY EVACUATION
ORDERS. THE CURRENT STILL
CURRENT GOAL BUT NINETEEN
HEALTH PANDEMIC HAS ONLY
FURTHER MAGNIFIED THE
VULNERABILITIES AND DANGERS THE
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND DAY
LABORERS FACE ON A DAILY BASIS.
I AM SO GRATEFUL TO THE BROAD
COALITION INCLUDING HELPING
HANDS HOUSEHOLD EMPLOYERS GROUP
THAT HAS BEEN WORKING HARD TO
SUPPORT THEIR DOMESTIC WORKERS.
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE AND
COMMITTED TO THE WELL BEING OF
THOSE MEN AND WOMEN. MY
WITNESSES BY PHONE TODAY ARE
YET ME NOT BECAUSE THEY ARE
THOSE DIRECTOR OF LOCAL LIKE
THE ABOUT THE MOORHEAD IS AT
THE LAWRENCE STREET COMMUNITY
SERVICES. HELEN I CAN BURKE
EMPLOYER WITH HAND IN HAND
MYSTIC WORKER EMPLOYERS NETWORK
AND HINA SHAH LEGAL COUNSEL FOR
DOMESTIC WORKERS. ON THE LINE-
MISTER CHAIR FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER. AND AS ALWAYS
ALL WITNESSES HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES O SPEAK EACH. AND
WHENEVER THERE'S A WITNESS THAT
NEEDS THE ASSISTANCE OF. AN
INTERPRETER WE TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT AS WELL SO. I SB THREE
TWENTY ONE. WE HAVE- GIVE ME
NOT BECAUSE THE AUTOS AND HELEN
I CAN BURKE SO GETTING YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE YOU MAY
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
EACH ONE OF THE- NUMBER OF THE
ADMIN OF THE YOUNG WILL BE
EXCELLENT ABILITY ONE OKAY
THIS. IS OF THE THREE COMMUNITY
SERVICE OR SOMETHING. ONE OF
THE NICEST YOUNG DEMOCRAT
ITSELF ABOUT US THAT LOOK THAT.
CONTENT GOT STUCK WITH THE
NINOS ON CM OF THE- BASED
POLICY THAT IS. A MEMBER OF ONE
LITTLE BIT OF POLITICS BEYOND
THAT THEY'LL HAVE A OF THE MOLD.
WILL CALIFORNIA. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DETERMINAR QUé OCT
DONALD. DOES NOT TO BE ON THE
MARKET THE BILL UNDER.
COMMUNITY SERVICES WILL DUMP.
ON ORGANIZATION UP INDEPENDENT
BURKE WHO CO HOUSE. I YOU FOR
SHOWS THEY- AND PEOPLE WITH.
AND A FINAL AND OF THE-
CALIFORNIA THE- WORK PUBLIC. WE
HAVE A PROBLEM IN THE MONTH
THING. DISAPPROVAL SOPHIE. SIX
ONE AND WE LOVE IT BUT I
O'CLOCK BUT WHAT IF I LOVE YOU
SEE WHAT THE NEED IS. THE
DEMOCRATS LAWS IN THE THAT THE
BILL WILL NOT A LOT OF THE- NEW
ZEALAND. DEMOCRAT AS THE- THERE
THAT A- BICYCLE. SEASONAL I'M
BEING. YEARS SIXTEEN SMALL GETS.
FIFTY THREE. IT'S OKAY INSTEAD
OF THE- CALIFORNIA ALMOST
DOUBLE THIS ISSUE SOON ONE OF
ONE OF OUR WATER WAS GOING
ISSUE. ON INCLUDED THAT FOR.
YOU'RE NOT IN A YOU FOR THE
FOR. YOUR PROPERTY THEFT ZERO
ONE MEAN FOR FIELD A LITTLE.
VEHICLES IN THE OF OUR- IT'S
THREE. MY. BOTH OF THESE
EXPLOSIONS I WORK FOR DAYS NOW
MAINLY IMMIGRANTS AND WOMEN OF
COLOR DO NOT HAVE THE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. TRAINING
OR INFORMATION ABOUT GROUPS
THAT WORK WHICH IS CRITICAL AND
EVEN MORE NECESSARY AFTER A
YEAR OF DEFENDANT LOOK AND WITH
THE FIRES. JUST AROUND THE
CORNER. THAT'S WHAT A COUPLE OF
THE LOWEST OF ON THE PHONE THE
MORNING. OF UNION FOR MUSCLE
NINE YOU'LL WANT IN THEM SO
UNLESS THERE'S STILL NOT MODEL
NUMBER THAT I WOULD BE OF A
VEHICLE ASSEMBLED. AS WE SAW
THAT IF I DID A LOT OF YOUNG
FOR YES PEOPLE OF THE STATE
BONTA HERO FROM THE MIDDLE
SEGMENT BUT MARKLE. I WOULD GET
SOME OF THE ANVIL NO PROBLEM
WITH THE RESULT OF THE FORMER
HAVE OWNER. IS THE BOTTOM. WHAT
DOLE THEY LOOKED THEY MET. I
THINK WORKERS WHERE AND TO BE
ON THE LINES LARGE A YEAR YOU
THE DEMO DOES NOT VULNERABLE TO
VIRUS OR HOMES AND OUT OF HER.
THERE ARE MORE FOR WORK WHO
HAVE DIED THEY CALL THE VIRUS
THAT WORK NOW THIS REAL WE CAN
FORGET THE WERE GOING YOUR DATE
FACT OF THE FANDOM. THE YOU
ALONG. THE NUMBER OF LOCAL
EXAMPLE VISIT THE- ARAB. IT'S
THE FIRST. IS THIRTY FIVE FOR
THE- PUBLIC OF ALL OF THE LOWER.
I WOULD WANT WAS A LITTLE BIT
OF TROUBLE. MEDICINE FEDERAL
SAID WITH HIS UP. GIVING ME THE-
INTO A BUCKET. I WOULD. IN YOUR
RESULT. WILL MAKE. MORE BUT
WHAT THEY ARE GOOD FOR. WILL BE.
SO THAT THE. SB THIRTY ONE WE
TO PUT TO. DISEASE GETS AND-
DOMESTIC WORKER LIKE ANY OTHER
WORK BECAUSE HEALTH SAFETY AND
BEGIN. ON THE JOB MORE THAN
EVER I ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTING FAVOR OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK VERY MUCH BECAUSE
THEY ALSO AFTER. THANK YOU-
HELEN EISENBERG. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS HELEN AND I DOMESTIC
AND A MEMBER OF HAND IN HAND I
AM PLAY A HOUSE CLEANER GLORIA
WHO'S WORKED WITH US FOR FIVE
YEARS GLORIA WORKS FOR SEVEN
DIFFERENT FAMILIES ON THE
STREET RIGHT NOW AND YOU KNOW
IT'S A VERY INTIMATE
RELATIONSHIP TO BRING SOMEONE
INTO YOUR HOME FOR WORK AND I
DON'T SEE HOW IT'S POSSIBLE TO
NOT CARE ABOUT THIS EMPLOYEE
HEALH AND SAFETY. I TOLD
GLORIA THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT
FOR ME TO BUY NON TOXIC
PRODUCTS FOR HER TO USE BECAUSE
I DIDN'T LONGER BREATHING IN
TOXIC FUMES ALL DAY ARE USING
ANYTHING THAT WOULD POSSIBLY BE
DANGEROUS TO OUR HEALTH OR
HOURS YOU TOLD ME THAT SHE
WANTED TO USE THE HEAVY DUTY
TOXIC PRODUCTS BECAUSE SHE
WOULD COMMITTED TO DOING THE
BEST JOB POSSIBLE SHOULD YOU
BELIEVE THAT THEY WERE BETTER.
I REALIZE THAT THERE WEREN'T
ANY GUIDELINES OR EQUIPMENT TO
PROVIDE RICH TO BE ABLE TO USE
TOXIC PRODUCTS SAFELY LIKE IN
ANY OTHER WORKPLACE THAT THEY
WOULD PROVIDE HOWEVER WE WERE
ABLE TO DISCUSS WITH HER HEALTH
AND ALL OF OUR HEALTH FOR MORE
IMPORTANT AND THE CLEANING WAS
STILL GOOD QUALITY AND WE WERE
ALL SAFE SHE ALSO TRUE WITH
COBIT THERE WERE NO GUIDELINES
FOR EMPLOYERS OR EMPLOYEES WHEN
HE CAME TO THE DOMESTIC WORK
INDUSTRY WE AND OUR FAMILY MADE
THE DECISION TO TAKE GLORIA AND
HAVE TO STAY HOME SO WE WERE
ALL SAFE. BUT NOT EVERYONE DID
AND SOME IT WASN'T EVEN AN
OPTION FOR LIKE THOSE WHO RELY
ON CARE GIVERS ARE MANAGED ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS ALL OF THE
CITY WE WERE MAKING SURE
EVERYONE'S SAFE BUT WHO WAS
ENSURING DOMESTIC WORKER SAFETY
WHEN YOU TAKE A JOB POSTED
SOMEWHERE IN THAT BUILDING ARE
THE GUIDELINES FROM CAL OSHA TO
HELP EVERYONE KNOWS THE
RESPONSIBLE STEPS YOU TAKE TO
ENSURE EVERYONE'S SAFETY WE ARE
THE GUIDELINES FOR DOMESTIC.
WORKERS LOOK FOR ME TO DO MY
JOB. I CAN. HER IN THE EIGHTEEN
PLACES. MY HOME. I BE ABLE TO
TELL. IF YOU HAVE TO. ABOUT
YOUR HEALTH AND SAFETY. THERE
IS A PLACE THAT YOU GO. AND
THEY WILL. YOU IN PROVIDE.
THESE ARE THE REASONS WHY I AM
HERE TODAY. TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT SB THREE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL NOW TAKE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT STARTING
WITH ANYONE IN THE ROOM- THAT
IS IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWENTY ONE. THEY WERE IN THE
ROOM THE SCOPE OF THE
MICROPHONE DOES ANYONE SO
ANYONE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
AND FOR A MODERATOR ANYONE IS
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
ZERO ONE NINE ZERO YOUR IN
SUPPORT. WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CITY
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO A PHOTO LINE OF
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY
PHONE NUMBER AT THE TIME LINE
OF THE VICTIMS DECEMBER
CURRENTLY UNDER THE POLITICAL
FOR THE DEVICES AND PUT THE
FALCONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF ONE OH THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MERCURY FOR YOUR SWEETHEART ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PLANET
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. THE BILL
COSPONSORED. IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF ONE OH TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FIND ONE OH TWO DO YOU
HAVE A SON MUTE. I'M SORRY I'M
NOT I WANTED BEGUN SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR. OKAY ANEXO
CAROLINE OF ONE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS THE NOT THE BAR BUT I'M
BASED IN LOS ANGELES AND THE
LEAD ORGANIZER OF THE
CALIFORNIANS AND I THINK
WORKERS COALITION AND I SUPPORT
SB THREE TWO ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AB NUMBER BUT ON THE CAN YOU
THOUGHT. ABOUT DEMOCRATS THAT
THEY DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE ANY
TROUBLE THAT INCLUDED TOMMY
BACK AT THE WHAT THE WHAT THE
PRICE OF IT IS A GOOD IDEA.
MATHIS THANK YOU ANNEX A LINE
OF ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS GREAT THREE HOT I
LIVE IN PALO ALTO I'M WITH THE
WOMEN AND GIRLS RIGHTS PROJECT
AT PUBLIC COUNSEL AND I SUPPORT
SB THREE TWO ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT A LINE OF
ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS MEGAN WHALEN I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC
WORKERS COALITION BASED AND SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M HERE ON
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE TWO ONE
THANK THEM RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ON A P.
ZERO I'M CALLING FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA I AM AN EMPLOYER THE
NANNY AND I'M PART OF HAND IN
HAND WITH A SINGLE PLAYER
NETWORK AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OF THAT THE
THREE TWO ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER TO
LINE OF EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
EVAN NIDA I LIVE IN DOWNING I'M
A DOT OF A DOMESTIC WORKER AND
A MEMBER OF THE PHILIPPINE
AMERICAN CENTER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. SB THREE TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTROVERT SECOND LINE OF ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS VANESSA BAHARI I
LIVED IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I
AM A PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
DOMESTIC WORKERS COALITION AND
I SUPPORT SB THREE TWO ONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL I MEAN
NUMBER SECRETARY BANK WILL MEAN
THAT THEY ARE NOT A SINGLE
MOTHER OF THE GREAT THINGS.
PHOTO HELLOAT IT IF WE IF WE
HANDLE THE INCIDENT THAT HAS
BEING GIVEN. THAT YOU. ASSIST
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT A LINE OF
ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS NATALIE
ABOUT THE SENATE CALLING FROM
SENATOR DINO I AM AN ALLY AND A
MEMBER OF THE POMONA ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY CENTER AND IT'S ON
THE SUPPORT SB THREE TWO ONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT OVER
LINE OF ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
ADDRESSES VETO AND I LIVE IN
SAN DIEGO I AM AN ALLY AND
MEMBER OF THE FILIPINO MIGRANT
CENTER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB THREE TWO ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JEANNIE
IN MY LIVE IN ROCK CALIFORNIA
I'M AN EMPLOYER OF TWO HOUSE
CLEANERS I'M A MEMBER OF HAND
IN HAND THE NATIONAL DOMESTIC
WORKERS. NETWORK AND THE
NATIONAL DOMESTIC WORKERS
ALLIANCE AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKYOU
NEXT TO A LINE OF ONE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HIBERNATES
CELL SILVA WAS ADAMANT THAT THE
GREETING DAY LABOR CENTER IN
CINEMA COUNTY AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND ACCESSIBLE TO LINE OF
ONE FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA KIßM I'M
CALLING FROM DALY CITY. I'M A
MEMBER OF HAND IN HAND I AM AN
EMPLOYER OF A DOMESTIC WORKER A
HOUSE CLEANER. AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT SB THREE
TWO ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AN EXTROVERT SO LINE OF WHAT
ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHEN ATTENDING A
RECKONING OF BATTLE OF ME WHEN
SOMEBODY CALLS ON UNANIMOUS
MASON YES THAT EVEN. IF I DON'T
I DON'T I THINK IN THE FACT
THAT WE OPENED. A LOCAL. ISSUES
SUCH AS- SO I DON'T FORTY TWO
YEAR LINE AT THE YOU WILL BOARD
A LINE OF ONE SIX FIVE YEAR
LINE OPEN. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT. I
REMEMBER DIDN'T AND I ORDER NOT
A BROKER. I'M SORRY. THANK YOU
FOR GETTING A LOT BIT AND P. WE
WILL ARE WE WERE TO HEAR FROM.
OKAY THANK YOU. WE WILL GO TO
LINE A ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PEOPLE. HE. SIX ONE MINUTE OKAY
NO I DON'T WANT FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ET. NOW IT'S GOOD
NOW IT'S GETTING A LITTLE
GETTING. HELLO TWO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. OKAY RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
YOUR EMAIL THE MODERATOR FOR
SECOND HE COULDN'T HEAR YOU
VERY WELL SO LET'S TRY THE NEXT
CALL AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THANK GOODNESS AT LINE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY MEMBERS OF THE
S. AND NIGHTS UPON MAINTAIN TWO
INTO ONE AND BECAUSE THE WORK
IS- ONE VERYCAR AND NEED AND
OKAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOUR NEXT TO GO T
LINE OF ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THERE
WERE MINIMAL NUMBER HAVE A GOOD
TELEPHONE NUMBER. OF THE
POLITICAL. RIGHT ONE OF THE
BEST. THANK YOUR NECK SO WELL
OF ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS SYLVIA MANDATES I
LIVE IN SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA I
AM A NO CAN I REMEMBER OPENING
MY NOTES IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I
STRONG SUPPORTER. OF THE IN THE
STREET TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JUST IN ROWS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWO HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LINDSAY IN MY HAN I AM
THE CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR
HAND IN HAND THE DOMESTIC
PLAYERS NETWORK WE REPRESENT
HUNDREDS OF EMPLOYERS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO IN THE ANY EMPLOYER AND
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TWO ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS JOHN GLOBALLY I AM WITH THE
NORTHEAST DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF
LOS ANGELES AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE- OF THE- LAW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS LUCY
SENTENCIA I DON'T EVEN KNOW
PLAN CALIFORNIA- DOMESTIC
WORKERS I MEMBERS OBLIGATED TO
ME THE FACT EVEN ON RAMA THROWS
THE BALL THE SB THREE TO ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TO ALL ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
HAYLEY CURRIER AND I'M A MEMBER
OF HAND IN HAND WITH THAT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR NETWORK I LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES IN MY FAMILY
EMPLOYED HOUSEKEEPER AND LOCAL-
THE HOME ATTENDANCE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE TWO
ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF ONE TO THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH. YES
HELLO YEP. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MEGAN ORTIZ UNDER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INSTITUTE A LITTLE CAMPBELL
PULLOUT BED SO THE CALIFORNIA
HE THAT START REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES DAY LABOR AND DOMESTIC
WORKER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TWO ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF ONE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALONG
THE NUMBER THREE AND THEN THE
NUMBER OF. FOUR EIGHT RIGHT UP
UNTIL THE MOMENT. HE THOUGHT
ABOUT. NOW FOR THE MOTION SEVEN
YOU FOR. THIS IS. THAT THANK
YOU NEXT TO- I OF ONE OF FORTY
ONE YEAR IS- OPEN. NINE ONE
FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MEXICO TO LINE A WALL
ONE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAN AND I AND
I AM AN ALLY AN ORGANIZER SO WE
DEBT AND I USED FROM THE POOR
IN THE THREE TWO ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OF A LINE
OF TWO OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI. THREE CAN WITH YOU
WILL LOOK STUPID AND WRONG
BECAUSE IF YOU DID IT WILL
BRING PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING TO
DO ANYTHING WELCOME TO YOUR
WILL WON'T AND MORMON WELCOME.
AND DIDN'T. WHO WILL BE.
ACCORDING Q. GREATLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEVERAL OF TWO TEN
LINE OF. NINE NINE IS MICHAEL
LED BY I'M NOT THANK YOU FROM
THREE LAST. AND I HOPE FOR SB
THE ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF TWO
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TO SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE OF A NUMBER IS
LOOKING UP TO SEE A- EVEN WITH
DENTIST IF YOU LOOK AT BULLYING
LANDSCAPING IT IS STILL ON THE
MARKET. THANK YOU NEXT ON THE
LINE OF EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
AVAILABLE CERTAIN ORGANIZER
WITH THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH OF THE PEOPLE
AT THE TABLE IN ADDITION A
STRONG SUPPORT SB TWO TO ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
A LINE OF TO ALL FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
CORINNE I'M GREAT STAFF
ATTORNEY AT WORK SAVE- WORKED
INTO THE PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE
TWO ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF TWO TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB DOT
ORG AND I'M WORKING WITH OTHER
SENIOR THAT. ARE MOSTLY WALKER
PERFORM POPCORN ON THE STOVE
THE BOX. BE CLEAR COOL. WATER
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT SO TO ALLOW OUT OF TWO.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME THINKING YEAH I AM A HOT
DINNER MEMBER OF YOUR QUICKLY
WENT AHEAD I THINK SOME
PRACTICAL AND I SUPPORT SB.
THREE TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
LINE OF ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND NEXT OVER LINE OF TWO
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I AM AN ALLY BUT THE MOMENT I
COULD NOT MUCH. BETTER THANK
YOU WHAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXAVAR LINE OF TWO THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS GLORIA BRUCE I LIVE
IN OAKLAND I'M A MEMBER OF HAND
AND- PLAYER OF THE HOUSE
CLEANER AND CHILD CARE WORKERS
ON IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THREE
TWO ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AN EXIT WHAT THE LINE OF TWO
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THERE MY NAME IS GREAT THREE
HOT I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND
WITH THE WOMEN AND GIRLS RIGHTS
PROJECT OF PUBLIC COUNSEL AND I
SUPPORT SB THREE TWO ONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVERLAND OF
TWO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS MADISON LEVINE I
REMEMBER ALL THE THEY SPENT ON
LIVING HUNTINGTON PARK THANKS
FUNDS ATED. THREE THREE TWO
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF THE TWO
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS MARIE IN MINE I LIVE IN
SCOTTS VALLEY I'M AN EMPLOYER
TO HOUSE CLEANERS AND A MEMBER
OF HAND IN HAND AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THREE TWO ONE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA LINE OF TWO TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAN
NUMBER EIGHT AND A BETA ON
BEHALF OF THE L. A. COUNTY
FEDERATION OF PAPER AND
TEAMSTERS PORT DIVISION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE A ONE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHEN I
STARTED WITH THE MAJORITY OF MY
AVAILABILITY I DIDN'T HATE IT
BUT THAT WILL HAVE ABOUT A LACK
YOU GET FOR YOUR LIFE AND MAKE.
A BIG DEAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF- ONE. IT'S
ME ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI I'M ONE OUT AND- I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT COUNTY- FROM
OUR MINDS A STRONG WILL TO
SUPPORT EIGHT. THREE THREE
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF ACUTE. TWO SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY TWO SIX
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN
MEXICO LINE OF THE TWO SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS DAVID GERGEN NINE BY WIFE
AND I LIVE IN ROSS REMEMBERS
THE HANDED AND WE EMPLOY A
HOUSE CLEANER. UP FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS AND WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT. AB THREE TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF AT NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. A DIFFICULT NINE LOS
ANGELES CLIENTS IN A KANEMI
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU YEAH MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER- SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
SMALL WONDER OPPOSITION THERE
NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES. WE
WLL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
THOSE OPPOSED OF THE STATE JUST
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION OBSERVED
ON THE BILL. ANYONE THE ROOM.
THIS MATERIAL IN THE ROOM SO IS
ANYONE OF THE REMOTE TEST MY
STATION IN OPPOSITION SB THREE
TWENTY ONE. AND IF NOT A META
MODERATED TO HAVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. Q. AND
OPPOSITION OF SB. THREE TWENTY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ONE NINE ZERO COULD OPPOSITION
OF SB. THREE TWO ONE. MY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AND WE HAVE
ONE IN Q. WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF FIVE TWO THIRDS TO SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHY DO
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHAU. NEXAVAR LINE OF A TWO
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NOW. NINE TO SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND AGAIN I'VE
BEEN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWO
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. LIKE TO SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN AND WE CAN HEAR
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN FROM YOU
KNOW WHAT I CAN DO AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU WELCOME M. SECRETARY
OF COULD. CALL ROLE FOR QUORUM
BEFORE WE BRING BACK COMMITTEE.
KALRA HERE FLORIDA. GONZALEZ
JONES SAWYER PRESENT VARIOUS
FERARRO WARD. WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND SO ANY COMMENTS OR MOTIONS
OR- FROM. COMMITTEE HER
EVOLUTION FROM A FEDERAL
WARRANT SECOND FROM JONES
SAWYER. ANY FURTHER COMMENT I'D
JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORD AGAIN I
BELIEVE I WAS A CALL AUTHORIZED
TIME IF BY FAILED TO ASK YOU TO
BE A CALL AFTER THIS TIME
PLEASE PLEASE. I BEG YOU TO ADD
ME. HOPEFULLY GET ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE THIS TIME. OF THAT
THANK YOU AND UP FOR A PURPOSE
YOU CLOSE I ALSO YOU KNOW IS
TRY TO AVOID. THEM I DON'T COST
A LOT OF THOSE AND ARE GONNA
COME UP FOR ME SEEMS LIKE THOSE
OF THE NAMES ARE ALSO ON IT
SEEM TO BE AN EXCEPTION MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT. AND SO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON OR THAT
ALSO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM SECRETARY
POWELL ON. SB THREE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE KALRA. HI.
KALRA HI FLORA. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. JIM SO. I JONES
SAWYER IRATE IS. THERE ARE NO.
WORK WARD I RIGHT BILL IS UP
WITH OPEN THANK YOU CENTER AND
THE WE GO TO THE NEXT ONE WE
HAVE A AMOUNT OF MY MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THAT'S- A
SB SEVEN OH FIVE IN SB SEVEN
FIFTY THREE. PERFECT MOTIONS
SECOND. APPROVAL COMPANIES
MANUFACTURE. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SB SEVEN OH FIVE THE
MOTION ON THAT BILL IS TO PASS
A CONSENT TO EDUCATION
COMMITTEE SB SEVEN FIFTY THREE
THE MOTION IS DUEPASS CONSENT
TO APPROPRIATIONS- KALRA FIVE.
KALRA HI FLORA GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE RADIUS SCIARRETTO
LORD. LORD ALRIGHT. ADOPTED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MUNONDO SB
SIX THIRTY NINE THOSE ARE THAT
ALSO YOU MAY BEGIN EVERYBODY.
WELL DO ONE TOGETHER AND IN
ORDER. THE DEAL WHATEVER YOU
GOT THAT'S WHY I THINK WE CAN
LEAVE THIS LAST. SO WHICH ONE
OKAY I'LL DO- SIX SEVENTY FOUR
OKAY SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR IS
FILE ITEM FOR. AT THE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR WILL SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF EQUITABLE HIGH
QUALITY TRANSPORTATION AND
RELATED MANUFACTURING
INFRASTRUCTURE JOBS IN OUR
STATE. GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE PUT FORTH
BUDGET PLANS- IDEAS THAT
PROPOSED SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN SUSTAINABLE JOB
CREATION AND THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS BEEN CLEAR THE PUBLIC
DOLLARS SHOULD CREATE COMMUNITY
BENEFITS INCLUDING WELL PAID
JOBS HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER ON
CLIMATE. IS THE URGENT ISSUE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS WITH
THE CREATION OF NEW GOOD JOBS
FOR ESPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN HEAVILY POLLUTED
COMMUNITIES- WE'RE POSITIONING
CALIFORNIA LEAD ON THIS FIRST
WE NEED TO HAVE A MECHANISM IN
PLACE. TO GUIDE OUR SPENDING
TOWARD QUALITY JOB CREATION
SOMETIMES WE THINK THAT'LL
JUST- TRICKLE DOWN- BUT IT
DOESN'T SB SIX SEVENTY FOUR
WILL ENSURE THAT THE BENEFITS
OF THE TRANSITION TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. MUST INCLUDE
GOOD PAYING QUALITY JOBS
ESPECIALLY COMMITTEES LEFT OUT.
LAST YEAR'S AB THREE NINETY A
REPORT IDENTIFIED GOODS
MOVEMENT AND MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE
AS THE BIGGEST SINGLE
CONTRIBUTOR OF POLLUTION AT THE
SAME TIME THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM UNDERPINS OUR ECONOMY
THE FREIGHT SYSTEM MOVES
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF GOODS
EACH YEAR SUPPORTING NEARLY ONE
THIRD OF THE STATE ECONOMY AND
MORE THAN FIVE MILLION JOBS. SB
SIX SEVENTY FOUR WOULD ENACT
THAT CALIFORNIA JOBS PLAN TO
CREATE A. PARTNERSHIP WITH
COMPANIES FROM FUNDED
TRANSPORTATION CA AND SUB. IT
WILL BE A COMPONENT OF AN APP
SUBMITTED FOR COVERED BY CON.
THAT'S BEST THE NUMBER OF JOB
CREATED PROPOS WAGES INVESTMENT
IN TRAINING AND TARGETED HIRING
PLANS FOR DISPLACED WORKERS AND
WORKERS HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED
IT WILL REQUIRE ANY NEW MINIMUM
COMMITMENTS OTHER THAN THOSE
ALREADY REQUIRED. OF PROCEDURES
IN CHRIST CRITERIA SHALL AWARD
ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATION TO
APPLICANTS IT WILL NOT BE
WAITED HIGHER THAN OTHER
SECTIONS SIX SEVENTY FOUR AS A
MECHANISM TO ACHIEVE THE BOLD
AND URGENT VISION. WE NEED
CLEAR ACCOUNTABILITY AND PUBLIC
ACCESS TO INFORMATION TODAY I
HAVE MELANIE JAMILA PRASAD FROM
JOBS TO MOVE AMERICA ON THE
WITNESS LYING TO US TO FIND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISPERCEPTION ABOUT TWO TWO
MINUTES YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. ELECTRIC CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS NOW IN THE PROCESS AND
I AM THE CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR
CONSTANCE AMERICA. AND NATIONAL
STRATEGIC RESEARCH AND POLICY
CENTER DEDICATED TO ENSURING
THAT PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE SPENT
IN A WAY THAT MAXIMIZES THE
PUBLIC GOOD. AND TODAY TO VOICE
STRONG SUPPORT SB SIX SEVEN FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DROPPED OUT. THE
CALIFORNIA DOCTRINE IT'S A
SIMPLE POLICY TOOL THAT ALLOWS
CAN MAXIMIZE THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS OF OUR PUBLIC. BY
BEING SMART ABOUT HOW WE
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS YOU CAN BASK
IN CLIENT FACING TRANSPORTATION
OF CREATING GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
CAREER PATHWAY FOR COMMUNITIES.
HIT HARDEST BY THE PAKISTAN.
AND I THINK THE MAIN. BE THE
TRANSFORM POWER OF POLICIES
LIKE ATHLETES SIX SEVEN FOUR
HAVE HAD LOCAL COMMUNITY. BUT
JOBS PLAN IT'S A COMBINATION OF
LEARNING FROM PRUDENT POLICIES
CALLED THE US AN APPOINTMENT.
THAT WAS FIVE HIGHLIGHTED TWO
THOUSAND AND- BY THE LAST
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. I HAVE. BEEN USED BY
AGENCIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING IN NEW YORK CITY
CHICAGO ATLANTA BOSTON AND
MINNEAPOLIS ST PAUL. THREE
THOUSAND JOBS FOR LOCAL. THE
NEW YORK CITY AND PERHAPS WITH
US ON A CONTRACT AWARDED SO
OFTEN THAT WOULD CREATE
THIRTEEN HUNDRED JOBS IN MORE
THAN NINETY CITIES ACROSS THE
US. IN CHICAGO THE CHICAGO
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY HE-
NEEDS THE RECORDS HERE ON A
CONTACT WITH THE RP. A NEW
FACTORY ON THE SOUTH SIDE OF
CHICAGO CREATING OVER TWO
HUNDRED JOBS DURING
CONSTRUCTION. AT LEAST A
HUNDRED SEVENTY JOBS DURING
FULL PRODUCTION. RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ALI METRO UP BY THE
US EPA ON A CONTRACT WITH THE
SHARIA THAT RESULTED IN A NEW
FACTORY LOS ANGELES COUNTY. YOU
SHOULD OF FOUR HUNDRED FOR HIGH
QUALITY JOB. WHEN COMPANIES
MAKE REAL COMMITMENT TO
INVESTING IN COMMUNITY.
COMMUNITIES TRANSFORM. THE
CURRENT SYSTEM OF AWARDING
PUBLIC CONTRACTS INHERENTLY BUT
WARNED THAT AFTER. WHEN PUBLIC
AGENCIES ONLY TAKES THE QUALITY
OF THE PRODUCT AND THE
CONSIDERATION THEY ARE CREATING
A FUNDING SYSTEM WHAT COMPANY
ARE INCENTIVIZED TO CUT WAGES
AND BENEFITS AND OFF SHORE MANY
JOBS AS POSSIBLE MISTER SIDE IF
YOU COULD YOU COULD THINK OF
THEM IF YOU GUYS. WRAP UP THEIR
FINAL COMMENTS APPRECIATED.
YEAH AND ABOUT THAT NO PROBLEM
THE BILL. THANK YOU THAT NOT
ONLY ARE WE MISSING OUT ON THE
REAL. FOR COMPANIES TO INVEST
IN CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY. BUT WE
DON'T KEEP UP THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO TAX DOLLARS ARE BEING TO
FUNDED CONTRACTS ARE THE WAY TO
GET HER. I SIX SEVEN FOUR EIGHT
HOW WE SHIP THIS SPRING MARC
EMERY FOR THE BOTTOM SO RIGHT
TO THE TOP. TODAY I CAN WITH
OVER THIRTY COMMUNITY LABOR AND
EVEN INDUSTRY ORGANIZATIONS AND
ZERO REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
BILL ANYONE IN THE ROOM AND
SUPPORT THE COME ON UP. DON'T
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. IF YOU'RE
A MEMBER OF MY. I THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM. RIGHT
ANYONE THE REMOTEST MY
PHYSICIAN. ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
IN SUPPORT OF YOUR IN SUPPORT
OF S. S. B. IS SIX SEVENTY FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN THEIR FEAR IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIX SEVENTY
FOUR. AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF TWO EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOW COP THAT
WAS SMART TD THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SHEET METAL AIR
RAIL TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWO EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO
EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WE'RE GONNA LINE OF ONE OH
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TEMAS CAL
WITH BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE
OF IT TWO EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE CALIFORNIA THE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
TO A LINE OF TWO EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHANG
NUMBERS KEEP IN BAKER WITH L.
A. COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR
AND TEAMSTERS PORT DIVISION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER THE LINE OF TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THE LINE OF FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE ABOUT
ANY OF THIS. YES I HAD DONE
THAT SORRY A GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS YVONNE NELSON THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY SEVEN
POINT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA LINE OF- FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
SCOTT TURN WITH COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT DIE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE
OF TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I NEED A AT THE NEEDS TO
WHAT THE WAREHOUSE WORKER
RESEARCH CENTER INSTRUCTS THE
PORT OF SB SIX SEVEN FOUR.
THANK YOU. YOUR NEXT OF A LINE
OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND NINETY TWO YEAH I WAS ON
MUTE. ANNEX OVER A LINE OF TWO
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JASMINE
BURGERS I AM SENIOR ORGANIZER
WITH WOODEN WATER WATCH FOOD
AND WATER ACTION. AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AT THE SIX SEVENTY
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF TWO
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES HI- THIS WITH YOU I MEAN WE
THAT MOVED TO LA AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT- SB. SIX SEVEN
ONCE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER LINE OF SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- ROBERT SMITH
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. SIX SEVEN
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF TWO NINETY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CATHERINE GIFTING UNITED
WORKERS THAT TWELVE STRONG
SUPPORT OF FIFTY SIX SEVENTY
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON LET'S SORENSTAM WITH
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND THAT'S THE SIX
SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF TWO
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROWN
GAP THE TEAMSTERS AND UNITE
HERE IN THE PARK THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
TO ROLL LINE OF TWO SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BURST
INTO THE ON BEHALF OF UAW
REGION EIGHT IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NOW FOR THE
SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU- LET'S MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANY FORMAL OPPOSITION
SPEAK WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE ROOM. ANYONE A
THERMAL TESTING STATION. VIOLIN
MEMORY ON THE PHONE OPPOSITION.
TO SIX SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
FOR IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION. OF S.
B. SIX SEVENTY FOUR AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF IT LINE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
ONE SIXTY THREE TICKETS OF ALL
YOU CAN PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
TO GET BACK INTO Q. AMATEUR WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. FOR
MOTIONLESS. THANKS WE ARE
MOTION FROM SEVERAL WARS IN MY
SUMMER RECESS ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. HER WELL
WE DO HAVE THE RECOMMENDATION
IS DO YOU PASSED A
TRANSPORTATION CENTER ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS. THANK YOU
ENOUGH ASPIRO AB THANK YOU-
SURGERY TO GROW ON SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
FLORA. GONZALEZ JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER IRAN'S. REYES AYE
ZERO WARD BY WARD I DOESN'T
SOUTH PARK THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'LL BE DOING- SO THA THE
BILL'S OUT MARKET OF THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SB
SIX IT WOULD BE RESET HONOR SB
SEVEN HUNDRED IS THAT IT WE ARE
ALL RIGHT THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
ON FIVE. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS-
SB SEVEN HUNDRED IS TO ENSURE
MISCLASSIFIED POOR DRIVERS HAVE
ACCESS TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO- AS A LABOR LEADER
I SAW FIRST HAND THE IMPORTANCE
OF UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS TO FAMILIES WHEN A
PARENT LOST THEIR JOB IT IS
OFTEN THE ONLY WAY A FAMILY CAN
KEEP THEIR HOME AND KEEP FOOD
ON THE TABLE IN HARD TIMES. FOR
PORT TRUCK DRIVERS EVEN THIS
MODEST PROTECTION HAS BEEN
DENIED AS A PANDEMIC HIT THE
AMOUNT OF CARGO IN THE PORT TO
DROPPED MANY DRIVERS FOUND
THEMSELVES OUT OF WORK WHEN
THEY APPLIED FOR BENEFITS MANY
WERE DENIED EVEN WORSE SOME
MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS WERE
DEEMED TO BE EMPLOYERS OF OTHER
DRIVERS MAKING THEM LIABLE FOR
UNPAID YOU WHITE TAXES INSTEAD
OF THE MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
COMPANIES PROFITING FROM THEIR
WORK. NOW WE KNOW THAT
COMPANIES USE ALL KINDS OF
ELABORATE SCHEMES TO
MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS
ESPECIALLY IN POOR DRAINAGE THE
LABEL WORKERS AS SEPARATE
BUSINESSES LEASE THEM TRUCKS
AND TELL THEM TO FIND OTHER
WORKERS TO DRIVE BY THE SHIFT
ALL OF THIS IS MEANT TO CREATE
THE ILLUSION OF INDEPENDENCE
WHEN IN REALITY THE WORKERS ARE
UNDER THE COMPLETE CONTROL OF
THE COMPANY- IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF STATE
AGENCIES TO SEE BEYOND EMPLOYER
FRAUD SCHEMES TO PROTECT
VULNERABLE WORKERS WHO ARE
BEING HARMED. THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED HERE DECISIONS DENYING
BENEFITS PROLONG SUFFERING AND
THE ALSO DELAY ACCOUNTABILITY-
FOR THE COOK COMPANIES MOVING
GOODS THROUGH THE PORT THE EDT
DECISIONS ARE BEING OVERTURNED
ON APPEAL BUT WORKERS CANNOT
WAIT THEIR VERY SURVIVAL THE
ABILITY PUT ROOF ON THEIR HEAD
OF FOOD ON THE TABLE DEPENDS ON
TIMELY ACCESS TO BENEFITS WHEN
WORK DRIES UP- MY BILL DIRECTS
THE ADD TO FOLLOW THE LAW IT
DIRECTS THEM TO COMPEL TO
COMPLY. WITH TWO KEY DECISIONS
OF THE CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE APPEALS BOARD THAT
RIGHTFULLY FOUND DRIVERS TO BE
EMPLOYEES AND THE TRUCKING
COMPANY NOT A FELLOW WORKER. TO
BE THE EMPLOYEE WHO MISSED PAY
YOU- I TAXES IT IS NOT ENOUGH
TO SAY WE BY ASIDE WORKER. THE
MATURE THEM THROUGH OUR ACTIONS
THAT'S- ENSURE PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS GET THEIR FAIR ACCESS
TO THE BENEFITS THEY DESERVE.
AND COMPANIES THAT. CHEAT
WORKERS IN THE STATE ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FIVE TWO WITNESSES
TODAY CAITLIN VEGA AND SHINGLES
MONTH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR A CAITLIN VEGA AND
SHANE GUSMAN WHOEVER'S READY TO
BEGIN MAY BEGIN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS INVEGA ON BEHALF OF
SUPPORT DIVISION AT THE
INTERNATIONAL. INVESTORS HOW
COSPONSORED THAT SB SEVEN
HUNDRED. SO WHERE HAS THIS
CLASSIFICATION OF WORKERS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND
MORE PERVASIVE THAN AT OUR PORT.
CORTES THE AGENCIES HAVE
CONTINUALLY FOUND THESE WORKERS
TO BE EMPLOYEES INCLUDING AN
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
CASES BROUGHT BY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR COMMISSIONER. A USA TODAY
EXAMINATION OF CONDITIONS AT
THE PORT THAT THAT IT RESEMBLED
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE. THESE
ARE THE EXACT EMPLOYEES MOST
DESERVING OF PROTECTION FROM
OUR STATE AGENCY. UNFORTUNATELY
EDT HAS CONTINUED TO DELAY AND
DENY DRIVERS APPLICATIONS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE CLEARLY
ENTITLED TO THE BENEFITS BASED
ON THE LONG SERIES OF DECISIONS
FINDING THEM TO BE COMPLETE.
EVEN MORE EGREGIOUS THE EDT
HAVE PURSUED INDIVIDUAL NOT
CLASSIFIED DRIVERS AS THOUGH
THEY ARE EMPLOYERS OF ONE
ANOTHER RATHER THAN TAKING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND UNPAID TAXES
FROM THE TRUCKING COMPANIES.
WERE ACTUALLY RESPONSIBLE.
THESE NEAR. CONTINUE BE
OVERTURNED BY. LOGIC AND BY THE
CALIFORNIA YOU Y. APPEALS BOARD
ALL OF WHICH HAVE FOUND THESE
DRIVERS TO BE EMPLOYEES AND NOT
EMPLOYERS. UNFORTUNATELY THE
EDT HAVE YET TO FOLLOW THE LAW
AND OUTLINED IN THESE DECISIONS.
SB SEVEN HUNDRED A DIFFERENT
BOOK DAHLE THAT DIRECT EDT TO
COMPLY WITH THE REASONING INTO
HAITI WHY APPEAL COURT CASES TO
INSURE WORKERS GET THE BENEFITS
THEY DESERVE. AND COMPANIES
THAT MISCLASSIFIED HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND THEN SHANE GUSMAN MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON XIN GUSTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND
SUPPORT AND PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL. SB SEVEN SEVEN
HUNDRED IS DESIGNED TO ENSURE
THAT EDT DETERMINATIONS WITH
RESPECT TO PORTRAY A DROP
DRAYAGE DRIVERS COMPORT WITH
THE LAW. UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE
A LONG HISTORY OF MIS
CLASSIFICATION THE PORT. EDT
HAS CONTINUED TO GO AFTER
MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS AS IF
THEY ARE EMPLOYEES RATHER THAN
EMPLOYERS RATHER THAN
EMPLOYEES. EVEN AFTER
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE AFTER
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE HAS
HELD THAT DDT HAS IT WRONG AND
EVEN AFTER THEIR OWN YOU AYE
APPEALS BOARD HELD IN FAVOR OF
THESE DRIVERS THEY STILL GO
AFTER THEM. THE RESULT IS HE
DENIED BENEFITS AND PURSUES
MISCLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES FOR
BACK PAYROLL TAXES RATHER THAN
THEIR EMPLOYERS. THIS IS
FINANCIALLY RUINOUS FOR THESE
DRIVERS WHO HAVE ALREADY
SUFFERED YEARS OF EXPLOITATION
FROM PORT TRUCKING COMPANIES
IT'S TIME THAT WE STOP
HARASSING THESE DRIVERS IN
START GOING AFTER SCOFFLAW
LAWYERS AT THE LAW ACTUALLY
REQUIRES WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF SEVEN HUNDRED. AND- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH ON NEXT
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ANYONE.
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE TAKE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THE BILL IN THE ROOM ANYONE
FOR SB SEVEN HUNDRED IF NOT
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND SEEING IF IT
WAS THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. AND THEN- NOT A
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN HUNDRED.
DEAR PARENT SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FEAR IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN HUNDRED. WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF. TWO TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS THIS IS DADDY VERY WELL
AT THE AT W. LESTER STATE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JANEWAY SEAN
POLITICAL VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
STONEWALL DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
OF A LINE OF TWO EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LIVING COSTS THAT WAS
SMART TRANSPORTATION DIVISION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AN EXTRA
LINE OF SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS NAOMI GOLDMAN
VICE PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCACY FOR HEART OF LA
DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN FULL SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN HUNDRED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO THE
LINE OF EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
DISCIPLINE ABOUT THE WITH THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY HEALTH
LOS ANGELES IMAGE FROM SUPPORT
SB SEVEN SEVEN HUNDRED. THANK
YOU. NEXAVAR LINE OF TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON GARY INTRICATE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
LONG BEACH CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU. NEXT OF A LINE OF
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JOINT FLOPPING WITH ST JOHN'S
EPISCOPAL CHURCH. WHO WITH
BROAD SUPPORT SB SEVEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
A LINE OF THREE OH SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHICH GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RON RAPP SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN HUNDRED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AN EXTRA LINE OF TWO
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
JOHN THE LOCALLY FROM THE
NORTHEAST DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF
LOS ANGELES WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL THE BILL SEVEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY
TWO THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO THIRTY GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI CAN YOU SHOP FROM
GARMENT WORKER CENTER- SHOWING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR- SB SEVEN
HUNDRED. THANK YOU. NEXT OF A
LINE OF SEVENTY SIX THEIR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS A WASHABLE.
WITH MEREKA AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS. THANK
YOU. NEXAVAR OF THREE ALL THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CATHERINE
HOUSTON UNITED STEELWORKERS
DISTRICT TWELVE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU BIG. AN EXTRA LINE OF
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HERTZBERG ONE MOMENT ROBERT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROBERT SMITH
BECAUSE I KNOW LIKE TRAITS
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI JESSICA BERMAN AND THE
ALLIANCE FRAN IN THE KANEMI
PROUD CO SPONSOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. THAT
JUST CAME UP. ONE MOMENT WHERE
WE GATHER THEIR LINE NUMBER.
AGAIN WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF- S.
B. SEVEN HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND THAT
LINE WHERE YOU WILL GO TO LINE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
COULD I PLEASE REMEMBER IT CAN
BRING ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND TRANSPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING KILL AT THIS TIME
MISTER CARE. THANK YOU. LEVINE
OPPOSITION THERE NO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR ANYONE OPPOSED.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM. AND YOU
WANT TO REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. I WANT TO SEE THAT
SOMEONE ON THERE'S ONE OF THESE
DAYS AND THEN- ANYWAY THE PHONE.
IN A POSITION. OF SB. SEVEN
HUNDRED. SO HERE IN OPPOSITION-
SB SEVEN HUNDRED YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW ONE ZERO
FOR IN OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION TO QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT AND SO WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WE HAVE A MOTION PLEASE. HI
JORDY THEATER IS JONES SAWYER
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. SO REMAIN CLOSE
THANK YOU ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU BUT I'M SECRETARY
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE MOTION IS
TO PASS THROUGH INSURANCE
COMMITTEE KALRA I KALRA AYE
FLORES GONZALEZ. JONES SAWYER-
JONES SAWYER IRATE IS. THIS IS
ZERO BOARD- WARD I. HI THE DOES
NOT LOOK AT THE ROLE OPEN AND
NOW SB THREE SIX THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- THIS
BILL ENSURES THAT WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES CANNOT BE PAID
LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE. YEAH
DONE THANK YOU. I ASK FOR YOUR-
ALL RIGHT WELL WE DO HAVE-
WITNESSES TO AND SUPPORT
INCLUDING JACKIE ARMSTRONG BY
PHONE AS WELL AS ERIN CARUTHERS
WHOSE IN PERSON SO WHY DON'T WE
GO. MR CROTHERS. IS IT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WILL BE A
MUCH BIGGER OFFERS UP TO TWO
MINUTES PLEASE- JACKIE HAS SUCH
A GREAT STORY TO TELL IF SHE'S
ON THE PHONE WITH. WHATEVER YOU
LIKE TO GO TO JACKIE. JACKIE IF
YOU'RE ALREADY ON THE PHONE ONE
UP TO TWO MINUTES ONCE YOU GO
IN BEGIN. I DO NOT SEE ADD
JACQUI. ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU ARE ON THE PHONE YOU MAY
PRESS STAR ZERO. SO WE CAN OPEN
AIRLINE. SORRY I DID NOT SEE
JACKSON AT THIS TIME SO ONLY A
MISTER BECAUSE ONCE YOU GO AND
AGAIN WE'LL TRY TO TRY TO GET
THE JACK ON THE PHONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS I'M ERIN
CARUTHERS AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE COUNCIL
ON DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WE'RE AN INDEPENDENT STATE
DEPARTMENT THAT EXISTS TO
CREATE POSITIVE LASTING CHANGE
IN THE LIVES OF PEOPLE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THAT'S WHY
WE'RE A CO SPONSOR OF SB SIX
THREE NINE- SENATOR ALSO HAD A
BRIEF BUT VERY COMPELLING CASE
AFTER WHY CALIFORNIA SHOULD IN
THIS EXPLOITATIVE PRACTICE IT
LITERALLY D. VALUES THE LABOR
OF PEOPLE WITH AUTISM PEOPLE
WITH DOWN SYNDROME PEOPLE WITH
CEREBRAL PALSY. THIS IS A LABOR
ISSUE AND THIS IS A CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUE I APPRECIATE
CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN EXPRESSED
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS TO EACH
INDIVIDUAL- WHO'S CURRENTLY IN
ONE OF THESE WORKSHOPS IF THE
BILL PASSES INTERESTINGLY THIS
CONCERN IS OFTEN BEING RAISED
BY PROVIDERS AND PEOPLE WHO
AREN'T CONCERNED ENOUGH TO PAY
MORE THAN TWO DOLLARS AN HOUR
IN SOME CASES. THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA EXISTS. TO WORK
WITH INDIVIDUALS TO FIND THEM
THE BEST RIGHT PLACEMENT. IT'S
IN PLACE THAT'S THE ROLE NOW
AND THAT'S WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
EACH INDIVIDUAL. THE REALLY
GOOD NEWS IS THE GOVERNOR THE
LEGISLATURE TOGETHER HAVE
PROPOSED SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM
INCLUDING A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FROM OUR SERVICE
COORDINATORS. THE ADDITIONALLY
THE MINISTRATIONS PROPOSED NINE
MILLION DOLLARS FOCUSED TO WORK
WITH INDIVIDUALS COMING OUT OF
THE SHELTERED WORKSHOPS. SO
THIS IS THE RIGHT POLICY AT THE
RIGHT TIME WITH THE RIGHT
SUPPORTS TO MAKE IT SUCCESSFUL
PER PEOPLE WHO REALLY DESERVE
BETTER THAN WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING NOW I'M HAPPY TO MAKE
MYSELF AVAILABLE FOR TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS
SIMPLY HAVE JACKIE ARMSTRONG ON
THE PHONE YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY JACQUI
FOR ON THE PHONE. OKAY. HELLO
MY NAME IS JACKIE ARMSTRONG AND
I WORKED AT A SHELTERED
WORKSHOPS FOR SEVEN YEARS- I AM
ON THE AUTISM SPECTRUM SO IT
IT'S NOT. HAVE A DISABILITY BUT
I DO HAVE A DISABILITY NIGHT
GET REGIONAL SERVICES SO- I HE
WORKED AT SEVEN YEAR AND A GOOD
PORTION THE TIME I WAS THERE I
WAS BRITAIN'S- BELOW MINIMUM
WAGE- I WAS IN THE ELECTRO ME
THE PART. AND BECAUSE OF HOW
MUCH I AND- PRECISE I WAS- WHEN
I GOT FROM TO THAT MIGHT PAY
WHY DOWN BECAUSE ALL THE IS HOW
FAT YOUR DO IT- AND THEY ARE-
THERE WERE PEOPLE WITHOUT
DESERVED. THAT FULLY ME- I'M
NOT SURE WHY THEY WOULD BUT
THEY WOULD BOTH ME IN SAYING
REALLY NEED THINGS ME AND SO IT
MAY ME FEEL AS THOUGH ON. THANK
TO A POINT WHERE MY ONLY-
INTERACT WITH KEEP WITHOUT THE
BILL. OTHER THAN MY FAMILY
REPEAT WANT HOW. SO OR PAID
MORE THAN ME SO I GOT TO AYE SO
SHE PEOPLE WITHOUT THIS BILL AT
THE BOTTOM. POSSIBLE POLYSTART
CURRENTLY. SO I BECAME A FOR OF
P. WITHOUT THIS BILL FOR A LONG
IT TO A LONG TO. OVERCOME NOT
SHEER- AND- AT ONE POINT I DID
FOR THIS BECAUSE OF THE BILLING.
BECAUSE THEY PROTECT THE NON.
BALI OVER AND I CERTAIN THE
STATE. JOBS IN THE COMMUNITY
COMPETITORS EMPLOYMENT I WORK
IN AN OFFICE NOW AND- IT IS
COMPETITIVE SO I HAVE A CHANCE
FOR PROMOTION IF I PURSUED
THAT. I ALSO AM VERY HAPPY
THERE- THAT FEAR THAT I HAD OF
PEOPLE WITHOUT DISABILITIES YOU
KNOW POSSIBLY BEING A BULLY AND
JUST WANTING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF ME AND MAKE ME CRY ALL THE
TIME IS NOT THERE ANYMORE
BECAUSE- THERE'S NO ONE LIKE
THAT THERE. AND ALSO- THE
REASON WHY AND OUT. IS BECAUSE
I AM INCREDIBLY VERBAL- I FEEL
LIKE I'M SPEAKING FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT- SO MAYBE DON'T
HAVE THE SAME STRUGGLE TO THOSE
THAT ARE GOING THROUGH THE SAME
THINGS THAT I. MIGHT BE BUT
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO TELL
THEIR SERVICE WORKER THEIR
PARENTS CAN'T BE BULLIED THEIR-
STUFF. SO THANK YOU AND- I.
THINK FOR SB. SIX THREE. THANK
YOU THANKS FOR MINOR US ALL
ONCE AGAIN. SOME DISABILITIES A
PAIR AND IS A- BUT NOT ALL. AND
TO GET SOME FOR ALL TO HAVE
THAT REMINDER- ROUTINELY. OKAY
THANK YOU SO GO ON- PUBLIC
COMMENT AGAINST- YOUR NAME
AFFILIATE OPPOSITE ON THE BILL
IS THERE ANY IN THE ROOM. IN
SUPPORT .COM THE MICHAEL WANTED
TO PLEASE AND KEEP A BIT OF
DOES. GOOD AFTER A NAME IS DE
OPEN US THE CAL. FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING SENT. HERE
IN SOME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RENEE AUTO. ARE THEY ARE WITH
US HE ARE YOU CALLING SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM ALL RIGHT THEN WE'LL GO RA.
TESTER STATION. AND THEN ON THE
NOT A MODERATOR ON THE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SIX THE NINE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB SIX THIRTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
UP TO TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS BY
THE RAILWAYS HE DOES WESTERN
CAPE TOWN AND- THANK YOU. SIX
OF A LINE OF FOUR YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
MITCH WITH THE LABOR FOR ALL
EXPORT THANK YOU. EXTRALITE OF
TUNE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
MY NAME IS CHRIS TOP MARE AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
THE LINE OF NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HM NUMBER CAN
WEIGH IN ON BEHALF THE CAL.
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU.
THANK NEXT OVER LINE OF THREE
YEAR LINE OF OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN FOR CRAIG
ON BEHALF OF THIS AND RIGHT
CALIFORNIA. NO WORKOUT BECAUSE
BY OF THE MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT LINE
SEVENTY YEAR OF THE- THANK YOU
HOME PHONE SO ADVOCATE SAY ON
THE OF THE THOUGHTS OF PROVIDER
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WELL I OF EIGHTY YOU
LINE IS A- YOUR FUTURE MEMBERS
AFTERNOON JAMES THERE WERE
ACTIVE THE CALIFORNIA SPEAKING
LABOR MISTER SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTY HIGH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT OF A LINE OF THREE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS WARNED
OF TO LOOK AT CAPCOM. IN FAR
PROVISIONAL WE ALL. SIX THREE
NINE. WHAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL ALLOW THREE SO YOUR LINE
OPEN. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN WILL ATTEMPT ON BEHALF
OF THE SO AT MINUTES OKAY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OCTOBER
LINE OF EIGHTY TWO YEAR LONG IS
OPEN. MISTER MEMBERS MAY
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEXICO ALAINA TO
THIRTY FOUR YEAR LONG IS OPEN.
ONE TO THIRTY FOUR YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. SIX OF A LINE OF TWO
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JAM PACKED
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT OF A LINE OF
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB
HERTZBERG THINKERS ABOUT LIKE
TRADE STATURE COUNCIL THIRTY
SIX IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND THREE OH THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THREE OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MR CHERRY HAVE
NOW FOR THIS PORTANTINO ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
YOU CAN THE- MOVEON DOBSON OF
FOR HAS WON THIS FOR BILLS WITH
NO OPPOSITION WITNESS RIGHT AS
IMPRESSIVE CENTER- BUT WE TAKE
ON ANY PUBLIC. IN OPPOSITION
ANYONE IN THE ROOM. WELL THIS
ONE I. I'M MIS READ MY NOTES DO
HAVE WE HAVE CALL AND IN ON HE
PRESS AND THEN BALL THE PHONE
BY PHONE. I APOLOGIZE MISTER
LONDON STILL THREE OUT OF FOUR
IS A BEST THERE ALSO. WE WILL
FROM MISTER LONDON AND WITH US
AS UP TWO MINUTES SO PLEASE.
YEAH I THINK YOU MAY CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LONDON HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE.
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH I. D. WE
ARE A STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
OF. COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFITS
THAT SERVE THIS PPULATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M ALSO A PARENT
OF A TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLD- IN
THIS POPULATION AND I'M ALSO A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT IN SACRAMENTO
AND HAVE BEEN FOR TEN YEARS-
UNLIKE. CENTER DRAWS A STEVEN
THIS ISSUE IS NOT A SIMPLICITY
PRESENTS- THE IDEA OF HAVING
EVERY PERSON WHO WORKS. THAT
HAS A DISABILITY- INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITY EARNING
MINIMUM WAGE IS A NOBLE IDEA.
BUT I JUST HANDED OUT TO YOU-
DATA SHEET THAT I WANT TO SHOW
YOU. BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED A LAW. THAT DECLARED THE
TOP HERTIE FOR THIS POPULATION.
THE PRIORITY OF FINDING PEOPLE
DISABILITIES. EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. HERE WE ARE
SEVEN YEARS LATER. WE'RE STILL
AT THE EXACT SAME PLACE IN
TERMS OF EMPLOYING THIS
POPULATION. THIS BILL UNLIKE
WITH CENTER DRAWS A SAID THIS
BILL DOES NOT GUARANTEE.
ANYBODY IN THIS POPULATION THAT
THEY DESCRIBE. AS MAKING
MINIMUM WAGE WHAT I CAN'T TELL
YOU WHAT WE'LL DO. IS WE'LL NOT
TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE. TWELVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS. WHO
CURRENTLY WORK. AND WHO HAVE AN
INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY AND WILL KNOCK HIM
OUT OF THEIR JOB. AND LET ME
REMIND YOU THAT IN THAT
PARTICULAR SYSTEM. THE ONLY WAY
YOU GET TO A SUB MINIMUM WAGE
JOB WHICH IS LEGAL. THROUGH THE
FEDERAL STATUTES. IS BY AS A
PERSON WITH AN INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
DECLARING THAT THAT'S WHERE
YOU'D LIKE TO BE. YOUR REVIEW
THE CHOICES YOU'VE DONE THIS
WITH THE REGIONAL CENTER.
YOU'VE DONE IT WITH COMMUNITY
BASED PROVIDERS. AND THEN YOU
SIGN PAPERS AT THE REGIONAL
CENTER. THAT EXPRESSED. YOUR
CHOICE TO BE IN THAT POSITION.
AND THEN YOU REMAIN VERY SIX
TO SEE WHERE YOUR PRODUCT LEVEL
STANDS IF YOUR PRODUCTIVITY
GOES UP YOUR WAGE GOES UP. IF
YOU'RE A PERSON WHO CAN COMPETE
AT THE FULL LEVEL YOU'LL GET AT
LEAST MINIMUM WAGE OR HIGHER
AND BY THE WAY. IF YOU WERE A
WAREHOUSE WORKER IN SAN
FRANCISCO. AND THE WAGE WAS
FORTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR BUT
ON YOUR PRODUCTIVITY YOU COULD
DO A THIRD. YOU WOULD STILL GET
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR. SO THE
IDEA HERE IS NOT TO EVER PLACE
ANYBODY. AT A BELOW MINIMUM
WAGE LEVEL WHAT IT IS DESIGNED
TO DO IS TO GIVE PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHO WANNA WORK. A
CHANCE TO WORKING GIVEN THE
MARKETING COMPETE. THIS BILL
NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
MINIMUM WAGE OR HIGHER FOR THAT
POPULATION. IT WILL PUT TWELVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S VIçT D.
OUT OF WORK. AND WHAT WE WOULD
URGE THAT YOU CONSIDER.
EVERYTHING IN THIS BILL. AND
MOVE IT FORWARD EXCEPT FOR THE
TERMINATION DATE OF THE
PROGRAM'S. LET THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
DEVELOP THE POLICIES ARE GOING
TO DEVELOP. TELL YOU HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO FUND IT. IN
THE ADMINISTRATION. AND COME
BACK TO THAT PROPOSAL WHICH IS
CONTAINED IN THE BILL. BUT
DON'T KNOCK THESE PEOPLE OUT OF
WORK UNNECESSARILY. WITH AN
EARLY AND PREMATURE- DATE. THAT
CANNOT BE FULFILLED UNTIL WE
KNOW WHAT THOSE ANSWERS ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
ON THE PHONE WE ALSO HAVE JOHN
BULL. I DO NOT SEE JOHN BUT
JOHN IF YOU WERE ON THE LINE
YOU MAY PRESS- STAR. ZERO YOU
WERE ONLINE FOR STARS. ZERO I
DO NOT HAVE JOHN ON THE LINE
WELL THE GO AHEAD AND GO TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT- IN OPPOSITION
OF JOHN JUMPS ON THE NORMAL
GIVEN UP TO TWO MINUTES AS A
WITNESS. SO ANYONE IN THE ROOM
IN OPPOSITION TO- SB SIX THIRTY
NINE. IF NOT. WE WILL GO TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. AND
THEN- MATTER MODERATOR ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION- TWO SB. SIX
THIRTY NINE. IF THEY'RE NOT
POSITION OF SB SIX THIRTY NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO IF YOU
WERE IN OPPOSITION. OF S. B.
SIX THIRTY NINE AND ONE MOMENT
WE DO HAVE ONE Q. AND WE'RE
AGAIN IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
THIRTY NINE. AND WE WILL VOTE
SO LINE OF THREE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
AMANDA RENDON I'M A PROGRAM
COORDINATOR WITH ACHIEVEMENT
HOW FORTY AGENCY THAT PROVIDES
SERVICES LIKE THE FOURTEEN THE
CERTIFICATE TO THOSE WITH DD.
AND I- WERE IN OPPOSITION OF
LEAST THREE NINE COULD BLOW
WHAT LAW FAD- IT ONLY. CHOICES
FOR PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE WHILE
ALSO A- NOT OF P. OUT OF WORK.
IT IS. THE TWO YEAR OUT PLAN WE
THINK WE DON'T THINK IT'S
ENOUGH. TO OUR INTRODUCED
PROGRAMS ALL WE ARE A LOT WITH
THE IDEA THAT SHOULD EARN WAGE.
TWO AND A HALF SIMPLY AS ENOUGH
TIME TO DEVELOPING PRO CAPTURE.
THE THOUSANDS OF IN THE- WHO
ARE CURRENTLY. SERVED BY. FEET
PRO. THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE'LL
TAKE THAT AS THE HUBS SHOWING.
AND AN COME TO I DON'T LOSING
ELSE THINK ABOUT MONEY. THIS
CORRECT THANK YOU FIFTY. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH WILL BRING UP.
TO THE COMMITTEE. I BELIEVE
IT'S AN EMOTIONAL ONES WE HAD
ONE RIGHT RIGHT AWAY WE HAD ONE
I YES SOME GONZALEZ. I AM SO-
SENATOR FOR YOU BRINGING THIS.
I AS YOU KNOW THINK WE JUST-
MAYBE MY FIRST YEAR EIGHT I A
RISE. ON SIMPLY THE GOVERNMENT
TO GET RID OF THE PROGRAM. AND
DESPITE GET THROUGH THE- AT
IMPAIR- ANY ACTIVE HUBER AT. AT
OF. INDIVIDUAL JUST IT WOULD BE
A THAT DIED THE BIGGEST ON THE
SENATE- AND IN WHO TESTED TODAY
SO- YOU KNOW PERHAPS THE
RESOLUTION WOULD HAVE BEEN A
WAY TO START THE PROCESS. EIGHT
YEARS AGO- BUT UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE HAVING DISCUSS ABOUT THE
LONG OF PRO. WHITE WAS CREE THE
OF HUMAN DIGNITY AND WHAT IT
SAYS ABOUT HUMAN DIGNITY AND
THE FACT THAT IF WE VALUE WORK
IN IN AN ECONOMY WHERE WE'RE
TOLD THAT THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
WORKERS. THAT THERE AREN'T
ENOUGH PEOPLE WILLING TO TAKE A
MINIMUM WAGE JOB PERHAPS THEN
WE SHOULD AT LEAST PAY
EVERYBODY MINIMUM WAGE SO I
VALUE ANY WORK THAT ANY
INDIVIDUAL DOES AND I THINK
THAT WE HAVE A MINIMUM WAGE SO
THAT EVERY INDIVIDUAL. CAN
UTILIZE THAT SO THANK YOU FOR
DO I THINK THIS IS- A CIVIL
RIGHTS AND- ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN
NEGLECTED FOR FAR TOO LONG.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENT NO
QUESTION. OKAY WELL YES PLEASE.
SOME WHEN I LOOK THROUGH- THE
BILL UNDER THE THAT IS I TO
FELT THAT THE WAS SOMETHING
THAT- WAS LONG OVER. BUT I HAVE
TO TELL YOU THE ARE LISTENING
TO THE TEST OF MISTER LONDON I
DO BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT. THE FACT THAT
HE HAS THIS HISTORY. IT ISN'T
AS THOUGH HE'S JUST COMING IN
AND SPEAKING ABOUT SOMETHING HE
HAS NO EXPERIENCE ABOUT- NO
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT. IT HE'S HE'S
LIVED WITH THAT WITH HIS CHILD
ALSO I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAS VALUE TO ME.
AND I THINK THAT- THE COMMENT
FROM THE OTHER. WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION ABOUT THE PERIOD OF
TIME. TO TRANSITION. THE LAST
THING I WANT IS FOR PEOPLE TO
LOSE THEIR JOBS AND TO LOSE THE
OPPORTUNITIES. BUT I DO WANT
THEM TO BE PAID AT LEAST
MINIMUM WAGE. SO I JUST THOUGHT
I'D KNOW THAT. AT EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY YOU YOU WORK WITH
OPPOSITION AND TRYING TO FIND.
THE BEST WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IN THE END IT IS A PROGRAM THAT
WILL BE EFFECTIVE ON THE DATE
THAT WE SAY THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE EFFECTIVE. AND THAT WOULD BE
MY ONLY COMMENT ON THIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF ANY
OTHER COMMENT- IF NOT. THIS. SB
SIX OR NINE AT THE HAVE WRECKED
TO PASS A Q. SERVICE. SO
SENATOR YOU LIKE TO. YES I DO
WANT TO- ADDRESSES AND IP-
CENTER ON YOU- YOUR REMARKS
ABOUT THE PERSONAL CONNECTION
THAT- OF MANY INDIVIDUALS HAVE-
HAVING SOMEONE IN THEIR OWN
FAMILY. BUT I DO THINK THAT WE
NEED TO REMIND OURSELVES THAT
THIS IS A RELIC OF THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES THIS STATES BACK TO A
TIME WHEN CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES WERE DENIED
EDUCATION BEFORE CIVIL RIGHTS
THAT LEGISLATION SUCH AS
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY ACT
AND END UP BEFORE THE FULL
HUMANITY OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES WAS. WAS
RECOGNIZED CALIFORNIA'S GONNA
JOIN ALASKA CONNECTICUT
MARYLAND NEW HAMPSHIRE NEW YORK
RHODE ISLAND TEXAS AND
WASHINGTON. IN PROHIBITING IS A
MINIMUM A SUB MINIMUM WAGE-
EMPLOYMENT ON. WE DID IN
TALKING TO THE CONCERN OF OR-
DID X. THE TIME FOR ANOTHER FOR
THREE YEARS THAT WAS A CHANGE
WE MADE BUT THERE IS- AS MR
CROWTHER'S US SPOKE ABOUT
EARLIER. THERE IS A LOT OF
MONEY THAT THE STATE IN OUR
BUDGET IS INCLUDING WHAT ARE
NEEDED ARE UP FOR SERVICES- TO
ASSIST THESE INDIVIDUALS- BUT
THE FACT OF THEM WORKINGAND
HAVING DISABILITY DOES NOT MEAN
THEY SHOULD NOT. BE PAID THE
MINIMUM WAGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WE ARE ABLE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER YES YOU'RE POINTINGTO
THE TENTH STATE SO WE'RE NOT
EXACTLY ENTRY ON. TERRITORY
HERE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT A MADAM SECRETARY IF WE
COULD PLEASE TAKE ROLL ON SB
SIX THIRTY NINE. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
FLORA GONZALEZ. RIGHT GONZALEZ
I JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER I
REYES. REYES ICE. ZERO OUR. THE
BILL SO ALL RIGHT WHO'S UP
THANK YOU SO MUCH ILLINOIS
ENJOY THE REST ENJOY THE YOUR
UP. AND WE UP FOR FILE ITEM
ONE. AS B. C. TWENTY CENTER AL
THANK YOU SO AND ARE YOU TO
YOUR HEAD AND BUS AND DRIVE I
GOT SHE TEACHES SOMEONE ALREADY
THREE WITH. THE GOAL STATES
THAT. HAS A CREATIVE ECONOMY
THAT'S- TO THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS IT'S LARGER THAN THE
WORLD- BUT AS WE KNOW KOBE
BROUGHT MUCH OF IT TO A
STANDSTILL. AND SOMETHING LIKE
96% OF CREATIVE WORKERS OF LOS
REVENUE OR EMPLOYMENT AND FOR
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. SO OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
HOPING TO GET THE SECTOR BACK
UP AND RUNNING. I'M BUT BUT
WE'RE ALSO AND INSPIRED BY.
SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT TOOK
PLACE IN THE WORKS PROGRESS
ADMINISTRATION. DURING THE
GREAT DEPRESSION WHERE. THEY
CREATED PROGRAMS FOR ARTISTS.
AND AND THIS IS A BILL THAT
COMES OUT OF THAT THAT IDEA
THAT WE WOULD WE WOULD DIRECT
THE CALIFORNIA WERE FIRST OF
ALL IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL TO ESTABLISH AND EARN
AND LEARN PROGRAM. IN
CONSULTATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COMMUNITY
NONPROFITS SIMPLY CREATIVE
WORKERS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND- THE IDEAS WE WOULD HAVE A
TRAINING PROGRAM FOCUSED ON
DEVELOPING MARKETABLE SKILLS IN
THE ARTS WHICH WOULD PRIORITIZE
LOW INCOME UNEMPLOYED
DISADVANTAGED PERSONS.
BEGINNING THEIR CAREERS IN THE
CREATIVE ARTS ARE THE BILL AS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE SENATE. YESTERDAY AS WELL
IN THE ASSEMBLY ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT COMMITTEE IT'S
BROAD SUPPORT FROM CREATIVE
INDUSTRY WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS
ACROSS THE STATE. IN HERE WITH
ME TESTIFIED SUPPORT OUR- JULIE
BAKER FROM CALIFORNIA ARTS
ADVOCATES AND ALSO CONGRESS
THAT WHAT IT AYE FROM THE ARTS
RALLY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR ALAN AND SO EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES TO TESTIFY THEY'RE BOTH
WITH US BY PHONE SO JULIE BAKER
AND THN FOLLOWED BY. SHE BAKER
THE FOLLOWED BY GUSTAVO
AGUIRRE. SHOULD OKAY THANK YOU
CHAIR KALRA MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JULIE
BAKER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES. AN
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CREATE WORKERS AND A TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY DOLLARS BILLION.
INDUSTRY TO CALIFORNIA OVER 80%
OF THE STATE'S GDP A LARGER
SHARE THAN CONSTRUCTION OR
TRANSPORTATION. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT THE BILL CALIFORNIA OUR
TOPIC IT IS PROUD TO SPONSOR.
AND MANY THANKS TO SENATOR ALAN
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE
SHOVING THE TOOK PLACE
RECOVERING CALIFORNIA WE NEED
OUR ARTISTIC CULTURAL BARRIERS
TO HELP US MAKE MEETING OF WHAT
JUST HAPPENED. TO TELL THE
STORIES IN WAYS THAT HELP US TO
UNDERSTAND THE TO BRING US
TOGETHER INTERNET WELLNESS AND
HEALING. WE ALSO NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE ARTIST'S WORK IS
LABOR AND IT TAKES A RIGOROUS
DISCIPLINE AND TRAINING THAT
THEIR WORK THEIR TALENT TO BE
STORYTELLERS COMMUNICATORS
DELIVERING HOPE. SOCIAL
COHESION AND ECONOMIC VITALITY
OF VALUE AND FOR THAT CAN
CONTRIBUTION IN ORDER SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO START. BUT INSTEAD
BE PAID A LIVING WAGE WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME IN FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CREATIVE INDUSTRY FUTURE WE
HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO ENTER. INTO
A WORKFORCE TO PROVIDE ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL BENEFITS EVERY
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
MUST ADDRESS THE RACIAL
INEQUITIES IN A CREATIVE
WORKFORCE PROVIDE. LITTLE
ORANGE SB SIX TWENTY IS A GAME
CHANGER THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
IN THE NATION TO RECOGNIZE
ARTISTS. CENTRAL LABOR FORCE
AND PROVIDED INFRASTRUCTURE TO
ENSURE COMMUNITY BASED HYPER
LOCAL JOB CREATION AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FOR THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON COMMUNITIES. THAT
BATES PREVIOUS BARRIERS TO
INCLUSION WE APPLAUD THE
VISIONARY LEGISLATION AND HOPE
YOU'LL JOIN US FOR INSURANCE
PASSAGE. THIS WEEK CENTER CAME
EXECUTIVE ACTORS HAVE ANNOUNCED
PLANS UNDER RIGHT A NEW HIGH
SCHOOL LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. IT'LL BE A
MAGNET SCHOOL IN DIVERSIFYING
THE PIPELINE OF
CINEMATOGRAPHERS VISUAL EFFECTS
ARTISTS AND OTHER WORKERS IN
THE CITY'S MOST FAMOUS JOB
SECTOR. HOWEVER WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
OUT OF SCHOOL FOR THE STUDENTS
AND FOR ADULTS RE ENTERING THE
WORKFORCE. WHICH MAY NOT
INCLUDE AN OPTION FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION BUT INSTEAD OF
EARNING LEARN OPPORTUNITIES
SUCH AS INTRODUCED IN SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. NOW THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO RE. OPEN THE ARE TOO
MUCH TO FAST WE LEARN LAST
SIXTEEN MONTHS. THE REALITY THE
ART OF CREATIVE ARE. ARE MY OUR
MOST VULNERABLE WORK FOR. BUT
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT AND UNDER
FUNDING IT MOST. AND ESPECIALLY
TRUE FOR BLACK INDIGENOUS THE
PEOPLE COLOR CREE. SB SIX
TWENTY CALIFORNIA CREATED WORK.
HOW NOTHING TO DRAFTING IN
EQUITY AND BILL A BETTER MORE
JUST THAT THE FACEBOOK. WORK
FOR ARE CAL. WHAT ON GOING
RESEARCH. FOR THE ARTS. IMPACT
COVER NINETY INSTANCE. SIXTY
THREE PER OF THE CREATOR
WORKERS WERE. AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY. FIFTH PERCENT OF
GREATER. OF THE IS NOT TO WATER
DRINKING WATCHING. WHAT I'M
TRYING TO CREATE A- TO
EXPERIENCE HOME. TO OVER
PERCENT OF CREATIVE WORKERS
HAVE EXPERIENCE STUDENTS. AND
55% OF ALL CREATIVE WORKERS
HAVE NO SAVINGS TO FALL BACK ON
AND ACCORDING TO COMMISSION
BEING COMPANY. A FULL RECOVERY
FOR THE SECTOR IS NOT EXPECTED
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. QUID
WORKERS ARE SUFFERING FROM A
LACK OF THE MOST BASIC HUMAN
NEEDS RIGHT NOW CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS FULLY ONE QUARTER OF
THE NATION'S ARTS AND CREATIVE
ECONOMY. WE CAN DO BETTER WE
MUST SB SIX TWENTY THE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIECTION. SIMPLY PUT
THERE'S NO CALIFORNIA COVERED
WITHOUT CREATIVE INDUSTRY. I'M
SURE RETURN OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
I JOB TO CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS
CREATING A PIPELINE OF WORKERS
WITH LIVING WAGES IN
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NONPROFITS UNIONS
AND CREATIVE BUSINESS. AND THE
EXPERTISE OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD IN THE
RECOVERING COMMITMENTS THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES WORK FORCE.
ARE DIFFICULT TO VERIFY FORMA
SENT TO WORK FOR THE PUBLIC
REDDING CALIFORNIA PROTECTING
NURTURING AND STRENGTHENING
SOCIAL FABRIC TO BENEFIT
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. WE HELP ASSEMBLY
LABOR COMMITTEE GLOBAL SUPPORT
OF SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT HOW
CALIFORNIA COULD NOT JUST
RECOVER FROM THE IMPACT OF THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. BUT
EMERGENCY CELEBRATION OF
CULTURAL EQUITY AND THE
RECOGNITION AND INVESTMENT
RESPONSE CALIFORNIA. EMPLOYEES
THAT YOU CAN PLEASE. WRAP UP.
VIEW HIS ROUGHLY IN. NATURE OF
ART CIRCUIT THE CREATIVE. YEAH
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATED AGAINST OUR ERA.
HELLO YOU HEAR ME YEAH. OKAY
YOUR CALL RIGHT NOW OF THE CA
HI MY NAME IS ADVANTA AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE OF CRAFTS WE
REPRESENT SEVEN THOUSAND ART
THAT THEY GET PAID ANGELES AND
ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
ARTS AND CULTURE ORGANIZATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX TO EIGHT I WHICH IS THE
BILL THAT ARTS BALLET IS PROUD
TO SPONSOR SB SIX TO WAITED
LONG OVERDUE AND WE APPRECIATE
SENATOR ALEX LEADERSHIP IN YOUR
PRIORITIZE THE SENATE THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TODAY. ASSEMBLY
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM THE KIND OF TO
SALVADORAN IMMIGRANTS. I GREW
UP IN LONG HOUSING AND SILVER
LAKE AND NEIGHBORHOOD IN EAST
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES. GROWING UP
A CREATIVE CAREER WAS NEVER
DISCUSSED THAT THE POTENTIAL
CAREER IN MY HOUSEHOLD. IN ART
EDUCATION WITHOUT PROPER AT
SCHOOL. I CAN TELL YOU THIS
BILL THE REALITY FOR MILLIONS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WERE BURSTING
WITH CREATIVITY. AND GROWING UP
IN LOW INCOME UNDER RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES TODAY. AT A TIME
THAT DEVASTATING JOB LOSSES IN
THE SECTOR. WE MUST EXPAND
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS
THE CREATIVE SPECTRUM IN A WAY
THAT BENEFITS THE ECONOMY AND
THE CULTURE OF CALIFORNIA.
CRISES CAN WORSEN PRE EXISTING
STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES. SB SIX
TO EIGHT THAT THE STEP TOWARDS
ENSURING I TRUST RECOVERY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW THAT
ONE IN SIX JOBS IN LA REGION
ARE IN THE CREATIVE ECONOMY. IN
TWENTY TWENTY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS WERE LOCKED
YOU IN LA. BUT THE DEVASTATION
WOULD NOT EQUAL BE EXPERIENCED
AS AN EXAMPLE WE KNOW BLACK
ARTS WORKERS EXPERIENCE JOB
LOTS. AND LOTS OF INCOME AT
DISPROPORTIONATE LEVELS.
COMPARED TO OTHER COULD EITHER
BRING. FEDERAL BELIEVE HAVE
ALIVE FOR AND- INCLUDING.
RELIEF BUT WE KNOW BY FORGET A
STUDENT WORKER WORK AT. AT
LEVELS. SB SIX TO EIGHT
INSURERS THAT WE CAN PRIORITIZE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO CREATIVE
SECTOR JOBS TO OFFER BURN AND
LEARN TRAINING TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. AND PRIORITIZE THE
LIVING WAGE TO BREAK THE CYCLE
OF INEQUITY FOR SO MANY. BILL
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA TO WRITE
STRONGER FROM THE IMPACT OF
COBIT NINETEEN AND OPERATE JUST
RECOVERY TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OF THIS GO
HEAD TO HEAR PUBLIC COMMENTS
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THE BILL ANYONE IN THE ROOM.
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. WILL MOVE ON TO THE ROAD
TEST TWENTY STATION. AND THEN
MADAM MODERATOR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. YES IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE OF THEIR
APPEARANCE SUPPORT. I WOULD GO
TO A LINE OF EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON OUT YOUR CALLIN
MEMBERS COMMITTEE KATHY LYNCH
REPRESENTING THAT CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR ARTS EDUCATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS NATURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT TO A
LINE OF FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI JANE WITH SEAN
POLITICAL VICE PRESIDENT TO
STONEWALL DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE
LINE OF EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
HEARING EXPECTING THE SUPPORT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF MEDIUM THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE OF TWO EIGHTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CAREY
MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF
THAT GAP TRANSPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS HAVE A LINE
OF NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS
MISSY JOHNSON WITH NIELSEN
WORKS NOT CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE DIRECTORS GUILD OF AMERICA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
DESIGNED TO NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE TO NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JOHN BELITTLING FROM
THE NORTHEAST DEMOCRATIC CLUB
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF TWO THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS ALMA ROBINSON CALLING.
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
FOR THE ARTS. STRONG SUPPORTER
SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT AM THANK
SENATOR ALAN MORE CONTACT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN CUBA AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH I AM NOW WILL
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION THERE ARE
NO OPPOSITION WITNESSES. PUBLIC
COMMENT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE REMOTE TEST
MY STATION AND THEN. BUT A
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN OPPOSITION SB. SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. GIVEN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MISTER. THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK. TO BE A MOTIONLESS. RIVER
MOTION A SECOND SERVICE. THANK
YOU SURE I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR ALLEN FOR BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I WANTED TO
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE SAMPOERNA
DINO SYMPHONY ORCHESTRA MMHM
WHO SENT A LETTER- SPREAD
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATOR
ALLEN'S BILL- AND IN THIS
LETTER THEY REMIND US THAT
CALIFORNIA. SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR. CREATIVE
ECONOMY IS THE LARGEST IN THE
WORLD. AND REMINDING US THAT
COVERT NINETEEN HAS BROUGHT
MUCH OF IT TO A STANDSTILL WITH
PERMISSION TO READ- ASSESSOR
PLEASE. COME FROM THE LETTER
THEY SAY CREATIVE INDUSTRIES
ARE INTEGRAL TO THE RECOVERY
REBUILDING AND HEALING OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR OVER NINETY
YEARS A SYMPHONY HAS ACTUALIZED
NUMEROUS PROJECTS THAT HE'LL
OUR COMMUNITY DRIVE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING IMPROVE
CULTURAL COMPETENCY AND
COHESION ADDRESS TRAUMA AND
INSPIRE NEW WAYS OF THINKING. I
AGAIN I THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
BRINGING YOUR BILL FORWARD AND
IN HONOR OF THE STAMINA DINO
SYMPHONY ORCHESTRA THE OTHER
CREATIVE ORGANIZATIONS IN MY
DISTRICT I. URGE ARE MY NUMBER
THE MEMBERS TO VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH YES AND
HOW TO SECOND THAT I'VE ALSO
HEARD THERE'S A LOT OF BUZZ IN
THE ARTS COMMUNITY IN SAN JOSE
VERY HAPPY ABOUT THIS
LEGISLATION AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING UP FOR SENATOR ALAN.
ACTUALLY BECAUSE YEAH I'M SO
HAPPY TO HAVE SUCH A WIDE RANGE
OF ARTS ORGANIZATIONS AND ALSO
LABOR PARTNER SAG AFTRA DGA
IOTTIE ACTORS LIKELY ALL
SUPPORT OF THE BILL- LOTS OF
THEATERS MUSIC SCHOOLS THE LA
PHIL- BUT ALSO- CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA SO IT'S A IT'S A
GREAT GREATER RANGE OF GROUPS
IS ALL ABOUT. TRYING TO CREATE
MORE MORE AND- MORE AVENUES FOR
ADVANCEMENT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AN DISADVANTAGED PEOPLE IN THE
ARTS IT'S AN IMMENSELY
IMPORTANT PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
HERITAGE AND- I AM A PROFESSOR
ABOUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER. OF MADAM SECRETARY
COULD BE TAKE THE WRONG SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH PROCREATION KALRA. HI
KALRA HI FLORA GONZALEZ. FIVE
DOLLARS I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I RARE FINE REYES SIZE
ZERO. WARD WARD HI HI THE
BILL'S UP THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU. FOR THAT'S GIVES IS
WITH THE. I NEVER. THE BILLS
ARE BASICALLY THINK. IN THIS
COME IN COMMITTEE ONE BECAUSE
OF OUR DOESN'T. OKAY NOW I'M
GONNA YOU'RE GONNA AS WE HAVE
WITH THE START BECAUSE IS GOING
TO GET TO YOU WANT TO GO DOWN
THAT ROAD. AS SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT- AND YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO PROTECT
THE CENTRAL FRONT LINE TRUCK
DRIVERS AT CALIFORNIA'S PORTS.
FOR TRUCK DRIVERS HAVE BEEN
NOTORIOUSLY EXPLOITED BY BAD
ACTORS IN THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY. IS THAT ACTORS
ROUTINELY MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS
TO CUT COSTS WRONGFULLY EXCLUDE
WORKERS FOR MINIMUM WAGE.
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND THE
RIGHT TO JOIN A UNION. THIS
ADDRESSES THIS ONGOING PROBLEM
BY ADDING TRUCKING COMPANIES IN
EXISTING JOINT LIABILITY BAD
ACTOR LIST IF THOSE COMPANIES
ROUTINELY MISCLASSIFIED.
WORKERS OR FAILED TO ADDRESS
SERIOUS CAL OSHA VIOLATIONS. SB
THREE THIRTY EIGHT ALSO HOLDS
THE MOST EGREGIOUS BAD ACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE. BY LOWERING THE
THRESHOLD TO GET PUT ON THE BAD
ACTOR LIST FOR PRIOR OFFENDERS.
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN FOUND TO
HAVE MISCLASSIFIED THEIR
WORKERS. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION. TO REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION BY NEARING THE BILL
SO THAT IT FOCUSES ONLY ON THE
WORST ACTORS AND LEVELS THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR GOOD TRUCKING
COMPANIES. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE SEEN
GUSMAN. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL AND CAITLIN VEGA FROM.
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF TEAMSTERS PORT DIVISION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER OF THE OCEAN DOESN'T
FALL BY CAITLIN VEGA SHAME
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY- YOU MAY
BEGIN. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SHANE GOT SPENT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL. IN SUPPORT AND PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL. FOR US
THE POINT OF THIS BILL IS TO
ADDRESS THE LONG HISTORY OF
DRIVER MISS CLASSIFICATION.
THAT HAS OCCURRED IN THE
TRUCKING INDUSTRY EVER SINCE IT
WAS THE REGULATED FOR DECADES
AGO. NO WHERE IS THE EVIDENCE
OF THIS PROBLEM GREATER THAN
OUR LARGEST PORTS. THEIR
EXPLOITATION IS THE DOMINANT
ECONOMIC MODEL. TRUCKING
COMPANIES HIRE A WORKFORCE OF
MOSTLY IMMIGRANT DRIVERS WERE
FORCED TO ACT AS IF THEY ARE IN
BUSINESS FOR THEMSELVES
RESPONSIBLE FOR PURCHASING OR
LEASING THEIR OWN TRUCKS.
PAYING FOR ALL THE FUEL AND
MAINTENANCE ALL THE WHILE
ACCEPTING AN EXTREMELY LOW NON
NEGOTIABLE RIGHT. IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON TO HAVE MONTHS WHERE
THE COST OF MAINTAINING THE
TRUCK IS ACTUALLY MORE THAN THE
DRIVER MAKES. ON TOP OF THIS
THE DRIVERS GET NO HEALTH CARE
NO MINIMUM WAGE NO OVERTIME NO
WORKERS COMP INJURIES ON THE
JOB NO PAID SICK DAYS AND
ABSOLUTELY NO PROTECTIONS
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THIS IS
NOT HYPERBOLE. THESE ARE THE
FACTS ON THE GROUND HUNDREDS OF
COMPLAINTS LABOR COMMISSIONER
INVESTIGATIONS AND LAWSUITS
HAVE BEEN UNIVERSALLY CONCLUDED
WITH FINDINGS THAT THE PORT
DRAYAGE DRIVERS ARE IN FACT
MISCLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
COUNTLESS NEWS ARTICLES HAVE
CHRONICLED THIS PROBLEM FOR
MANY YEARS NONETHELESS THE
PROBLEM PERSISTS. THE TEAMSTERS
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND OTHERS
HAVE TRIED TO HELP THESE
DRIVERS UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY
THEY ARE MISCLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. HAS
MADE IT VERY VERY DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO ACT COLLECTIVELY. ON
FOUR YEARS AGO WE REALIZE THAT
THE REAL WAY TO TACKLE THIS
PROBLEM IS TO GET AT THE ROOT
OF IT THE GIANT COMPANIES THAT
BENEFIT FROM THE SYSTEM NEED TO
TAKE SOME RESPONSIBILITY. WE
SPONSORED SB FORTINO TO LARA
WHICH PROVIDES FOR JOINT
LIABILITY OF THE COMPANY HIRES
ONE OF THESE BAD ACTORS
TRUCKING FIRMS TO SHIP ITS
GOODS. HOWEVER THERE ARE TOO
MANY LOOPHOLES. IN THIS LAW AND
LEFT IT INEFFECTIVENESS
INEFFECTIVE AT ACHIEVING THIS
GOAL. WE NEED SB THREE THREE
EIGHT. BUILDINGS AND MAKE SURE
EXPLOITATION ENDS ONCE AND FOR
ALL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH- CAITLYN VEGAS WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER KEEPING DATA ON
BEHALF OF SUPPORT DIVISION AT
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF TEAMSTERS. HOUSE CO SPONSORS
SB THREE THREE EIGHT. MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE IMPORTANCE OF
LAWS THAT ALLOW FOR AT THE
CHAIN MY ABILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THE CORPORATIONS THAT ARE
PROFITING FROM THE EXPLOITATION
OF WORKERS AND THE
CLASSIFICATION OF WORKERS. ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND HAVE AS
BUSINESS REASON TO ENSURE THAT
THEY USE RESPONSIBLE
CONTRACTORS RATHER THAN DRIVING
A RACE TO THE BOTTOM. SB THREE
THREE EIGHT MAKE SEVERAL
CHANGES TO SB FORTINO TO- TO
STRENGTHEN THAT LAW AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE REAL BAD ACTORS
IN THE INDUSTRY ARE CAPTURED
AND HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO BEGIN
WITH ADTOKEN SAFETY VIOLATIONS
WE SAW WIDESPREAD VIOLATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE CODE THE
PANDEMIC. DRIVERS NOT BEING
PROVIDED PPE- GUARANTEEING
EXPOSED TO COPE WITH ON THE JOB
SO SERIOUS POLISH AND IRISH AND
OUR ATTITUDE THAT- CRITERIA IT
ALSO CRETES A CATEGORY FOR
PRIOR OFFENDERS BECAUSE WE KNOW
WHEN IT'S INDUSTRY MANY MANY OF
THESE COMPANIES HAVE ALWAYS HAD
A BUSINESS. MODEL ETHNIC
CLASSIFICATION. AND I PRIOR AT
THE END. SHOULD BE. TREATED
MORE. SINCE STATE CONTINUE TO
BE A BAD. I'M GLAD IT REQUIRE
THAT THE COMPANY'S ACTUALLY
SHOW. B. I. ART THAT THEY HAVE
STOPPED MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS
BEFORE THEY GET REMOVED FROM
THE LIST. UNTIL IT OUT OF THOSE
THREE IMPORTANT PROTECTION BUT
ON EACH OF THEM WOULD HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS WE
CAN NARROW THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS TO INCLUDE
ONLY. HELLO CHAU VIOLATION WE
HAVE ADDRESSED- THE ISSUES
THEY'VE RAISED AROUND DUE
PROCESS IN DEFINING WHO IS A
PRIOR OFFENDER AND WE HAVE
REMOVED THE AUDIT REQUIREMENT.
AND TO ENSURE THAT COMPANIES
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS WHILE THE DEALER FEE OR
THE P. I. R. CONDUCT AN AUDIT
THEY SIMPLY HAVE TO PROVIDE.
THE INFORMATION SUFFICIENT TO
SHOW THAT THEY ARE NO LONGER
MATH CLASSIFIED WE ASK YOU TO
GIVE US THE TOOLS TO
EFFECTIVELY ENFORCEMENT
CLASSIFICATIONS IN THE INDUSTRY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WILL NOW GO ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT I CAN JUST TAKE
YOUR NAME. AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THE BILL WE'LL START WITH
ANYONE IN THE ROOM MS COMMITTEE
TO MICROPHONE THANK THANK YOU
RENEE BAYARDO WITH THIS YEAR
YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK.
YOU NAY. I ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM. GOING WILL GO ON TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY TO. AS MADAM
MODERATOR IS ON THE SB. THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
CURED SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE
THREE EIGHT. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU- AND GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN JANE WITH SEAN
STUMBLED DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND LINE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND ONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BERMAN WAS
SUFFICIENT. THANK YOU. AN
EXTROVERT SO LINE OF FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS OF A LINE OF
THREE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MATT CLEMENCY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OPERATING ENGINEERS
HAPPY BEARD INSTRUCTS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS AT
THE RUSSIAN POLO WITH KHAKIS
AMERICA AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ALAINA TO TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS THAT THE GRANT WHILE
THE G. S. C. W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SIX OF A LINE OF THREE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THANK
YOU NAOMI GOLDMAN VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCACY FOR HEART OF LA
DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT OF A LINE OF
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB
HERTZBERG PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY
SIX IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. TEXACO ON A
TWO NINETEEN YEAR LINES OPEN.
JOHN GLOBALLY COULD NOT BECOME
A CREDIT CLUB OF LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. A LINE
AT THREE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SHRIMPTON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RON RAPP SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANEXO GOAL
LINE OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS JUST SECOND- LOS
ANGELES ALLIANCE AN ECONOMY HOW
TO COOK ON. THANK YOU. THANKS
HAVE A LINE OF EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SEVEN ABOUT THE FROM THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COAST YOU
PRESIDENTIAL FIFTY POUNDS AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND NINE TO EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LIVING COSTS OF A SMART
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION IN
pYOU NINE THREE ALL THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THEY'RE WORKING
TWELVE THE TRANSPORT THE THREE
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND THREE TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DANIEL COULD CARE AOUT
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AN
EXTRA LINE OF ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI JASON LINDSEY
IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AN EXTRA LINE OF TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
TWENTY. GO AHEAD PLEASE. EJECT
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
LONG BEACH CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF THREE OH FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FIVE IF YOU HAVE
PREVIOUSLY SO IT DIDN'T CROSS
INSIDERS MARCH STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTROVERT SO LINE OF THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOINT
FATHER HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH.
A PAST COUPLE CHURCH. THANK YOU.
AN EXTROVERT SO LINE OF SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES THIS IS MARTIN RODRIGUEZ IT.
THE HEAD PLEASE. THOMAS THREE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE THREE TWENTY THREE DO YOU
HAVE A SUMMIT. WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF WHOA ONE OF SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVERYONE IS
TALKING. JUST THIRTY SIX IN
MARCH ACCORDING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- IS THERE ANYONE
PRESIDENT ANYONE THAT REMOTE
TESTIMONY. AND MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE AND OPPOSITION SB
THREE THIRTY EIGHT. HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
EIGHT MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE OF THEIR OF THE
OPPOSITION OF S. AS OUR S. B.
THREE THREE EIGHT. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE UP FOR THREE THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO TURN
MEMBERS KRISHNA CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION WERE
NEUTRAL ON SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT AS AMENDED ON JUNE
FOURTEENTH AND THANK THE
AUTHORED SPONSORED FOR WORKING
WITH US TO REMOVE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS WELL APPRECIATED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION AND KILL.
THANK YOU AND NOT WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. AND MILLION
MOTIONS TO AMEND SECTION THIS.
REGULAR MOTION FROM A SUDDEN
REWARD IS THERE A SECOND. AND
WE HAVE A SECOND FROM OUR
MAJORITY LEADER ANY COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH- THE SENATOR FOR WORKING
WITH OPPOSITION CLEARLY A LOT
OF WORK WENT INTO THAT PRECEDED
AND ALSO WE'VE HAD PREVIOUS
INFORMATION HEARINGS HOSTED BY
THIS COMMITTEE WILL BE HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM SOME OF THE- PORT
TRUCK DRIVERS I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU. I'M PUTTING
YOUR TIME AND ENERGY AND INTO A
BETTER PICTURE WE BETTER
PROTECT THEM SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I JUST
WANNA SAY THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT OF COURSE TO MY
DISTRICT BUT REALLY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITH ALL OF THESE
PREP PORT TRUCK DRIVERS THAT
HAVE REALLY BEEN MISCAST BY THE
MISTREATED. WANT TO THANK THE
OPPOSITION AS WELL FOR WORKING
ON AT THE FORMER OPPOSITION FOR
WORKING WITH US IN OUR QUEST
FOR THE ADULTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM SECRETARY FOR.
HAVING TO TAKE ROLE ON SB SIX
THIRTY OR THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
SB THREE. EIGHT OUR MOTION OF
THE PAST TWO JUDICIARY KALRA.
AYE KALRA AYE FLORA GONZALEZ.
HI GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER
REYES ALL RIGHT REYES FIVE ZERO
FOUR- WORD I. THANK YOU AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO SB. SIX OH
SIX. THE MOTION A SECOND MAY
BEGIN THANK YOU I THINK WE'RE
DONE THEN. I THINK WE'RE GOOD
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
AGAIN HERE I'M AT TODAY TO
PRESENT SB SIX OF SIX WHICH
DIRECTLY RESPONSIVE SOME OF THE
WORST EMPLOYER ABUSES CYNDER
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SB
SIX OH SIX WILL CODIFY PARTS OF
THE FEDERAL OSHA POLICY FOR
AGREE JUST EMPLOYERS GIVING CAL
OSHA THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES ON
EMPLOYERS FOR WILLFUL
VIOLATIONS WERE WORKERS HAVE
BEEN KNOWINGLY HARMED BY A
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH HEALTH
AND SAFETY LAWS. THE BILL THE
FEDERAL OSHA'S CORPORATE WIDE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT POLICE
POLICY BY PROVIDING FELLOWSHIP
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO ISSUE AN
ENTERPRISE WIDE CITATION- THAT
WOULD APPLY TO ALL LOCATIONS
UNDER COMMON OWNERSHIP WHEN AN
EMPLOYER'S POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES DIRECTLY VIOLATE
LABOR HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS. AS CHAIR OF THE
SENATE SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE
LAST YEAR I HEARD FIRST HAND
HOW OSHA HAD BEEN INUNDATED
WITH MORE COMPLAINTS THAN THEIR
INSPECTORS CAN HANDLE LEADING
STAFF TO INCREASINGLY RELY ON
LETTER ONLY OR NOTICE ONLY
INVESTIGATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
INSUFFICIENT. SB SIX OF SIX
PROVIDES CAL OSHA WITH THE
NECESSARY TOOLS TO MAXIMIZE THE
USE OF THEIR LIMITED RESOURCES
SO THEY'RE ABLE TO RESPOND MORE
EFFECTIVELY TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS BY LARGE
EMPLOYERS THAT PUT WORKERS
LIVES AT RISK. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE JUST A
GREAT WALL LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR U. F. C. W. WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL AND MITCH STRIKER
POLICY ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER WILL HAVE JESSE
GREYBALL. FALL BY MISTAKE- UP
TO TWO MINUTES EACH. THE ON THE
SCREEN WHILE YOU MAY START
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER
BY NAME IS THAT THE GRANT WHILE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR WITH YES
HE W. ACTOR DAY TOWN HALL. I'LL
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF I AM. AT
WE JUST WANNA CAT THE HIGHLIGHT
THAT CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
PERMIT COLOR SAID TO LEVY FINES
OR OTHER REMEDIES EVERY STEP BY
STEP BY THE CONSEQUENCE. OF
THAT TURNED DEADLY CONTACT BY
LARGE CORPORATIONS AND A
COMPARTMENT NEEDLESSLY
DIFFICULT AND- THAT'S WHY WE
NEED AT THE FACT THAT SEX AND
THINGS THAT ARE GOING DOLLARS
FOR OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. I AM WE BELIEVE AT THE
STATE PERFECT IT'S CRITICAL TO
OUR STATE'S RECOVERY WE MUST
BUT WORK PAY SPREAD AND PREVENT
ADDITIONAL OUTBREAK IF WE HAVE
ANY. ANY HOPE OF RETURNING TO
NORMAL FOR THE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I DON'T
NASTY SUCCESS AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT
THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH UP NEXT YEAR
AMID STEIGER- MISTER STRUGGLING
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU IN THE
CHAIRMAN BIRDS IN THE STEIGER
WITH THE- CALIFORNIA LABOR SAID.
PROUD TO SPONSOR THE SPELL
ALONG YOU. AND WORKSAFE. WE
TAKE A LOT OF THE MEN TO THE
BILL IT REALLY JUST. FOR YOU
THANKS. IT ALLOWS FOR
ENTERPRISE WIDE CITATIONS AND
THIS DEALS WITH SPECIFIC CASES
WHERE. AN EMPLOYER WITH
MULTIPLE LOCATIONS. IS BREAKING
THE LAW AND ALL OF THOSE
LOCATIONS AT ONCE. IT JUST
STREAMLINES THE PROCESS OF
SETTING UP A PORTER IN A WAY
THAT. WE BELIEVE IS VERY FAIR
AND JUDICIOUS ESPECIALLY TO
EMPLOYERS THAT. DON'T HAVE A
BLANKET WORKER SAFETY POLICY
ACROSS ALL OF THOSE LOCATIONS.
THEY ALSO ESTABLISHES THE
CATEGORY OF EGREGIOUS CITATIONS
THAT. THE AUTHOR DID A GREAT
JOB OF EXPLAINING. JUST WANTED
TO SPECIFY THE LOCAL CITATIONS
RIGHT NOW ALREADY HAPPENED
ABOUT TWO OR THREE TIMES PER
YEAR. AND THIS WOULD BE A
SUBSET OF THOSE. SO THEY BE
EXTRAORDINARILY RARE ONLY USED
IN THE WORST OF THE WORST CASES
IF EVER. AND IT ALSO CLARIFIES
THAT. HELLO SHOULD HAVE THE
OPTION OF CITING VIOLATIONS OF
THE LABOR CODE. SO RIGHT NOW IN
THE LEGISLATURE PASSES THE BILL
RELATING TO WORKER HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THERE'S REALLY NO ONE
THERE TO ENFORCE IT AND SO THIS
BILL WOULD SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
I JUST BRIEFLY TOUCH ON A FEW
OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN. WE HAVE REMOVED THE
ECHO THE NINETEEN SPECIFIC WERE
POSSIBLE PRESUMPTION OF
RETALIATION. WE ALSO DELETED
LANGUAGE THAT EXPANDED THE
TYPES OF TELOS INVESTIGATIONS
THAT COULD RESULT IN A
CITATION. AND WE ALSO REPLACED
WHAT WAS THE NEW PROCESS OF
REVIEWING CERTAIN TYPES OF
APPEALS. I JUST BROUGHT IN ONE
THAT ALREADY EXISTS SO THAT
IT'S SOMETHING FOLKS ARE
ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH. AND ALL
TOGETHER WE THINK IT'LL REALLY
HELP CALLOUS M. TO DO A BETTER
JOB IN FUTURE. CRISES AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SOME. OF ALL GOING TO PULL COM-
AGAIN JUST YOUR NAME AFFILIATE
POSITION ON THE BILL ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM IF NOT WE'LL GO
AHEAD TO THE ROAD TEST MY
STATION. I AM NOT A MODERATOR
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX OH SIX. THANK YOU PART OF
AND BE IN SIX OH SIX YOU MAY
PRESS THE ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO PURE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. IT'S A CO SIX
WE WILL GO TO TWO EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LIVE ACOSTA WITH SMART
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION AMPLE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK WHAT
ARE LINE OF ON NINETY FIVE
AIRLINES OPEN. GOOD LUCK SURE
NUMBERS TOTALING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIANS POIGNANTLY OF
PATIENT SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
OVER LINE OF THREE THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHAPLAIN ROWS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK
AND CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOTES
SILVERLIGHT OF THREE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION CALIFORNIA
COMPETENT MACHINIST UNITE HERE
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIA. UTILITY WORKERS
UNION OF AMERICA AND IFTTT
LOCAL TWENTY ONE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE OF TWO NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINES OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED MEMBERS TOP MAYOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AT B. SIX
THE- THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
OVER NINE ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINES OPEN. HELLO CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THIS IS FACT
THAT LURK AND ENVELOPING
SUPPORT- SB SIX OH SIX ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS ARE AT
WORK THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
FOR WORLD STUDIES. CENTRAL CAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NETWORK
COPED ALLIANCE INDICTED FOR
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY OUR
COMMUNITY PROJECT AND PROBABLY
NOT FEEL NOT ABOUT A- THAT
BATTERY- IN THE CANAL NO
KOMITET ATV CALL MADE BY A-
ELEGIES- BERMAN WORKING GROUP.
IVERS MEDINA COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CAL. WE SHOULD COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MADE AT A FANTASY MATH. IN THE
POLICY COUNCIL NATIONALLY
FARMERS COALITION AND GROUPS OF
CHANGE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER A LINE OF
ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINES
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT GOD
LOVE ALL RIGHT WORKERS UNION
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
SPEAKING IN THE COURT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ADELINE OF ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINES OPEN. YEAH
OKAY COMMITTEE IRONWORKERS
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND
YOUR FORTY FIVE AIRLINES OPEN.
WHAT THE WHERE OF LOCAL
RESOURCE CENTER INSTRUCTS SB
SIX OH SIX. THANK YOU. THREE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINES OPEN.
THE TICKET NUMBER WHEN THEY GET
FOR THE L. A. COUNTY FEDERATION
OF LABOR AND TEAMSTERS PORT
DIVISION IN STRONG PART OF THAT
SIX OF SIX. THANK YOU. PINE
THREE ALL THREE AIRLINES OPEN.
SACRAMENTO CA NINETY THEIR
WORKERS GOOD. PART OF THE FOLKS
THANK YOU. THE YOU. BY AND
LARGE THREE OH FIVE YOUR LINES
OPEN- YES WE'VE ISSUES SO HE
PROCESS LETTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINESIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIRTY ROBERTS
MAP PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTING KILL AT THIS
TIME. I THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
I BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS ROBERT
MUTRIE- BY PHONE. YES THANK YOU
AN APOLOGY THAT I CAN'T JOIN
YOU ALL THE OPEN THE CAPITAL OF
A LITTLE UNDER THE WEATHER BUT
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU
ALL AGAIN- AGAIN BARB WHICH
SHOULD BE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
YEAH I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
DEATH BECAUSE SIX- WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH YOUNGER LOOK AT
THAT ONE SECOND- IF IT'S
PRESENT FORM. AT SIX THIRTY SIX
GREAT TENSELY- NEW LIFE GROUP
JUST WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUT OF
COPA NINETY AND WE OPEN. UP IN
A FEW PROVISION AS THE AUTHOR
NOTED IT WOULD CREATE A NEW
EMPLOYER WHY TAKE CATION. ON
THAT THAT ONE LOCATION.
CONCERNS HERE THE PRESENT
LANGUAGE WE COULD NOT BE WHAT
CLEAR IT UP LIKE DE THAT THE
ISSUE MUST BE MULTIPLE- IN
ORDER TO JUSTIFY THAT CATIA- WE
ALSO ARE CONCERNED THAT THE-
EMPLOYER WHITE THAT HAITIAN.
WOULD CREATE ISSUES WHERE HELLO
CHAU POLICIES MAY CHANGE OR
CLIMATE MAY CHANGE VERY
RECENTLY. OF THE NINETEEN
PROVIDE THE PERFECT EXAMPLE OF
THE- POLICY SUCH AS THE
REGULATION THAT WENT TO AFFECT
LAST WEEK. MAY CHANGE AN
EMPLOYER COULD PAY TEN POINT Y.
TECHNICIAN THEY TRULY HAVEN'T
HAD TIME TO ADAPT THEIR POLICY.
WE'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
A SPONSOR ABOUT THIS ISSUE BUT
THAT THE ONE REMAINING CONCERNS
BROUGHT. WE'RE GOING TO BE
AGREED TO DEPLOYER DEFINITION
WE HAVE ONGOING CONCERN BUT IT
AT PRESENT- DITCH FAVORS.
LONGER ESTABLISHED BUSINESSES
IN THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN SUCH
THAT THEY WILL MORE LIKELY FALL
INTO THIS CATEGORY AGAIN
WORKING WITH THE SPONSOR AND
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS- AND- I WOULD LIKE TO
FLAG THAT. WE PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE I THINK MITCH
MENTIONED AT. THE RECENT EVENTS
TO ATTRACT THE APPEAL ISSUE
WHICH WE DO THAT THE TEMPLATE
UNINTENTIONAL BUT VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS FOR THE
APPEALS PROCESS OF
CALCIFICATIONS WERE GLAD TO SEE
THE EFFECTS THERE- WE HAVE
OFFERED A MEANT TO GO TO TRIAL
AND THAT THAT THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE SPONSORED
AUTHOR AROUND THESE TO TRY TO.
TO TRY TO FIX WE CAN HERE- AND
I'D LIKE IT'S CLEAR BY ONE
POINT THAT WAS RAISED EARLIER
WE WOULD AGREE TO KALIFAT BEEN
SOMEWHAT OVERWHELMED WITH THE
SCOPE OF IT OF WORKING THEN
UNDER COKE AT NINETEEN. HOWEVER
WE SHOULD BE CLEAR THIS BILL
DOES NOT ADD THAT TO CALLOSUM
REALLY FIX THAT PROBLEM
THANKFULLY THAT IN THE BUDGET.
BUT THAT ISSUE I THINK IS IT
SEPARATE FROM THE CHANGES TO
CAL OSHA. ENFORCEMENT AMOUNT.
HERE I'M GLAD THEY HAD LIKE I
DISAGREE WITH THE- HAVE. THAT
THE PRESIDENT- FINE STRUCTURE
NOT SUFFICIENT TO MOW EMPLOYERS.
I KNOW THAT IN THE LAST TWO
WEEK THANK HAD A- THE CALLS
PLAYERS TEXT. HOW THEM TO
COMPLY WITH. NEW OSHA
REGULATIONS I THINK DEFLECTING
CERTAINLY TRY TO COME. AT LEAST
THE VAST MAJORITY THAT. POPULAR
REASON WE ARE RESPECT THE- IN
THANK YOU COULD TIME. THANK YOU.
NOW WILL GO ANY CART. IN IN THE
ROOM AN OFFICE. RASKIN JUST
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION ON
THE BILL. ANYONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. IN THE META
MODERATOR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE SB. SIX ZERO SIX.
THANK YOU I'M A RELIEVING AB
FOR A FEW MINUTES HERE FOR A
BREAK AND- A TO SHOW OPPOSITION
FOR. AB SIX OH SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED
BY ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR
AB SIX OH SIX THE FIRST ONE
MISTER CHAIR IS ONE THREE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'LL TO
HAVE A PUBLICLY. GLISTENS AND
MANAGEMENT IN THE SECTOR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR. ONE SEVENTY FOUR YOU ARE
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CAMERA HANDLING ON THE OPPOSITE
KERN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR ALL THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE OF THE SENATE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT LINE THREE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVERYTHING
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY AND WITH A
MINOR COMMENTS WITHOUT CHAMBER
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO.
FINE THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN TOM SHE HE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SIX OF SIX THANK YOU. I WANT
THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS BY
LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION
FOR THE REASONS OUTLINED BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CALCHAMBER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE GOING IT ONE
ZERO TWO CHAU. EXPRESS YOUR
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX OH SIX WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE MORE QUEUING
UP. I WILL GO TO LINE THREE
FORTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE
HANSON WITH A CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION YOUR
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WINE THREE FORTY SIX
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MURCHISON CHENEY HELP
ON BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
LINE THREE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU RYAN COOGLER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE AND WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION CORRECT- ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. YES WE ARE WE HAVE
A MOTION THAT IS NO LONGER
CRITICS WILL BRING IT TERM BOX.
OUR AUTHOR I JUST SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH I THINK THAT- TO THE
OPPOSITION'S POINT ABOUT OSHA
BEING OVER WORKED INVOLVED THAT
WAS THE CASE BEFORE BECAUSE OF
IT. I THINK THAT- COVERAGE
DEFINITELY EXPOSE A LOT OF WAYS
IN WHICH WE CAN IMPROVE BY
GIVING MORE TOOLS OSHA MORE
RESOURCES CERTAINLY WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT POINT OF MOST OF MY
COMING UPON ALL OF US I CARE
ABOUT THE QUALITY. OF OUR JOB
PLACES AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE
SAFE FOR ALL OUR WORKERS- AND
WITH THAT WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
WILL JUST SAY BUILDING OFF OF
WHAT YOU JUST MENTIONED THAT WE
NEED A CAL OSHA TO FOCUS THEIR
EFFORTS ON THE MOST AGREE
SHOULD REGIS AND WILLFUL
VIOLATIONS AGAIN. SO WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY LOOK
FOR ALL OF OUR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS THANK YOU SO MUCH. A
MADAM SECRETARY FOR INTAKE ROLE
ON S. B. SIX ZERO SIX. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE KALRA I KALRA. HI
FLORA. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES SAWYER. HI JONES SAWYER.
RATES FAIR. FOUR FIVE WORD I.
THINK SO MUCH THE- NOT LOOK AT
THE ROLE OPEN. AND FOR THE NEXT.
SEGMENT OF OUR PRESENTATIONS WE
HAVE SENATOR LEYVA WE'LL GET
AFTER YOU'RE HERE GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS LOOKS LIKE WE
SENATORS ARE JUST DOING
MULTIPLE BILL YEAH I KNOW THAT
IS WE LIKE HEY LIKE THAT FOR
AWHILE. AND YOU'LL BE STARTING
IN ORDER SB THREE THIRTY ONE
YEAH THAT IS FINE ABSOLUTELY.
ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS ARE MR CHAIRED LIKE TO
THINK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS BILL IS MUCH
APPRECIATED. SENATE BILL THREE
THREE ONE ALSO KNOWN AS THE
SILENCE NO MORE ACT EXPANDS THE
PROHIBITION ON NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS NDAS. TO NOW COVER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS INVOLVING
ALL FORMS OF HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION THIS BILL ALSO
EXPANDS THE PROHIBITION ON
OVERLY BROAD CONFIDENTIALITY.
AND NON DISPARAGEMENT CLAUSES
IN EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENTS TO
COVER WORKERS ARE REQUIRED TO
SIGN THESE TYPES OF CLAUSES AS
PART OF A SEVERANCE AGREEMENT.
AS MANY OF YOU MAY REMEMBER I
AUTHORED AND THEN GOVERNOR
BROWN SIGNED SB EIGHT TWENTY
ALSO KNOWN AS THE STAND ACT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. SB EIGHT
TWENTY SPECIFICALLY BANNED
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS IN
CASES OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND SEX
DISCRIMINATION IMPORTANTLY THE
SAND ACT ALSO ALLOWS THE
CLAIMANT TO REQUEST
CONFIDENTIALITY IF THEY SO
CHOOSE. IN PASSING THIS
HISTORIC LAW THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZE THAT SECRET
SETTLEMENTS WERE HELPING TO
PERPETRATE HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENTS AND ALLOWING
COMPLAINTS TO BE SWEPT UNDER
THE RUG. OF COURSE THE SECRET
SUMMITS PLAYS MUCH A ROLE IN
PERPETUAL FOR. PERPETUATING
WORKPLACE DISCRIMINATION
HARASSMENT AND BIAS BASED ON
RACE ETHNICITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AGE DISABILITY
RELIGION AMONG OTHERS. BECAUSE
HERE TO COMPLAINTS ARE KEPT
SECRET AND THOSE WHO RAISE THE
COMPLAINTS ARE EFFECTIVELY
SILENCED. MEMBERS IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE FOR ANY EMPLOYER
TO TRY TO SILENCE A WORKER
BECAUSE HERE SHE WAS A VICTIM
OF ANY TYPE OF HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION. THE SILENCE NO
MORE ACTUAL POWER SURVIVORS TO
SPEAK OUT IF THEY SO WISH SO
THE PERPETRATORS CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE CAN
HOPEFULLY PREVENT ABUSES FROM
CONTINUING TO TORMENT. AND
ABUSE OTHER WORKERS. WORKERS
SHOULD ALWAYS BE ABLE TO SPEAK
OUT AGAINST THIS DEPLORABLE
BEHAVIOR IN THE WORKPLACE WELL
TO DEMAND ACCOUNTABILITY AND TO
PREVENT FUTURE ABUSES. HERE
WITH ME TODAY ALTHOUGH REMOTELY
TO SHARE HER OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE IS A FORMER AS SO
MUCH AS WELL AS MARIE GO.
YOU'RE SURE YOSHI HORA SORRY
MARIE GO WITH CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR AND
SO YES WE HAVE- THE FAMAS
ONLINE MOVIE CLICHE HARA UP TO
TWO MINUTES EACH PLEASE ANSWER
FORMA. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIRED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY MY
ENTIRE CAREER HAS BEEN ATTACKED
PUBLIC POLICY OFFICIAL ENGAGING
WITH OFFICES LIKE YOURS. ON
BEHALF OF COMPANIES LIKE GOOGLE
FACEBOOK AND ENSURE. MY LAST
WORK TRIP BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
WHAT THE DC PAPERS AT WORK I
LEAD ON HEALTH MISINFORMATION.
THAT WAS DAYS BEFORE PINTEREST
LAWYERS PRESENTED ME WITH A
HIGHLY RESPECTED NONDISCLOSURE
AND NON DISPARAGEMENT
AGREEMENTS I THINK HE NEEDS
SILENCE ABOUT THE RACE AND
GENDER DISCRIMINATION AND
RETALIATION CLAIM. I'D RATE
OVER THE PREVIOUS YEAR WHEN I
DECIDED TO COME FORWARD
PUBLICLY I ALONG WITH THE
FORMER COLLEAGUE NAMED ERICA IS
THE BANK. DID SO WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT WOULD BE COVERED
FOR DISCLOSURES RELATED TO
GENDER BASED DISCRIMINATION
UNDER AT THE EIGHT TWENTY WHICH
I'M SO GRATEFUL TO STAND AWAY
THAT FOR OFFERING DURING THE
MEETING WITH MAC. UNFORTUNATELY
AS A BLACK WOMAN I CANNOT
SEPARATE MY RATE FOR MY GENDER
WHICH MEANT THAT MENTIONS AT
THE RATE DETERMINATION I AND
THERE COULD RESULT IN LEGAL
RETALIATION. NO WORKER SHOULD
BE IN A POSITION WHERE PART OF
THEIR IDENTITY ISN'T COVERED
WHEN IT COMES TO DISPOSING
UNLAWFUL TREATMENT. AND HE IS
LIKE THE ONE I HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO FIND ARE USED BY
COMPANIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO
WORKERS I FUNDAMENTALLY
AMERICANS EACH RIGHT. HOW MANY
WORKERS CAN REFUSE TO SIGN
THESE AGREEMENTS AT THE EXPENSE
OF INCOME ARE HEALTH INSURANCE
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WHAT WORK IS THAT
COMPANIES DON'T NEED TO ENGAGE
THE KEY PROPRIETARY INFORMATION
STATE. THAT INFO IS ALREADY
PROTECTED THE USE OF
CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENTS
EMPLOYEES MIGHT FIND WHEN
THEY'RE HIRED ADDITIONALLY A
RELEASE OF CLAIMS PARTISAN
SEVERANCE AGREEMENT ENSURE
COMPANIES DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT LITIGATION FROM OUTLYING
EMPLOYEES. FINALLY THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO BENEFIT THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY BY INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY FOR SHAREHOLDERS
I'M NOT INDIVIDUALS SPEAK UP
INVESTORS ARE KEPT IN THE DARK.
ABOUT MISCONDUCT AT THE COMPANY
IS AND WHY WHICH THEY HAVE
FINANCIAL STAKE. LET'S BE SURE
ARGUMENT AGAINST THAT COMMON
BUT- FAIL OUT MORE ABOUT THOSE
IN OFF BAN ABOUT THE BALLOT. SB
THREE THIRTY ONE BLOOM AND
HAPPEN AND ASSAULT BUT MY HOPE
IS THAT ONE SILENCE HAVE NOT
THANK. THANK YOU MUCH. UP NEXT
THE AMERICAN YOSHIHARU.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. HERE ARE
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- UP BEHIND THE QUALITY
WITH THE COW SENATE LAWYERS
THAT THEY AND WE PROUD SPONSORS
OF THE BILL ALONG WITH THE AND
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES. I'M
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE SEEN A
CALL ACROSS CLAUSES LIKE NBA IS
AN HONOR AND A GREAT MAN I
REALLY BEEN USED AS A WAY TO
SILENCE WORKERS ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCE IN THE WORKPLACE
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW ALREADY
HOLD THESE TYPES OF AGREEMENTS
AND LOW REGARD THE NATIONAL
LABOR RELATIONS ACT FOR EXAMPLE
MAKES IT AN UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE FOR AN EMPLOYER TO
PUNISH OR OTHERWISE PREVENT
EMPLOYEES FROM DISCUSSING THE
TERM THE CONDITIONS OF THEIR
EMPLOYMENT. INCLUDING
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION
THAT THEY MAY HAVE EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE WHAT WE KNOW IT WHEN
WORKERS LIKE MR DAHMER AND
MISSION YOU THE BANK OUT OTHERS
WILL JOIN THEM AND THIS IS HOW
WORKERS COLLECTIVELY CAN
EFFECTUATE REAL CHANGE AND WHY
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE NEEDED
OPPONENTS OF SB THREE THREE ONE
ARGUING THAT THE BILL WILL
DISCOURAGE EMPLOYERS FROM
PAYING SEVERANCE TO WORKERS AND
A SIMILAR ACCUSATION WAS MADE
ABOUT SB EIGHT TWENTY THE FAN
BACK IT WITH THAT BUT IF YOU
TAKE AWAY THE NDA PARTIES WON'T
BE ABLE TO KIND OF KEEP THAT
AND THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED. WHAT
AND HE'S WORKING ON THE TABLE
THEY JUST NO LONGER BECAME A
PART OF THE NEGOTIATION
SIMILARLY AND A SEVEN CONTACT
WE KNOW THE TRUE VALUE IN A
SEVERANCE AGREEMENT IT IS THE
RELEASED THE CLAIM NOT THE
SECRECY PROVISION A RELEASE
AVOID THE POSSIBILITY OF MINE
FOR YEARS OF LITIGATION AND THE
POTENTIAL OF AN ADVERSE
JUDGMENT. NON DISPARAGEMENT
PROVISIONS ARE JUST ADDED TO
THE 7 DEGREES MEANT FOR THEIR
INTERIM A FAT AWAIT TO
INTIMIDATE EMPLOYEES INTO
STAYING SILENT AND ADMIT THE
NUMBER JUST THAT THIS NOT ONLY
HURT THE WORKERS IN A DANGEROUS
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE PUBLIC
GOOD ENTER THE DISSERVICE TO
LAW ABIDING EMPLOYERS. THIS
BILL WILL HELP STOP THESE
ABUSES SILENCING TACTICS AND
ENSURE MORE WORKERS CAN SPEAK
OUT AND CAN SPEAK TOGETHER
ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES OF
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION.
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SOME. THANK YOU SO.
I'M WELL NOW. ONE OF THE ROOMS
SUPPORT. IF NOT THE ROOM MY
STAY. THE NEW RAIDERS ARE ON
THE PHONE LINES OF TWO THIRTY.
THIS IS STILL I'M DIED TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR F. THREE THIRTY
ONE- PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AND EIGHTY JAPANESE
GOING TO GO AHEAD GET YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE IN THE PLACE YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE. WILL BEGIN
TODAY MISTER CHAIR WITH- TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
EMBARRASSED CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THREE ONE ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL'S CO SPONSORS WHICH
INCLUDE- XPT EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THREE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
OVERLIE THREE OF HIS THREE
FIGHT THREE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE TECHNI BOARD ON BEHALF
OF THE CALTRAIN COMMITMENT THAT
THE WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB THREE THREE ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TWO
NINETY SEVEN YOU ARE ALL BUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS COULD POP MAYOR CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THIRTY ONE
THANKS. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
FIFTY NINE YOU ARE ALL BUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WINE THREE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
FORTY EIGHT WOULD YOU PLEASE-
YOU. ONE MORE TRY THREE FORTY
EIGHT ARE YOU MUTED. MOVING
ALONG WILL GO TO LIKE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JAN WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIND THREE FIFTY
EIGHT EURO BUT. ERICA SHE NEEDS
THE BANK'S FORMER CAN JUST
SIMPLY IN GODERICH OUTGROW
CALIFORNIA AND PROJECT WORK ON
THE CELL AND FIND STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE ONE.
THANK YOU. FIVE THREE FIFTY
FOUR EUROPE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MINING THE
COMMANDER WHY I'M A LICENSED
PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON COMMUNITY
HEALTH ADVOCATE AND PROPONENT
OF DIVERSE WORKPLACE
REPRESENTATION AND RETENTION
AND HEALTH CARE SETTINGS AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THAT YOU CANNOT SPELL
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. ROBERT
INTERNATIONALLY TRAITS DISTRICT
COUNCIL THIRTY SIX IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AT THE PUMP
THANK YOU I'M SORRY- AS A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE THIRTY ONE.
AND NEXT IS LINE ONE SEVENTY
SIX. EVERYONE MY NAME IS
TALKING INTERNET ALSO. THANK
YOU. AB MISTER CHAIR WELL WE
JUST HAD ANOTHER ONE QUEUE UP
ONE MOMENT. WE WILL GO TO LINE
THREE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CHAIR MEMBERS EVEN
TAKE A FOR UNITE HERE LOCAL
ELEVEN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE THREE FIFTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. NINE THREE FIFTY ONE OR
TRY AGAIN. CAN YOU HEAR THREE
FIFTY ONE. I'M SORRY THEY'RE
NOT RESPONDING WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
OKAY AND THEN NOW WILL MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION. FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN PERSON REPRESENT THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ASHLEY
OFTEN. GET AFTER RESEARCHER
MEMBERS ACTUALLY HALF AN ONLY
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE THIRTY ONE I DO WANT TO
CLARIFY WE ARE ONLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SECOND HALF
OF THE BILL RELATED TO
SEVERANCE AGREEMENTS- WE HAVE
NO POSITION ON THE FIRST HALF
RELATED TO THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS. WELL WE HAVE
CONCERNED GENERALLY ABOUT THE
BILL'S LIMITATIONS ON THE USE
OF CONFIDENTIALITY PROVISIONS
AND SEVERANCE AGREEMENTS AND
THE EFFECTIVE THAT WILL HAVE AN
EMPLOYER'S DECISION TO OFFER
SEVERANCE TODAY LIKE TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS JUST ONE
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS- IN THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WE
HAD DISCUSSIONS OF THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL AND I DO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
MINUTES TAKEN IN THAT
COMMITTEE. THE ANALYSIS
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS CAUSE
CONCERN ABOUT THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL THAT COULD BE
INTERPRETED TO MEAN THAT
EMPLOYERS CANNOT KEEP SEVERANCE
AMOUNTS CONFIDENTIAL AMENDMENTS
WERE ACCEPTED THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO QUOTE CLARIFY THE
AMOUNT OF A SEVERANCE PAYMENT
MAY BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL AS
PART OF A SEVERANCE AGREEMENT
HOWEVER THE AMENDMENT TO
SUBSECTION E. STATE SAID
NOTHING PROHIBITS RIVETING
DISCLOSURE OF THE AMOUNT OF THE
SETTLEMENT NOT A SEVERANCE
AGREEMENT. WOULD RAISE THE
DISCREPANCY AT THE TWENTY
ANALYSIS IN THE AMENDMENT TO
THE AUTHOR THE SPONSORS- THEY
HAVE SO FAR DECLINED TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENT BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT BELIEVE THE BILL AND PRINT
NOW COULD BE READ TO PROHIBIT
KEEPING THE AMOUNT CONFIDENTIAL
ASK CLARITY IN STATUTORY
LANGUAGE ABOUT A WIDE LOT DOES
OR DOES NOT DO AS ESSENTIAL FOR
EMPLOYERS ESPECIALLY OUR SMALL
EMPLOYERS WHO MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO LEGAL COUNSEL. IT'S
ALSO BENEFICIAL TO COURTS THAT
ARE INTERPRETING THESE LIES A
COURT MAY LOOK AT SUBSECTION E.
IS PRESENTLY WRITTEN I BELIEVE
THE LEGISLATURE INTENTIONALLY
CHOSE ONLY TO MENTION
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS NOT
SEVERANCE AGREEMENTS OF THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY ANALYSIS
AGREED THAT THIS CLARIFICATION
WOULD BE BENEFICIAL
RECOMMENDING THIS AMENDMENT BE
MADE TO ASSUAGE REASONABLE
CONCERNS THE STATUE NOT BE READ
MORE BROADLY THAN INTENDED.
THAT ANALYSIS ALSO CORRECTLY
POINTED OUT THAT CCP SECTION
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE WHICH THE
BILL ALSO AMENDS CONTAINS A
PROVISION CLARIFYING THAT IT
SHALL NOT PRECLUDE AGREEMENTS
THAT PROHIBIT DISCLOSURE OF THE
AMOUNT. PAID IN THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT WITH- FOR REQUESTED
SOME. E. OF COVER CODES. ONE TO
NINETY FOUR POINT. BE AMENDED
TO BE MAKE CLEAR THAT NOTHING
PROHIBITS THE KEEPING THE
AMOUNT OF A SEVERANCE. IN
AGREEMENT FROM BEING KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OF ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. NOT
BECAUSE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. AND THEN FINALLY
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN OPPOSITION- TO SB. THREE
THIRTY ONE. SORRY I WAS MUTED
LINE THREE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND ANYBODY ESE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR S. B. AT THREE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YOUR OFFICE.
THREE FORTY SIX. THREE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MORE
TRY AND WHITE THREE FORTY SIX
YOU ARE OPEN. LIVING ALONG
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS
FORGIVE ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS ABOUT
THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE FORTY TO YOUR OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WITH A
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AND IN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE COMMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIVE ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN YOU
ARE ALL BUT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BY
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
IN OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE CHAMBER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO THE EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR
BILL SB THREE THREE ONE. MR
CHERNOBYL ELSE'S QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH-
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A MOTION.
I'M ON A SECOND. THANK YOUR
COMMENT. WE WILL BRING YOU BACK
TO OUR OTHER AND TO SAY THANK
YOU AND FOR CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION SUMMIT THERE'S
BEEN SOME MOVEMENT THERE WHICH
IS GOOD BUT- THIS IS AN ISSUE
AND ON EVERY TO WORK ON FOR
MANY YEARS APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED- HE CONTINUED
PERSISTENCE AND COMMITMENT-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND I JUST WANT TO
PUBLICLY THANK MS OSAMA AND MS
SHIMAZU BANKS UP FOR THEIR
COURAGE TO COME FORWARD SO THAT
WE CAN TRY AND RECTIFY THIS
PROBLEM AND ALSO JUST MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE KNOW. THAT THE
COMPANY THAT WAS REFERENCED- IN
THE WITNESS TESTIMONY HAS NOW
MADE PUBLIC THAT THEY ARE
CHANGING THEIR PRACTICES AND
ARE IN FACT NOW SUPPORTING THE
BILL SO WE ARE ALREADY MAKING
PROGRESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE MADONSELA'S THE
KUDOS THE COURAGE OF THE WOMEN
FOR STEPPING FORWARD- THAT
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT
THAT THAT'S ABOUT THEM AND IT
WOULDN'T ACTUALLY BE HERE
WITHOUT THEM EITHER. SO WITH
THAT- MADAM SECRETARY FLEAS-
TAKE ROLE ON SB THIRTY ONE
MOTION IS THE PATH TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR KALRA I KALRA
HIGH FLOOR THE DALLAS GONZALEZ
SIDE JONES SAWYER REYES ZERO
WARD AT THE PHONE CALLS TO THE
BILL WILL BE ON CALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND- WE CAN MOVE ON TO
SB FIVE TWENTY THREE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY VERY GOOD THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATE BILL
FIVE TWENTY THREE EXPANDS AND
MODERNIZES BIRTH CONTROL ACCESS
AND ENSURES GREATER
CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY STATEWIDE
REGARDLESS OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
GENDER INSURANCE COVERAGE
STATUS WHERE THEY WORK OR WHERE
THEY GO TO SCHOOL. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN CALIFORNIA
ENACTED SB TEN FIFTY FEET THREE
THE CONTRACEPTIVE COVERAGE
EQUITY ACT TO BUILD ON EXISTING
POLICY INCOME FOR THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT'S
CONTRACEPTIVE COVERAGE MANDATE
INTO STATE LAW THE MEASURE
REQUIRED MOST COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS TO COVER ALL FDA APPROVED
CONTRACEPTIVE METHODS WITHOUT
CO PAYS COST SHARING OR
RESTRICTIONS LIKE STEP THERAPY
OR PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
ADDITIONALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN JUST AFTER SB TEN FIFTY
THREE WAS AN ACTIVE SB. NINE
NINE NINE WAS IMPLEMENTED TO
REQUIRE MOST HEALTH INSURANCE.
AND CAL. TO COVER A YEARS TO.
OF BIRTH DISPENSED AT ONE TIME.
DESPITE THE PROGRESS MADE IN
CALIFORNIA HEALTH DISPARITIES
IN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
OUTCOMES PERSIST AMONG BLACK
INDIGENT INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR INCLUDING
DISPROPORTIONATE UNINTENDED
PREGNANCY INFANT AND MATERNAL
MORTALITY AND STD RATES. IT IS
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
MODERNIZE AND EXPAND ITS
CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY LAWS. TO
REDUCE BARRIERS TO
CONTRACEPTIVE CARE IMPROVE
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES. AND CREATE GREATER
HEALTH EQUITY. TO THAT END SB
FIVE TWENTY THREE ACCOMPLISHES
THE FOLLOWING MAKE CALIFORNIA'S
CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY LAWS
GENDER INCLUSIVE. REQUIRES
COVERAGE OF OVER THE COUNTER
BIRTH CONTROL OPTIONS TO
INCREASE ACCESS. TO TIME
SENSITIVE CARE. EXPANDS
CONTRACEPTIVE COVERAGE TO
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS BY
EXPANDING BENEFITS. TO STATE
EMPLOYEES AND INDIVIDUALS
ENROLLED IN HEALTH PLANS
OPERATED BY UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES. PROHIBITS EMPLOYER
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
EMPLOYEES CONTRACEPTIVE
CHOICES. TESTIFYING REMOTELY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL OUR LIST
MAKE CAYMAN OF THE NATIONAL
HEALTH LAW PROGRAM. AND DR
DANIEL GROSSMAN PROFESSOR WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF OBSTETRICS
AND GYNECOLOGY AND REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. SAN FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR OF
KING OF WITNESSES UP TO TWO
MINUTES REALISM BECAME INVOLVED
BY DANIEL GROSSMAN. HELLO THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME AS WELL AS MY
CAMERAMAN AND I AM A SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH THE NATIONAL
HEALTH LAW PROGRAM. FOR AND
HEALTH IS A PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
FIRM WITH OFFICES IN LOS
ANGELES DC AND CHAPEL HILL.
IT'S OUR MISSION TO PROTECT
THEM VANCE THE HEALTH RATES OF
LOW INCOME AND UNDERSERVED
PEOPLE. WE ARE VERY PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR SB FIVE TWENTY THREE
AND WANT TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
GRATITUDE TO SENATOR LATE THAT
THE BEING A FAMILY PLANNING
CHAMPION. PROBABLY DEFECT ON
THE IMPORTANT ISSUE. I HELP
WITH THE CO SPONSOR OF THE- BUT
COVERAGE EQUITY. AND INTO
FIFTEEN A SENATOR LEYVA MENTION.
A CONSENT HAVE AN ACTIVE
PROVISIONS THAT GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE EIGHTEENTH BIRTH
CONTROL MANDATE TO CREATE GREAT
OF CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY. SEVEN
EIGHT NOW REQUIRE COVERAGE OF
MALE STERILIZATION SERVICES
WITH NO COPAYS. VOLUNTEERED
MANY CALIFORNIA STILL HAVE TO
PAY COST SHARING PROTECTING IS.
OUR STATE MANDATE COVERAGE OF
OVER THE COUNTER BIRTH CONTROL
WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION- AND I
THINK AND FINALLY AT THE AT
THREE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY THREE
WOULD BRING CALIFORNIA- UP TO
DATE IT WOULD ALSO GUARANTEE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS AND STATE
EMPLOYEES EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO
COMPREHENSIVE CONTRACEPTIVE
CARE IN THEIR PLANS AFTER FOUR
YEARS OF ATTACKS ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. CALIFORNIA
CAN AND MUST ADVANCE PROACTIVE
SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE THE
CONTROL THEY WANT WHEN THEY
WANT IT WITHOUT DELAY. WE
RESPECTFULLY PERSPECTIVE
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB
FIVE TWENTY THREE TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND THEN UP
NEXT ANNUAL GROSSMAN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY
NAME IS DR DANIEL GROSSMAN AND
I'M A PROFESSOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF OBSTETRICS
GYNECOLOGY AND REPRODUCTIVE
SCIENCES AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO. AS A
PRACTICING GYNECOLOGIST I KNOW
VERY WELL THE CRITICAL WORLD
BUT CONTRACEPTION PLAYS IN THE
LIVES OF MY PATIENTS. ALLOWING
THEM TO PLAN IF AND WHEN THEY
WANT TO HAVE. CHILDREN AND
GIVING THEM MORE CONTROL OVER
THEIR LIVES. I ALSO KNOW FROM
MY PRACTICE BUT NOT EVERY
CONTRACEPTIVE METHOD IS RIGHT
FOR EVERY PRSON AND PEOPLE
HAVE INDIVIDUAL PREFERENCES
ABOUT WHAT TEACHERS OVER BIRTH
CONTROL METHODS ARE IMPORTANT
TO THEM. SB FIVE TWENTY THREE
ADDRESSES IMPORTANT
SHORTCOMINGS OF EXISTING
LEGISLATION BY MANDATING
COVERAGE FOR THE FULL RANGE OF
CONTRACEPTIVE METHODS.
INCLUDING PROTECT ME INCLUDING
OVER THE COUNTER MEDICINES
WITHOUT REQUIRING A
PRESCRIPTION WHICH WE KNOW THAT
CERTAIN POPULATIONS THAT
SENATOR WEBER MENTIONED.
ESPECIALLY BLACK INDIGENOUS
OTHER PEOPLE OF COLOR. AS WELL
AS THOSE LIVING ON LOW INCOMES
CONTINUE TO FACE BARRIERS TO
OBTAINING A BIRTH CONTROL THAT
THEY WANT. PARTICULARLY IN THIS
MOMENT IN THE WAKE OF A
PANDEMIC THAT HAS AFFECTED SO
MANY WE NEED TO REMOVE ALL OF
THE REMAINING BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING EFFECTIVE
CONTRACEPTION. RIGHT NOW IF
SOMEONE WANTS TO USE AN OVER
THE COUNTER CONTRACEPTIVE
METHODS SUCH AS SPERMICIDE WORK
FOR MODEL EMERGENCY
CONTRACEPTION. WERE IN THE NOT
TOO DISTANT FUTURE AN OTC
REGULAR BIRTH CONTROL PILL. THE
ONLY WAY TO GET INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR THAT. OTC
CONTRACEPTION IS IF THEY GET A
PRESCRIPTION FIRST AND NOT
REALLY JUST MAKES NO SENSE. THE
FDA HAS ALREADY DETERMINED THAT
THOSE METHODS ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE ENOUGH TO BE SOLD
WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION. AND
REQUIRING SOMEONE TO GET A
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY
PRESCRIPTIONS IN ORDER TO GET
INSURANCE COVERAGE UNDERMINES
THE IMPROVEMENT AND ACCESS-
THAT OTC. STATUS CONFERS. SB
FIVE TWENTY THREE WILL REMEDY
THIS INCONSISTENCY. FINALLY AS
A MEMBER OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY I STAND
WITH MY FACULTY COLLEAGUES AND
YOU SEE STUDENTS. TO REQUEST
THAT THEY BE GIVEN THE SAME
CONTRACEPTIVE COVERAGE AND.
OTHER CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. FOR
MAKING MOVE TO. PUBLIC FOR
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
TWENTY THREE ANYONE IN THE ROOM.
WILL MOVE THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. AND THEN MODERATOR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
SB FIVE TWENTY THREE. EXPECT
THE STRUCTURE IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHAT OPERATOR
CAN GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE. THEY SHOULD THANK YOU
WE'LL BEGIN WITH LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU BRIAN SPENCER
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE THREE
SIXTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN. HI THIS
IS MARGARET SPEND WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORTER
AT THE AT FIVE THIRTY PM. THANK
YOU. FIND THREE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ERIN EVAN ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA HAS
A CUTS CO SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT- DRIVER
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE THREE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATHY VAN
OFTEN REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU.
TWO TWENTY YOU ARE UP PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JENNIFER
PASSED THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE THREE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHRAN RAP SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIVE THREE SEVENTY
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
FARE THAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
UNFUNDED CASTEEL WAS ESSENTIAL
ACCESS HEALTH PROUD CO SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL IN THE FIFTH
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK THREE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU ON YOUR
BEHALF OF EACH OF YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN COURT.
THANK YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. TWO I SHOW SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL SB FIVE TWENTY THREE.
SURE NOBODY ELSE WAS GIVING UP
THANK YOU. OKAY SO WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION THERE ARE NO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO SEE
THERE'S A ONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TWENTY
THREE. BY TWENTY THREE. DON'T
SEE ANY ONES WILL GO TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. AND
THEN FINALLY- MODERATED WE HAVE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. CHAU OPPOSITION FOR SB
FIVE TWENTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CARE NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP THANK YOU. SO WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. AND
IS THERE A MOTION. ON SB FIVE
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND CELL
PHONE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY OFTEN
I'VE A GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MA'AM SECRETARY KALRA PLEASE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO HELP
COMMITTEE KALRA HI KALRA HI
FLORA GONZALEZ. THE DALLAS I
JONES SAWYER REYES SARAH WARD.
FIVE WARD HI. ALL OKAY SO THE
BILLS ARE ON CALL AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO SAID TWENTY SAID.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU MUCH SB
SEVENTY SEVEN AIMS TO PREVENT
WAIT STAFF WITHIN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT WE ARE SEEKING TO GO AFTER
THE BAD ACTORS IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND HELP THOSE THAT PLAY BY THE
RULES AND MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
WORKERS ARE PAID ON TIME.
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY BUILT OUR WORLD CLASS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A KEY DRIVER
OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND
PROVIDED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF HOUSING UNITS ANNUALLY TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF A GROWING
CALIFORNIA POPULATION. DUE TO
THE SKILLS REQUIRED AND THE
FAIR WAGES AND BENEFITS WORKERS
RECEIVED THE INDUSTRY PROVIDED
A PATHWAY TO THE MIDDLE CLASS
FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WHO
COULDN'T AFFORD THE HOMES THAT
THEY BUILT. UNFORTUNATELY FOR
MORE THAN THE LAST FORTY YEARS
THE STANDARDS HAVE GRADUALLY
BEEN A ROADING ACCORDING TO THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
CRITERIA OVER 50% OF
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTRUCTION
WORKFORCE FAMILIES. CURRENTLY
FALL IN THE LOW INCOME CATEGORY
CATEGORY LESS THAN 80% OF THE
MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME. AS AND
OVER ONE THIRD OF ALL
CONSTRUCTION FAMILIES ARE
CLASSIFIED AS VERY LOW INCOME
EARNING LESS THAN 50% OF THE
MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME. LIKE MANY
OTHER SECTORS CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS HAVE GONE DOWN BUT WAGE
THEFT AND CASH PAYMENTS HAVE
INCREASED AND A KEY FACTOR FOR
THIS IS THE LACK OF ENFORCEMENT
OF BASIC LABOR LAWS ON JOB
SITES. UNSCRUPULOUS CONTRACTORS
THAT DO NOT PLAY BY THE RULES
HAVEN'T ILLEGAL AND UNFAIR
ADVANTAGE OVER ON ITS
CONTRACTORS AS THE UNDERMINE
WAGES AND WORKING CONDITIONS
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY. BUT I
WILL SHARE THAT WELL AB
SEVENTEEN OH ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN AT THE
TIME WHICH TOOK EFFECT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HAS MADE SOME
DIFFERENCE IT IS NOT DONE
ENOUGH SOME CONTRACTORS STILL
CONSIDER WAGE THEFT JUST A COST
OF DOING BUSINESS. HERE WITH ME
TODAY IS DANNY CURTAIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH-
YES. WE HAVE ONE WITNESS. SO WE
HAVE ONE WITNESS A DANIEL. YOU
MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU READY. A
RECENT BERKELEY NINETY FOUR.
ALMOST HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S TO
WORK WITH. FROM THAT. FOUR
THREE DOLLARS VERY VALUES BE
LEGAL ONE PRACTICE PRIMARILY
JUST FIVE. HANG ON TABLE TO
MINIMIZE COSTS. EIGHT TWENTY
FORTY ECONOMIC GROUND REPORT
INCLUDED CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY TAKE
FIFTY CENTS ON THE DOLLAR TO
THE OF- WITH THIS THE LADY
REFERRED TO- SHOW OVERHEAD THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS BEING ABLE
OR LOWER AND TO STAY. BUT I
WANT TO OUT AT THE LOWEST LEVEL
THE EXTREME LOW LET THAT'S
ABOUT 84% PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
THAT CATEGORY. IN THE FOUR
DECADES BETWEEN NINETEEN SIXTY
TO TWENTY TEN IT WAS AN
INCREASE OF A 4100% THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY. CURRENTLY
ALMOST 20% OF ALL CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ARE IN THE ON
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY OFF THE
BOOKS UNDER REPORTER
MISCLASSIFIED. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION WAS A ONE HUNDRED
NINETY BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
EDT ESTIMATED SIXTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN CREDIT
CONSTRUCTION WAITED WAGES WERE
LEGALLY REPORTED. WITH TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS UNREPORTED AND
THREE TO FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IN LOST TAXES. OF TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF UNREPORTED
WAGES THAT YEAR THE BUREAU
FIELDING FORCES FORSMAN
COLLECTED LESS THAN ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN WAGES AND PENALTIES
THAT DOESN'T EVEN SHOW UP AS A
STATISTIC OR A BLIP. FOR ALMOST
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CONTRACTORS IN CALIFORNIA THE
CHANCES OF FACING INSPECTION-
ABOUT ONCE EVERY THREE HUNDRED
YEARS. SO WE HAVE A FAILURE OF
ENFORCEMENT OF FAILURE OF
INSPECTION AND A FAILURE OF
COLLECTION THE CRIME DOES PAY
IN THIS INDUSTRY AND HONEST
CONTRACTORS ARE BEING DRIVEN
OUT OF THE INDUSTRY. THE
GENERAL CONTRACTORS RESPONSIBLE
FULLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF THE
PROJECT THE ONLY ENTITY TO HAS
THE ABILITY THE TOOLS AND THE
AUTHORITY TO MONITOR EVERY
ASPECT OF A PROJECT THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERALL SAFETY
OF A PROJECT THEY MANAGE THE
SEQUENCING OF A PROJECT FROM
THE GROUND UP THEY ORGANIZED
THE TIMING DELIVERY OF
MATERIALS TO A PROJECT. THEY
HIRE AND OVERSEE THE WORK OF
THE SUBCONTRACTORS IF NOT THE
WORK'S NOT DONE RIGHT THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE IT'S CRITICAL THAT
PRIVATE SECTOR PLAYS A BIGGER
ROLE AND THAT'S THE THEME I'M
HEARING NOW IN POLICING ITS OWN
INDUSTRY IN THIS COMMITTEE.
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN EDGE JOINT
LIABILITY FOR PENALTIES OR
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES FOR WAGE
THEFT IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. THIS IS A INTERESTING
JOINED SEVERAL LIABILITIES A
CENTURIES OLD LEGAL CONCEPT FOR
pSHARED RESPONSIBILITY THAT
PLAYED AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
ABOLITION OF CHILD LABOUR IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS.
IT'S NOT A PANACEA BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT STEP. SCHERING
LIABILITY AS A WAY OF CHANGING
BEHAVIOR. WE'VE TAKEN SEVERAL
SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED BY CONTRACTORS
BECAUSE THEY MADE SENSE. WE
DROP THE LIABILITY FOR FAILURE
TO PAY WORKERS COMP INSURANCE
AND UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE NOT
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO. BUT
BECAUSE OF THE CONTRACTORS
POINTED OUT IT IS LITERALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE DIRECT
CONTRACTOR TO MONITOR THOSE
PAYMENTS. WE PROVIDED AN OFF
RAMP. FROM THE ADDED LIABILITY
MODELED ON EXISTING PUBLIC
WORKERS THAT PUBLIC WORKS
STATUTES IF A DIRECT CONTRACTOR
REGULARLY MONITORS THEIR SUB
CONTRA TRACTORS. LEGALLY
REQUIRED PAYROLL RECORDS AND
DILIGENTLY TAKES CORRECTIVE
ACTION WHEN THERE'S A PROBLEM.
A RECENT NEWSPAPER ARTICLE
ACACIA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OVER
LUNCH IF YOU CAN WIND UP ALMOST
DONE BUT I WAS SORT OF DOING
THE TO. STEPHANIE I AM GOOD I'M
ALMOST AT. THAT HEY THERE WAS A
RECENT NEWSPAPER ARTICLE IN
CASE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
OVER ONE MILLION STOLEN WAGES
DISCOVERED BY WORKERS COMP
AUDIT. ENDED WITH THIS
STATEMENT PROSECUTORS CANNOT
IDENTIFY MANY OF THE ELIGIBLE
WORKERS BECAUSE OF SCANT
EMPLOYEE RECORDS THAT'S GOT TO
STOP SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN IS
NOT A PANACEA BUT WILL MAKE A
DENT. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THIS IS NOT A
WAGE BILL THERE ARE NO WAGE
STANDARDS BEYOND ALREADY
EXISTING LAW MINIMUM WAGE EIGHT
HOUR DAY AT CETERA IT'S A WAGE.
THEFT BILL TO PLAY BY THE RULES
BILL. KEEP LEGALLY. PAYROLL
RECORDS AND PAY WHAT YOU
PROMISE NO CHEATING NO LOOKING
THE OTHER WAY WHEN YOUR
SUBCONTRACTOR BREAKS THE LAW.
THIS BILL WILL HELP WORKERS GET
WHAT THEY EARN AND WIL GIVE US
CONTRACTORS THAT PLAY BY THE
RULES A CHANCE TO GET BACK INTO
THE INDUSTRY. I WANT TO
ESPECIALLY THANK CENTER THE
LABOR FOR THE HARD WORK SHE'S
BEEN DOING ON THE CENTER STAFF.
PARTICULAR IN THIS DIFFICULT
TIME. WE AFTER I VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH-
ANYONE IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
BILL PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JEREMY SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HI ANYONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS SUPPORT. SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. WILL MOVE
ON MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN. TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AN
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE AND THEN PLACE
IT BACK INTO THE QUEUE. SO WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS
COMING UP FOR THIS BILL AND
IT'LL BE ADELINE THREE SIXTY
NINE TO START. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS TIMOTHY RIGHT FROM
SEEING IT FEEL REPRESENTED BY
CARPENTERS LOCAL TWENTY TWO
PRETENDING TO FIX. IT THIS CALL
WE ARE LOGGING IN SUPPORT OF.
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIND
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ED EVANS
WITH CARPENTERS UNION LOCAL TWO
SEVENTEEN REPRESENTING SAN
MATTEO COUNTY CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. THE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
WILLIAM THAT DID REPRESENTATIVE
UP PLUMBERS AND STEAM FITTERS
LOCAL FOR SIXTEEN KERN COUNTY
I'M JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES OF THE PORT SB SEVEN TWO
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAN
MCCALLUM SENIOR FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE FOR CARPENTERS-
UNION LOCAL SEVEN FIFTY ONE AND
THIRTY FIVE COVER IN MARIN
SONOMA NAPA LAKE MENDOCINO
HUMBOLDT AND DEL NORTE COUNTIES
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. NINE THREE OH EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY THREE TWENTY. GIVE
ME THREE OH EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
NINE THREE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARE MOVING ALONG WITH A
LIGHT THREE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TO KEEP
GOING WITH THE DISTRICT COUNCIL
OF OUR WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA
BUT THE THING CENTER LABELS ON
SUPPORTED FROM SIX THANK YOU.
AND LINE THREE SEVENTY NINE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MARIO
SANTA CRUZ WOULD MILLWRIGHTS
LOCAL ONE OF TWO REPRESENTING
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FORTY
SIX COUNTIES WE AREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I STANDARD
INSULTS THE SHEET METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE ZERO FIVE THREE FOR
THE BILLING TRADING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND MOVING ALONG WE
WILL GO TO LINE THREE OH FIVE
YOU ARE ALL THAT. SH HI THIS IS
A BUSINESS AGENT WITH LOCAL
SIXTEEN PROCESS LETTER
SOMEWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES AT
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TWENTY THREE OH FIVE
EXCUSE ME ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOU
ARE ALL BUT. FOR I'M MOVING
ALONG WILL BATTLE LINE TWENTY
THREE. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
EUGENE MORRIS WITH CARPENTERS
LOCAL ONE FIFTY TWO
REPRESENTING SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
STANISLAUS MERCED CALAVERAS
WOLLEMI AMADOR MARIPOSA COUNTY.
COLLEGE STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIVE ONE OH SEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
PAUL MARINO WITH IRON WORKERS
LOCAL FOUR THIRTY THREE AND
WE'RE STANDING IN SUPPORT WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES FOR
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. FIND ONE HUNDRED TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CAPITAL AND I'M REPRESENTING
THE PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS
LOCAL FOR SIX SEVEN HERE IN
SANTA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOU ARE ALL THAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS GLENN LEVEL
IRONWORKERS UNION LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT I THINK IT'S ALL
THERE TO USE EIGHT BILLION
TRADE BETTER BILLION IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB. SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE TWO NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MY NAME
DATE OPEN WORLD REPRESENTING
PLUMBERS AND FITTERS LOCAL
SEVEN SIXTY ONE AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SO
THE LINE OF THIRTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
FROM SCHOOL OVER THE YEARS-
PROPERTIES IN YOUR LOCAL TWENTY
TO THIRTY SIX INVESTING STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS TONY WHEN YOU ALSO WITH
CARPENTERS LOCAL SEVEN THIRTEEN
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA COUNTY
CULMINATE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
BORDERLINE THREE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NOW THIS IS
MY GREAT WHAT DID YOUR JOB
SECOND GAIN THEIR KNOWLEDGE
RIGHT DOWN STATE ROAD TRIED TO
DEPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHY NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STEVE
ALONG WITH DISCOUNTS OF SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO A PHOTO
LINE OF FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH MY NAME GET THE
GREER WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE AND JOIN
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
THEIR SUPPORT OF SEVENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
OF THREE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JEFF
YOU'RE PROBABLY THE
REPRESENTING CARPENTER LOOK ONE
PARTICULAR CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN. THANK YOU.
NEXAVAR LINE OF SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS BRANDON ROAD LOCK THE
DISCOUNT AFFECTING SANDERS ALLY
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRAVéS SUPPORT.
THANKS A LOT A LOT OF THREE OH
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN- THANK YOU
KAREN COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS A
SHAUN HEBARD REPRESENTING
COMPANIES LOCAL FIVE OH FIVE
AND SIX OH FIVE SANTA CRUZ OR
MONTEREY COUNTY. MEMBERS ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT OVER THE LINE OF
THREE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS RAHEL
NEAR THEM WITH THIS ACCOUNT
SIXTEEN PAIRS ALLY TRADED WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ABOUT ONE
OF SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE ROB STOKER
REPRESENTING SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OF FOUR AND
WE'RE JOINING WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
AN EXTRA LINE OF THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS RYAN
REPRESENT THE BURGLARS TYLER'S
ALLY CROPPERS LOCAL THREE FORTY
FIVE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SAN WEIRD STRONG SUPPORT OF.
FIFTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR THE LIGHT OF
THE THREE SIXTY SEVEN. THREE
SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GREETINGS I'M HERE MY NAME IS
JASON GOING WITHOUT THOUGH I'M
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL FIVE NINE FIVE
AND WE STAND. WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF
THE LIGHT OF FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MARTINEZ BUT OF THE
JUNIOR CALLING ON BEHALF LOCAL
THIRTY FOUR PARAGRAPH WHICH
REPRESENTING THIRTEEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS DROPPED FORTY SIX
COUNTY THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE AREN'T STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OCTOBER LINE OF ONE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS I GET
BLOATED I AM THE BUSINESS A
UNIT LOCAL FOR SIXTY PLUMBERS
AND PIPEFITTERS I WOULD LIKE TO
JOIN THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANKS OF OUR LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS TONY TURNER WITH THE
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX
HERE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'LL BE HAPPY MARKET DAHLE
THE MEMBERSHIP HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR LABEL FOR THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MIX
OF A LOT OF ONE OH SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE PARK BUCK FROM IBEW
LOCAL FIVE NINE FIVE
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA. THAT
JOAQUIN CALAVERAS COUNTY WHERE
THEY STAND ACROSS THE BOARD SB
SEVEN TWO SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANNEX OF A LINE OF
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MINIMUM JOHN PART ONE I'M
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOOKING AT FORT WAYNE
AT A KERN COUNTY CALIFORNIA
WITH HIM TO STATE BUILDING
TRADES INSTRUCTOR PART OF THE
BILL SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
LINE OF EIGHTY TWO AIRLINES
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS GILBERT
PREETO I'M FROM LOCAL FOR
THIRTY ONE TEAMSTERS UNION
JOINT COUNCIL SEVEN AND I AM
JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES AND THEIR SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN TWO SEVEN. THANK YOU.
PINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON RUSSELL
LAMB BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE
FOR DISTRICT THREE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OFFERING
ENGINEERS LOCAL TWELVE WE
REPRESENT A CURRENT ANNUAL
MODEL COUNTIES AND WE ARE DOING
A STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
SUPPORTING SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARGUED
BELCHER AND WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL AND IT'S WRONG SUPPORT
OF THE S. B. SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXUS OUR
LINE OF THREE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I HAVE DOUBLE
FIVE STUDENTS IN THAT MEETING
WITH LOCAL THREE HUNDRED. AND
IN YET MORE WORK THANK. SOKOTO
LINE OF FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINES
OPEN. AN EXTROVERT SO LINE OF
THREE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS
MET COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WERE HAPPY
TO BE HERE TODAY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE SHOULD
LOOK TO COULD HAVE THANK YOU
NEXT TO. THAT'S ABOUT TO LINE
SIXTY AIRLINES OPEN. PINE SIXTY
ALIGNED OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON
WELCOME TO A LINE OF FORTY
THREE YOUR LINES OPEN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S MANDY
PINERA MODERATE TANKERS COUNTY
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AND WE'RE JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN THE
SUPPORT. OF SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OF A
LINE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINES
OPEN. GET UP IN A CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AMANATULLAH
DEBRA LOOK ON BEHALF OF CARBON
LOCAL FORTY SIX SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND DRIVE A LAP
LOCAL NINETY ONE ONLINE.
REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO YOLO
YUBA. FOR ALL THE ROB BONTA BE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN TWO
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE OF THREE OR
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHE INVESTMENT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HREE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE TERM
MEMBER CAITLIN VEGA ON BEHALF
OF THE TEAMSTERS PORT DIVISION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THREE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINES OPEN. YES THIS IS MARTIN
RODRIGUEZ PRESIDENT TRY COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES REPRESENTED
VENTURA SANTA BARBARA SAN LUIS
BUT CAN OBISPO COUNTY SEVENTY
FIVE ONE MEMBER STRONG AND WORD
STRONG SUPPORTER WAS STATE
BUILDING TRADES AND SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
KRISTOFFERSON WERE DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES. AND WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWO
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT CHAU LINES OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS JOHN SPALDING
REPRESENTING THE KERN INYO AND
MONO COUNTIES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF
THE SENATE BILL SEVEN TWO
SEVEN. EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU I'M THAT'S
WHAT OUR POSITIONS SILVIO
FERRARI. AND IS HERE IN THE
ROOM AND YOU MAY. BEGIN
WHENEVER. ACTUALLY THE
MICROPHONE SET UP. SO BEGINS
SOON AS THE MICE READY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBER- MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SYLVIA FOR OUR BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION-
YOU KNOW. EVERYTHING WE JUST
HEARD ABOUT WAGE THEFT ABOUT
GETTING BAD ACTORS WE ARE FULLY
ALIGNED WITH THAT I'M SENATOR
LEYVA WE ARE FULLY ALIGNED WITH
THAT. WE ARE HERE TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY AND OFFER MEN IS TO TRY
TO MAKE IT WORK- THE VERY
FOUNDATION OF THIS BILL IS
BUILT OFF A CONCEPT OF PAYROLL
REVIEW BEING CONDUCTED. OF OUR
SUBCONTRACTORS SO SUBCONTRACTOR
EMPLOYEE WE HAVE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT INFORMATION SO THAT
PAYROLL REVIEW CAN BE DONE IF
THAT FOUNDATIONAL ELEMENT IS
NOT DONE WELL AND IT IS NOT
DONE CORRECTLY. THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE MEANINGLESS BECAUSE
WE WILL NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
COURT RECORDS THAT ARE
MEANINGFUL SO THAT WHO EVER
LOOKS AT THEM CAN LOOK AT IT
AND DETERMINE IF THERE IS A
VIOLATION OF LAW. THAT IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO MAKING THIS BILL
WORK IT WILL NEVER WORK IF WE
DON'T GET THAT RIGHT WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS COULD BE A TOOL FOR
THE GUT. WE ARE ASKING FOR SOME
FLEXIBILITY WE ARE COMING TO
YOU TO SAY LISTEN WE WILL BE
HELPFUL WE WILL BE
PARTICIPATORY BUT WHEN WE ARE
NOT WAGE THEFT INVESTIGATORS
OUR MEMBERS ARE NOT STAFFED UP
WITH PEOPLE IN THEIR OFFICES
WHO ARE. TRAINED AND HAVE
TAKING CLASSES AND HAVE
EDUCATION AND HOW TO PILE
THROUGH WHAT COULD BE. HUNDREDS
OR THOUSANDS OF PAYROLL RECORDS
AND IDENTIFY A VIOLATION OF LAW
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY DO. JUST
YESTERDAY WE SUBMITTED A THIRD
SET OF AMENDMENTS WHAT WE
THOUGHT WERE PARED BACK THAT
AMENDMENTS WOULD SAY. THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT COULD DO THE
REVIEW. THEY ARE CURRENTLY THE
ENFORCING AGENCY TO DO THIS
THEY ARE- THEY ARE EQUIPPED
THEY ARE SKILLED AT THIS IT IS
WHAT THEY DO NUMBER THREE.
DON'T BE THROWN OFF BY THIS WE
WILL PAY FOR IT. SO ARE
AMENDMENTS WERE CLEAR THAT WE
WILL PAY FOR THAT WILL BE A
COST WE KNOW THAT WE WILL PAY
FOR IT. AND I WE HOPE OUR
AMENDMENTS WERE CLEAR THAT EVEN
IF THE LSE DOES THE REVIEW WE
ARE NOT BEING ASKED TO BE
RELIEVED OF ANY LIABILITY WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ON THE HOOK
FOR PENALTIES. FOR EIGHT
ANYTHING ELSE LIQUIDATED
DAMAGES AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT EMPLOYEE GETS PAID WE HAVE
NO PROBLEM WITH THE NEXT
PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT SAYS
HALL PAYMENT RECTIFY THE ISSUE
GET THE EMPLOYEE PAID. WE WILL
DO THOSE THINGS WE ARE COMING
TO YOU TO TELL YOU THERE IS A
BETTER WAY TO DO THIS. I MEAN I
THINK THEY'RE IT'S SAFE TO SAY
THERE IS A LOT OF. DISTRUST
AMONGST DIRECT CONTRACTORS SUBS
EMPLOYEES EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN.
IT ISN'T CLEAR TO US WHEN WE
ARE SAYING HEY WE ARE NOT THE
RIGHT PEOPLE TO DO THIS. WE
HOPE THAT IS TAKING A HEART WE
ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS WITH WE HEART PHILLY
FEEL LIKE WE'VE OFFERED A FEW
OFFERS OF AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
THIS WORK. HAPPY TO KEEP THAT
CONVERSATION GOING BUT AT THIS
TIME A POST THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. THAT'S BECAUSE ON
TWENTY SEVEN NOT WILL GO TO
MONTEZ THE MONEY AND THEN
MODERATOR ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN THE ZERO. ONE
NINE ZERO FAIR IN OPPOSITION OF
SB. SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. AND ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. AND
THEN AGAIN IT IS ONE THAT IS
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION.
OF THE SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF TWO
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN.
MISTER AREN MEMBERS PARKING
CHEN FEN ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
TO AT THE TIME TO CHECK THANK
YOU SO MUCH I DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
YOUR BILL MOTION A SECOND
SUMMER GONZALEZ. I AND I DON'T
KNOW I HAVEN'T OBVIOUSLY HAD A
CHANCE TO ASK- THE YOUR SPONSOR
BUT IT IT SEEMS AS IF- THE
BUILDERS ARE GETTING INTO A
PLACE OF TRYING TO OFFER UP A
SOLUTION THAT'S GRACEFUL OF
JUST WONDER IF THERE'S BEEN ANY
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE THE
RIGHT PERSON ASKED IF THERE'S
BEEN ANY DISCUSSION WITH. THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE IF
THEY'D EVEN BE WILLING TO DO
THIS IF THE FUNDING WAS THERE
WE CAN I WILL TO SAY WE JUST
GOT THE AMENDMENTS YESTERDAY WE
ARE LOOKING AT THEM WE DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTIONS WE JUST DON'T KNOW. I
WOULD SAY THAT WE HAVE HAD A
LOT OF REALLY GOOD DISCUSSIONS
WITH C. B. I A AND I APPRECIATE
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH US AND WE GET
SOMETHING SO AS WE ALL KNOW
SOME AMENDMENTS ROCKFORD IN
THERE JUST NOT WORKABLE TO WHAT
YOU WANT TO DO IN THE BILL. BUT
I APPRECIATE THAT THEY CONTINUE
TO TRY TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING SO THAT WE CAN GET
THEM TO A SUPPORT OR EVEN AT. A
NEUTRAL POSITION SO WE'LL KEEP
TALKING. THANK YOU SIR WHAT
NINE I ALSO REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THIS ON- I'M
WONDERING IN IN ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS YOU HAD IF YOU FEEL
LIKE THE EMPLOYERS HAVE THEIR
CAPACITY RIGHT NOW TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE ALL OF THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO REALLY THAT THE
THAT THE FILES- AND TO TALKING
TO THE POINT ARE RAISED. AM I
APPRECIATE YOUR STUDYING THESE
IS ERROR ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITIES WITHOUT LETTING
RESPONSIBILITY THAT I THINK
THAT WHAT WE ARE GOING TO IT
WHAT WOULD WANT TO ACHIEVE IN
THIS BILL- WHAT WHAT ARE SOME
OTHER WAYS THAT THEY MIGHT BE
ABLE TO- HAVE THE SUPPORT
NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO COMPLY
WITH THE BILL HOUSES EMPLOYMENT
SO WITH THAT YES THE NOTE HERE
ANSWER I THINK THAT THE
EMPLOYERS ARE READY THEY DO
HAVE THE CUT- CAPACITY IN THE
CAPABILITIES IN SOME REGARDS
BUT I THINK IT TOO CBA'S POINT
WOULD YOU WANT AN ACCURATE LIST
AND WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- THEY KNOW WHO THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR- SO WE'RE JUST
CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN COME UP WITH
THE CLEAN THIS BILL POSSIBLE
THAT ACTUALLY. SOLVE THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE WAGE THEFT
SHOULD NOT BE A COST OF DOING
BUSINESS AFTER AND THIS IS ON
THE PAST TO APPROPRIATIONS OKAY
GREAT LIMITED ISSUE EDITION
ASSURING THEM AND THEN
APPROPRIATIONS FALL OKAY SO THE
REAL MARK SOME OPPORTUNITIES TO
BE ABLE. TO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU VERY S. I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE. IT IN
CASE THAT WASN'T CLEAR I AM. SO
OF THIS BILL I'M- I WAS JUST
ASK BECAUSE WE DO WANT IT TO BE
WE WANT TO WORK I DON'T I FEEL
LIKE IN YOU AND I BOTH HAVE
BEEN LABOR MOVEMENT- BEFORE
COMING INTO OFFICE AND- I
REMEMBER GOING OUT TO. IMPERIAL
COUNTY WHICH IS PART OF MY-
JURISDICTION THEY FELL CHAU N.
JUST. SEEN LINES OF- A LICENSE
PLATES FROM OTHER PLACES- AND
ONE OF THE MANY THINGS THAT IS
OFTEN USED TO PULL PEOPLE IN
AND- CIRCUMVENT THE LAW WAS
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS I MEAN AND
IT'S LIKE WHACK A MOLE
BASICALLY ESPECIALLY WITH THEM
THE SUBCONTRACTORS AND THE
THEIR ABILITY TO BRING AND- YOU
KNOW KIDS LABOR CHILD LABOR
LABOR FROM MEXICO LABOR FROM
UTAH AND ARIZONA- AND JUST
RIGHT HERE BUT YOU KNOW
VIOLATING THE LAW SO. THIS IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT- AND I
KNOW HOW MANY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WE LOSE A YEAR BECAUSE
OF THIS AT THE STATE EVEN- SO
THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS BILL
I'M FULLY SUPPORTIVE IF WE CAN
FIGURE OUT A WAY. TO ENSURE
THAT THIS IS- AT THAT THAT THE
BUILDERS CAN ACTUALLY DO THIS
IS WHAT WE I THINK WHAT WE WANT
TO DO AND I DON'T KNOW IF- IN
IT. IF IT'S OKAY IF I CAN ASK
THE SPONSOR THEN IF THAT THE
DISCUSSIONS ARE ONGOING. YES
ABSOLUTELY. SO AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS PROCESS- I
MADE IT CLEAR AND WE MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT IF IT'S GOING TO
ACTUALLY HELP GET THE JOB DONE.
OR WERE YOU CANNOT MONITOR IT
WE WILL NOT REQUIRE YOU TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOMETHING YOU
CAN'T MONITOR. BUT A GOOD
PORTION OF THE INDUSTRY ALREADY
DOES THIS. AND THEY DO HAVE
SUPERINTENDENCE AND THEY DO
HAVE TO SCHEDULE THIS MASSIVE.
YOU KNOW PROJECT. AT THE LARGER
THE MORE COMPLICATED AND THEY
DO HAVE PEOPLE WATCHING HOW
MANY WORKERS FOR THE SUB THEY
HAVE CONTRACTS SO IT'S DOABLE-
THE IDEA OF PAYING THE D. I. R.
WAS BROUGHT UP YESTERDAY HE
CAN. YOU MIGHT IMAGINE WE WERE
QUITE INTERESTED IN THE CONCEPT
BUT IT WAS KINDA LATE BOB
THERE'S NOTHING IN IN THE LAW
THAT SAYS THEY CAN'T HIRE.
SOMEBODY TO HELP AUDIT YOU KNOW
OR NOT AUDIT BUT AT LEAST
REVIEW IT'S NOT MANDATORY THAT
EVERY SUBCONTRACTOR HAS TO
PROVIDE. ALL OF THEIR PAYROLL
ROLL RECORDS ALL OF THE TIME
JUST WHEN THEY ARE ASKED TO
HAVE TO OR YOU WITH HOLD WHAT
YOU OWE THEM FOR THOSE PAYROLL
RECORDS THAT THAT'S A FAIRLY
POWERFUL A TOOL RIGHT THERE.
YOU DON'T REALLY HAVE TO HAVE
BOXES OF IT WHEN YOU SUSPECT
SOMETHING YOU SEE LESS PEOPLE
ON THE JOB. YOUR SUPERVISOR
SEAT LEFT PEOPLE ON THE JOB FOR
YOU KNOW WHATEVER THE CONCRETE
PORTION OF IT. YOU SEE LET'S
SEE YOUR PAYROLL RECORDS AND
THEN YOU START THE BALL ROLLING
BUT WE ARE. ACTUALLY IN
CONVERSATION QUITE A BIT AND
OUR EYES WELL IMPRESSED WITH
THE CONCEPT THAT- WE WENT FROM
SORT OF- WE DON'T NEED TO DO IT
WE DON'T WANT TO DO IT AND
MAYBE YOU KNOW HOW TO DO IT OR
WE CAN. IF WE COULD FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO IT WE WOULD DO IT.
THAT'S A BIG MOVEMENT SO WE'RE
WE'RE WILLING TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION QUITE A BIT. I
THINK IT'S FANTASTIC IF WE CAN
FIND CREATIVE WAYS TO GET MORE
MONEY INTO ON LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT AND GENERAL. STATE
SO I JUST WAS INTRIGUED A
LITTLE OR TO THE CONTINUE
CONVERSATION OBVIOUSLY I SAID
ON JUDICIARY. IT EVENTUALLY
COMES TO US AND APPROPRIATIONS
SO LOOK. FOR A CONTINUED WORK
ON OKAY THANK YOU. HI THANK YOU
ALL. SO MUCH AND LOOK BACK. FOR
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS FROM
SENATOR LEYVA. I WOULD JUST SAY
TO A FAMILY MEMBER INVOLVED AS
POINT IT'S EXACTLY RIGHT WE
WANT TO WORKABLE BILL- ANY BILL
THAT WE DO IT ENFORCEMENT. AND
HOW IT ACTUALLY IF IT IS SIGNED
INTO LAW HOW DOES IT ACTUALLY
IN THE REAL WORLD. ACTUALLY
WORKS AND IS IT PRACTICAL SO
WE'RE VERY COGNIZANT OF THAT
TOO BECAUSE IF WE'RE GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE YOU PUT SOMETHING
INTO LAW. THAT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM WITHOUT BEING
REDUNDANT- SO THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE QUESTIONS AND THE
DISCUSSION I APPRECIATE IT. AND
WE HAVE WORKED VERY WELL.
TOGETHER AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE DOING IT WE'VE GOT A
LITTLE WAYS TO GO AND- LIKE I
SAID HOPEFULLY CAN GET TO
SOMETHING THAT WHERE BY WALKS
WITH A LITTLE HAPPY. AND A
LITTLE UNHAPPY. SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY HOUSE FRONT ABOUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MANUFACTURE
TAKE ROLL. ON AS PRESENT MYSELF.
MOST IS TO PASS THROUGH
JUDICIARY. KALRA I KALRA AYE
LARA. AND SALAS. SALAS I JONES
SAWYER. RADIUS REASSIGNED ZERO
FORD. FORD II. THE DOES NOT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU AND UP NEXT TO
SANDERS STERN BE IT WE HAVE
JUST THREE BILLS LEFT BUT-
WE'VE BEEN GOING OUT OF FOR A
WHILE SO I'M GOING TO. LITTLE
MORE STRICTLY ANOTHER MORE
STRICTLY ENFORCED THE- TWO
MINUTES FOR WITNESSES A LOT OF
THE OTHERS WERE. WE DON'T HAVE
OPPOSITION SO AS LITTLE MORE.
LET'S GO CURRENTLY. I'M AYE
DOES GIVE THE GAVEL TO THE
SUMMER GONZALEZ. OKAY THAT
REALLY. OKAY SO MEASURE.
STARTED OFF TO GOOD START. I
WON'T TALK PASSED YES I'LL JUST
BRIEFLY STATE THAT THIS BILL IS
REALLY ABOUT UPPING OUR SAFETY
STANDARDS IN THE QUALITY OF
WAGES- IN IN THE SECTOR I THINK
THAT WE WRESTLE WITH THE OIL
AND GAS SECTOR WE HAVE TO BE
HONEST WITH OURSELVES AND
REALIZE THAT- WE DO PRODUCE A
LOT OF OIL AND GAS IN THE STATE
AND THAT. THE PEOPLE WORKING
THERE SECTORS- HAVE IMMENSE
SKILLS AND- THE STANDARD SHOULD
BE IMPROVED UPON AND FRANKLY-
THOSE JOBS CAN BE LIFE OR DEATH
AND SO THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
HAVING SKILLED AND TRAIN
WORKERS AND- AND SUBCONTRACTED
WORKERS PAYING LESS THAN
PREVAILING WAGE IS A PROBLEM.
IF WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA HAVE A
JUST ECONOMY WHICH I KNOW YOU
ALL SPENT A LOT OF TIME LOOKING
AT- IT STARTS IN IN IN ALL
SECTORS OF OUR OF OUR ENERGY
ECONOMY NOT JUST THE RENEWABLE
SIDE TOO SO- I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION HERE TODAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES- UP TO TWO MINUTES
EACH ANIMAL WILL USE THE
BUZZER. OF ALL THE WITNESSES
GOING FORWARD MORE STRICTLY BUT
WHAT WE HAVE WITH US RON MILLER
AND JEREMY SMITH AND- SO IF MR.
MILLER IS ON THE PHONE YOU MAY
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
OKAY THANK YOU CHAIRMAN. I'M
RON MILLER EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
OF THE LA ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES. BUT I'M HERE
TODAY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND SKILLED
AND TRAINED MEN AND WOMEN UP
AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH THOUSANDS THAT
MAKE A LIVING IN THE OIL AND
GAS INDUSTRY. IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. INSPIRED BY SB FIFTY
FOUR THE MAJORITY. OF
CALIFORNIA REFINERIES CONVERTED
TO A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. PRIOR TO THIS MOST
OF THE WORKERS WERE WHO
PERFORMED LABOR INTENSIVE WORK
IN THE REFINERIES. WERE A
TRANSIT WORKFORCE MOSTLY FROM
OUT OF STATE. NOT FROM
CALIFORNIA. AND DID NOT HAVE
THE LEVEL OF TRAINING THAT THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED.
TRADESPEOPLE HAD. ALSO THEY DID
NOT SPEND THEIR MONEY IN THE
COMMUNITY. INSTEAD THEY TOOK
MOST OF THEIR MONEY HOME WITH
THEM TO THE STATE THAT THEY
RESIDED IN. IS IT WAS IMPORTANT
FOR THE SAFETY OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO TRANSITION THESE
OPERATIONS. SO THE WORKERS WERE
THE MOST SKILLED AND TRAINED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN THE
COUNTRY. AND AT THEIR LOCAL
WORKERS WHO LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY. THAT ARE HOST TO THE
REFINERIES. THIS IS A VERY
DANGEROUS INDUSTRY AND HAS HAD
ACCIDENTS IN THE PAST WHETHER
THROUGH HUMAN ERROR LACK OF
UPKEEP TO THE INTERNAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE HAVE TO HAVE
THE UPMOST SAFETY IN MIND AND
THAT COMES OF TRAINING AND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADE SPENDING
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR ON
APPRENTICESHIP AND JURNEE
pWORKER TRAINING. THIS IS HOW WE
MAINTAIN A HIGH LEVEL OF
CONSISTENT SAFETY. THIS IS THE
SAME SOLID ARGUMENT THAT
SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
CALIFORNIA'S ALL FILLED SHOULD
BE MAINTAINED BY THE MOST
HIGHLY TRAINED AND DIVERSE
TRADES PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
WITH THE CHANGES THAT THIS
INDUSTRY IS FACING IN YEARS TO
COME. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
GET THE WORK FORCE IN PLACE SO
WE CAN DO THE WORK SAFELY INTO
THE FUTURE. WITH BOTH
REFINERIES IN CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES. WE HEARD FROM LOCAL
CONTRACTORS THEY WERE CONCERNED
WHEN THIS CHANGE HAPPEN. THAT
THEY WERE CONCERNED IT WAS NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THESE PROJECTS. WHAT WE
FOUND AROUND THE STATE FROM C.
R. C. OIL FIELDS IN LONG BEACH.
THE MID COAST AND KERN. AND THE
REFINERIES IN LOS ANGELES IN
THE NORTH BAY. THE CONTRACTOR
SIMPLY ADOPTED AND ENJOY THE
BENEFIT OF BRINGING ON A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE.
WE HAVE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO
ENHANCE THE HIRING OF MEN AND
WOMEN FROM THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT PROGRAMS WITH OUR
PRINTER SHIP READINESS
PROGRAMS. PUTTING VETERANS
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND FOLKS
FROM THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. INTO
WORLD CLASS APPRENTICESHIPS
THAT PROVIDE TRAINING THAT
LEADS TO GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
CAREERS WITH FAMILY HEALTH
CARE. IN A MODEST RETIREMENT
THANK YOU MISS MILLER. ENOUGH
ABOUT THESE. WE'RE PROUD OF THE
WORK OUR MEMBERS DO IN
CALIFORNIA'S OIL FIELDS AND
REFINERIES UTILIZING THE MOST
HIGHLY TRAINED WORKERS IN THE
NATION. TO PRODUCE HOMEGROWN
ENERGY UNDER THE MAASTRICHT
STRICTEST ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
AND REGULATIONS IN THE WORLD.
ALL THE WHILE SUPPORTING THE
LOCAL ECONOMY WHERE WE LIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND JEREMY SMITH WHO IS
HERE IN THE KINGDOM. JERRY YEAH.
BOB THE BIRDER THE OPRAH
CHANNEL OVER YES OKAY I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE I CAN
CAN DO MUCH BETTER THERE ON
MILLER JUST IT'S ALL JUST. A
SUFFICE TO SAY WE SUPPORT BILL
OR DRIVER THANK YOU THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT OF ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM PLEASE- ON BEHALF OF
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. STRUCTURE
MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE
HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION ELECTRICAL WORKERS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADES COUNCIL AND WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
UMBO NOW GO TO. REMOTE STATION
AND THEN MODERATOR THE FINGER
THE PHONE FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
SB. FOUR ONE NINE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB FOUR ONE
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE NINE ZERO FOUR S. B.
FOUR ONE ONE NINE. IN SUPPORT.
I WILL GO TO A LINE OF THREE
FIFTY FIVE- LINES OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT.
THANK YOU. EXTROVERTS THREE
FOUR FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHAIM KATZMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK NEXT OVER TO LINE OH A-
YOUR LINES. NINE THREE AWAIT
YOUR LINES OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS MATT COMMITTEE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
THAT A CONFLICT OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE ARE JUST SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE LINE OF EIGHTY YEAR
OPEN. YEAH THIS IS JEFF ROBERTS
WITH THE TO CAPITAL SIXTEEN
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES EXPAND STATE
BUILDING STROKES OF THANK THANK.
THANK OVER THE LINE THREE THREE
AIRLINE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN- CHANGED LACK OF
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL. IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS ABOUT THE LAW OF FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE SO. AND FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU
HAVE A TIME YOU. BERMAN BONTA
FOR TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS
IS KEITH DONE WITH THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL WIRE WORKERS IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA CITY WOULD LIKE
TO THANK CENTER STERN STAND
STRONG SUPPORTER OF S. BEFORE
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FIFTY
FOUR YEAR LINES OPEN. JACK
GREER THEY'RE OFFERING. LOCAL
ADJOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRAIN IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF THE
SB PORT FOR NINETY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT NEXT
TO A PHOTO LAI WITH SIX YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE THIRTY SIX.
GARY YES. MY NAME YOUNGER-
MATTER OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF LET'S WORKERS
FOR TWENTY EIGHT A CURRENT CA
ASSEMBLY BUILDING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL SB. FOUR
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT THE UP FOR- SPECTRUM
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS A LIST YOUNG BEHALF OF
THE INTER FROM OF. MISTER
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE ONE THIRTY SEVEN YEAR IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON GLOBAL.
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY A THE
FEELING WITH THE COUNCIL AND
OTHER BILLION IN STRONG. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
LINE OF THREE OH FIVE FELINES
THOUGH. HI THERE THIS NEW SOLAR.
FLARES LOCAL SIX IN WHICH THE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THOUGH TRADES
AND POOR NINETEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THEN NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLOYES GO AHEAD YES.
HELLO SIR. HELLO MY NAME IS
RUNNING KNOW WHAT THE WITHOUT
THE DEFENDERS ARE TRADING OF
THE DURING. THANK YOU. AND SO
LINE ONE FOUR YEAR OLD OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE TOP
FLORIDA I AM BUSINESS A YELLOW
COURSE PLUMBER AND I'VE BEEN IN
BAKER. I REPRESENT OVER EIGHT
MEMBERS AND IN CURRENT AND
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN BUILDING IN
STRONG SO. OF DEATH PEOPLE IN
NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE LINE UP
FOR NINE NO I OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBER TALK BALLOONS.
FOR THE SOUTHERN CONTRA
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING SOME
THE EMPLOYEE THAT WORK AT THE
SCHOOL. THANK YOU MUCH CHAIR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT VOTE
THE LION THREE NOW NINE YOUR
LINE OPEN. YOUR OPERATIVE.
SIXTEEN TEN I LIKE. WE STAND
WITH STATE BUILDING TRADE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO THE LINE THREE FOR YEAR
OPEN. YEAH THIS IS EVER AT THE
TOP OF STUDENTS. YOUR LINES
OPEN. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
UP AND THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RYAN ROUGH ON ME HAPPY
THE BURGLARS NOW LIKE PROPER
PRODUCES SD FOR ONE NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU KNOW ABOUT LINE
UP FOR ALL ONE YEAR LINES. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MAY- MY NAME IS JOHN HENRY
LOPEZ ON WITH THE THIS. OF
PLUMBERS PIPEFITTERS. LOCAL TO
SIX AND I WANT TO STAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT WITH THE BILL
TRAY AND ON S. B. FOUR ONE NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT
TO GO TO LAW OF ALL FIVE. LINES
OKAY. HELLO MY NAME IS PICKING
OPPORTUNITY DISTRICT SIX
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
WE- WITH THE BILL TRAIN INTO OF
S. FOUR NINE. THANK YOU. THANK
NEXT OF A THE LINE OF FORTY
THREE AIRLINES OPEN. NINE FORTY
THREE LINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YEAH MY NAME'S MATT
COMPARE I MET THE MODERATES CAL
BILLING TRADES CAL. AND IN
STRONG SO THE STATE'S TRADE FOR
AT B. HOME NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOT TO GO LINE OF
ALSO YOUR OPEN. WHAT I WAS
YEARS AS THOUGH. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES HI THIS IS TOM
RAIL WITH AYE WE'RE- THE FORTY
THREE AM WHERE YOU STANDING IN
SUPPORT OF THE STATE BILL
TRADES- ON BEFORE ONE NIGHT YOU
THE YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
TIMELINE OF. THREE FORTY EIGHT.
HMM KEEP IN VEGAS FOR THE
TEAMSTERS REPORT TO IN SOME.
THANK YOU. THANK AN ACT SO LINE
OF TWO YOUR LINE THOUGH. WELL I
EIGHTY TWO YEAR LINE OF THE- HI
MY NAME IS GILBERT PREVAIL I'M
FROM LOCAL THIRTY TEAMS UNION
JOINS CAL SEVEN AND I AM DURING
THE STATE BUILDING TRY AND THE
SUPPORT OF SB ONE NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE
LINE OF THREE SIXTY SEVEN LINES.
THREE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINES
OPEN. SORRY SHAPING THE TOP OF
YOUR WITH INTERNATIONAL OF A
WORKERS LOCAL FIVE NINE FIVE
JENNINGS STATE BUILDING TRADES.
OR- SB COLLECT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT TWO I
OF TO NAY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HI THIS IS A UP OF OUR
WITH CLAMOR IS BEING.
WUNDERPHOTOS SIXTY ONE WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF. NINETEEN THANK
YOU. YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE THOUGH.
THAT'S MY GREAT WITH THAT
YOU'RE. OUR KNOWLEDGE REYES
WERE DOWN THE STATE BUILDING.
TO THANK YOU NEXT OVER CAROLINA
FOR YOUR LINE OPEN. FINE FOR
FORTY YEAR LINE IS OPEN. AND
NEXT OVER SO UP FOR SIXTY YOUR
LINE OF OPEN. CONFERENCE IN
NINETEEN STILL WORKERS TO
TWELVE WE APPRECIATE YOUR KIND
TO WORK WITH SPENT AND REMAIN-
DURING THE PROCESS OF TRYING TO
GET YOUR- THANK YOU. THEY YOU.
AND I TOOK A LINE OF THREE SICK
EIGHT AIRLINES. ONE THREE SIX
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FEDERAL GOTO LINE OF THE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WILLIAM
THAT THE REPRESENTATIVE OF
PLUMBERS FIFTEEN THERE'S LOCAL
PORTS TO. REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND ANNUAL MODEL CAN
I'M GOING INTO BUILDING. AND
SUPPORT. FOUR NINE. DO YOU. AND
WE HAVE NOT OVER NOPE THE IN Q.
THE TIME MR THANK YOU UP NEXT
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE BEEN
HARD. AND RUBLE CALL. IS MR
HARMER HERE. OKAY AND THEN
MICHELLE OF THE COVER YEAH OF
ONE YOU GO AHEAD AGAIN- I TO ME
ABOUT FROM BOTH THE- THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER. MEMBER SHOVEL
ON BEHALF OF AB CAL. ABC
CENTRAL. AT THE OUTSET I'D LIKE
TO MAKE CLEAR EVERYONE. OUR
ORGAN. DO NOT OPPOSE THIS AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE CAL. THREE OF
OUR FOUR STATEWIDE CHAPTERS
PRODUCE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. AND SO THAT'S NOT
THE ISSUE HERE BUT WE DO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH SB
FOUR ONE NINE. BECAUSE IT
IMPACTS SEVENTEEN THOUSAND MEN
AND WOMEN WHO WORK IN KERN
COUNTY. NOW THOSE PEOPLE ARE
55% PEOPLE OF COLOR. SIX POINT
FIVE WOMEN. 18% VETERANS. AND
THIRTY PERCENT. FORMALLY
INCARCERATED. THESE ARE THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING IN KERN COUNTY IN THE
OIL FIELDS. AS THIS BILL AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED. ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TO. 30% OF
THAT WORK FORCE WILL BE
DISPLACED. AND THAT IS BECAUSE
THE REQUIREMENTS STATED IN THE
BILL. WILL FIND THEM TO BE.
UNFIT AND UNSAFE. GEORGE
HUMMERS GONNA TO THE C. ASK OF
THE BILLS I WANTED IN. BUT IN A
TIME OF COATED IN A TIME OF
SKYRIM. SKY HIGH ON IN RATES.
WIRE DISPLACING MEN AND WOMEN
IN KERN COUNTY. SOME OF THE
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND SO WE HAVE
REACHED OUT TO THE AUTHOR WE
HAVE ASKED FOR SOME AMENDMENTS.
I KNOW THERE WERE SOME
COMMITMENTS MADE. WE'RE HOPING
TO SEE LANGUAGE SOON WE HAVEN'T
SEEN ANYTHING YET WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE IS WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE.
A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION. WE
WOULD LIKE TO FIND A WAY TO.
PROTECT THOSE SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND WORKERS IN KERN COUNTY.
AND ALSO THERE IS A MULTI CROP
CURRICULUM. THAT IS USED IN
KERN COUNTY THAT WAS CREATED BY
THE OIL INDUSTRY FOR OIL AND
GAS WORKERS AND AS MR HARMER
WILL SAY RIGHT BEHIND ME HAS
PRODUCED SOME OF THE SAFEST
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA. I
REGINALD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MR HARMER I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A-
AS A MEETINGS ON JIM'S IS GOOD
TO SEE YOU IN PERSON SO YEAH AN
IDEA WILL YOU. UP MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GEORGE
HARMON I'M FROM BIGGER STILL
CALIFORNIA HERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR ONE NINE
THE WHOLE PREMISE OF THE BILL
FOUR ONE NINE IS BASED OFF THE
SAFETY. AND I'VE SHARED SOME
DATA WITH ALL OF YOU IN
ACTUALLY I'M SHARING DATA I
HAVE NOT HEARD ANY SUBSTANTIAL
SUSTAINABLE DATA FROM THE FOLKS
THAT ARE IN- THAT ONE SB FOUR
NINETEEN- TO PASS SO MY
QUESTION IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SAFETY AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
UNSKILLED AND UNTRAINED
WORKFORCE BUT THERE'S BEEN NO
DATA TO PROVE THAT THOSE FOLKS
ARE UNSKILLED OR UNSAFE AND THE
DEAD THE INFORMATION THAT I
PROVIDED YOU TODAY THE OIL AND
GAS SECTOR IS ONE OF THE- THE
SAFEST SECTORS OUT THERE WE'RE
ACTUALLY SAFER THAN REALTORS.
WITH THE T. R. I. R. OF POINT
EIGHT MOST FOLKS OUT THERE IN
THE INFORMATION I PROVIDED WITH
YOU PROVIDED YOU TODAY OR FOUR
POINT TWO OR BETTER SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOME FOLKS THAT
WE WANT TO TARGET. AND IF YOU
LOOK ON THE PAGE THAT I
PROVIDED YOU YOURS ISN'T IN
COLOR BUT I CAN SHOW YOU HERE
THE ONLY FOLKS THAT ARE IN
GREEN THAT MEANS GOOD READ IS
DANGER YELLOW IS CAUTION IS
YOU'LL AND GAS SECTOR AND I WON
A STEP FURTHER AND BROKE OUT
JUST THOSE CONTRACTORS. THAT
THE GOOD GENTLEMAN SAID EARLIER
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR ONE NINE
THAT ACTUALLY THESE FOLKS ARE
COMING FROM OUT OF STATE THAT
IS FALSE ALL THE CONTRACTORS
THAT SB FOUR ONE NINE IT'S
GONNA TARGET ONLY ONE COMPANY
HAS LESS THAN A 100% WORKING
LIVING AND RAISING THEIR KIDS
RIGHT HERE. IN KERN COUNTY OR
ACTUALLY IN KERN COUNTY WHERE
I'M FROM THERE 98% ALL OTHER
CONTRACTORS A 100% FROM THERE
WE HAVE AN AGGREGATE T. R. I.
R. OF THE POINT THREE. THERE'S
NO OTHER SECTOR OUT THERE THAT
IS BETTER THAN THE OIL AND GAS
SECTOR NEXT CONTRACTORS WORKING
IN THIS AND THIS BILL IS GOING
TO TARGET MY WANT TO READ AND.
CLOSE WITH THIS THERE'S A PUT
UP. THE BILL THAT SAID SKILL
JOURNEY. MEAN THE WORK WHO MAY
BOWL THE PHONE CREDITS YOUR ONE
OR BOTH. THE WORKER EITHER. OR
HE HAS ENOUGH TIME OUT THERE IN
THE FIELD SO THIS BILL SAYS
YOUR UNSKILLED AND UNTRAINED
TODAY. BUT WHEN THIS BILL COMES
INTO EFFECT BOOM. YOU'RE NOW
SKILLED AND TRAINED. DOES THAT
MAKE ANY SENSE TO ANYONE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. HI EVERYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION.
LEVINE TO REMOTE STATION. THANK
TO THE PHONE A MODERATE AND ONE
ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION. SB
FOUR ONE NINETY GIVEN UP AT THE
TOP. EVENT. FOUR ONE NINE. S.
ONE ZERO FOUR SEVEN ZERO UP OF
S. B. FOUR ONE NINE. AND WE
WILL GO OUR FIRST LINE OF EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MY NAME
IS JOBS AND I AM SUPPORT OF
FOUR NINE I COULDN'T READY. IN
THE OTHER VERY. AND I AM
SUPPORTER AND ALCOHOL RIGHT.
TWENTY THIS BUILDING TRADES
THANK YOU MUCH. THANK YOU AND
THAT WE WILL GO TO LINE OF POOR
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MEMBERS MARX AND FOR
THE WAY LIKE POWER IS. THERE'S
NEVER BEEN A SH OF THAT THAT'S
ENTRY. MAKES ANY. WE'RE OPPOSED
TO THE MEASURE THINK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEDNAX WILL GO TO
LINE OF SEVEN YEAR LINED THE.
GOOD EVENING TURN THEM NINETY
ON B. OF THE COUNTY BLOCKED OF
COMMERCE. THE CURRENT HAS
CHAMBER OF. AND THE DEFENSE
VALLEY BUT BETTER WHICH-
SEVENTY BUSINESSES THIRD.
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND FOR
HUNDRED- EMPLOYEES. THANK ALL
IN REGARDS TO PASSED THE ONE
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. MEXICO LINE OF
THREE NINETY YOUR LINES OF.
THURMOND PARK WOULD THE L.
EXTENDS FROM UP WITH THE BEFORE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU EXTROVERT
SO I OF FOR YOUR LINES OPEN.
YEAH THE DATABLE FOR WITH THE
TECH AND BAKER. WE HAVE A
KILLED IN TRAINING WILL FORCE
RIGHT NOW DOING A GREAT JOB OUT
THERE. STRONG UPPER TO FORMER
NINE. THANK NEXT THIRD OF
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINES ARE.
THREE NINETY FOUR YEAR OKAY.
HELLO MY ON TO A THREE YEAR
LINE SO. FIVE THREE EIGHT ZERO
YOUR LINES OPEN YOU HAVE A SIDE
NOTE. PINE FOR FIFTEEN YOUR
LINES OPEN. YEAH THE FIFTY
UPTON WITH TRUDEAU. AND HEARING
KERR COUNTY AND OPPOSE. THE
THANK YOU THANK WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP FOR YOUR LINES OPEN. IT
IS MARTIN PRESIDENT COUNTY PRAY
I DON'T GET ON THIS. INITIALLY
SO I AM SUPPORTING MMHM SB PORT
NINE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
VOTE SO I KNOW FOR ALL. THREE-
HI MY NAME IS GOOD AFTERNOON BY
NAME IS LESTER CARE OF QUANTUM.
I WAS OUT THE AMEND THAT
SENATOR STERN STATED THE RECORD
THAT HE WAS PRESENT THE SAM
WHICH INCLUDES. INCLUDED THE
CURRENT LAW AND GAS WORK FOR
WITHIN THAT THE MINORITY AND
SECTOR CHANCE ARE AT SKILLED
AND TRAIN AS OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK. SB FOUR ONE
HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THREE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINES
OPEN. MY NAME IS LAURA BARNES
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF THE THIRD SEEDED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND KERN COUNTY
OIL AND GAS WORKERS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB FOUR NINETEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTROVERT SO
I KNOW FOUR HUNDRED YOUR LINES
OPEN. HELLO YES. HELLO GO HEAD
TO HEAD THIRTY NINE OPEN. YES
MY NAME IS TIED TO PASS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL- I
FEEL LIKE WE'RE KIND OF LOOKING
TO ECHO CHAMBER OF- DON'T EVEN
WORK IN OUR IN OUR KERN COUNTY
LIVE AND WORK HERE IN CASPER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE
LONG FLOOR ANY. COMMENTS SOME
REWARD THANK YOU VERY IN THE
SPORT IS CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
AND I SUPPORT THE INTENT OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO TO
RAISE THAT STANDARD FOR FOUR
WEEKS BACK- I'M CURIOUS ANNIE
AND ANALYSIS- SB FIFTY FOUR-
BYE CENTER HANCOCK THEN- CHAT
ESTABLISHED SKILLED AND TRAINED
AND FOR OIL REFINERIES AND- OR
IF- IF SOMEBODY FROM THE
BUILDING TRADES ALSO- WERE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THAT EITHER THE
AUTHOR SO HOW DOES THIS GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT IS A
SOUND SORT OF. OTHER OTHER WORK
WORKPLACE OF OTHER WORK SITES.
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WILL SITES-
PIPELINE INFRASTRUCTURE THE
FEEDING LINES IN- THIS KIND OF
PLUGGING AND ABANDONING JOBS A
LOT OF THAT THE WELL WILL HEAD
IN THAT SITE WORK AS OPPOSED TO
THE REFINING WORKS ON
EXTRACTIVE SIDES WE AND WHAT IS
WHAT AND WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
OIL REFINERIES IT'S NOT THAT WE
ALL OF A SUDDEN GOT PEOPLE FROM
OUT OF STATE CUNNINGHAM OR
EVERYONE LOST THEIR JOB RIGHT
EVERYBODY RAISED UP TO THE
STANDARD THAT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SEE YOUR FOR LABOR IN
CALIFORNIA. YEAH I THINK I
THINK SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION.
THEY WERE REYES ONE FIFTY FOUR
WAS BEING WITH PUT FORWARD BUT
THE- THE- BOTH THE
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS THAT
WERE PROMULGATED AND THEN. YOU
KNOW THE ACTUAL CONTRACTING
ACTIVITY THAT OCCURRED
AFTERWARDS DIDN'T. PUT A BUNCH
OF PEOPLE OUT OF WORK RIGHT SO-
I DON'T KNOW IF. YEAH I DON'T
TO. GO TOO DEEP IF THE
COMMITTEE OESN'T WANT TO GO
THAT DEEP BUT I I'M SURE MR
MILLER HAS. AN INSIGHT ON X.
EXPERIENCE AND HOW IT SORT OF
PLAYED OUT IN PRACTICE BUT-
YEAH I SHOULD JUST NOTE I WAS
GONNA SAY THAT MY OPENING. SO
MEMBER BUT- THE AMENDMENTS WE
COMMITTED TO ON THE FLOOR WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO IT I DIDN'T
QUITE SUMMARIZE THOSE OFF FOR
YOU IN THE COMMITTEE BUT WE DO
PUSH OUT THE- START DATE OF THE
BILL AS WELL TO TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. OKAY SO. THE JUST TO BE
CLEAR AND I DON'T WANT TO GO
BACK ON MY WORD OR M. CONCERN
ANY OPPOSITION WE'RE NOT
CHANGING THAT COMMITMENT IT
ALSO. IT DOES START IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. I'M NOT TWENTY TWO
WE JUST HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO GET
AUTHORS IMMENSELY AND SORT OF
FIGURE THAT OUT WITH CAMILLA
OKAY. GIVE EXISTING EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYEES THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THAT STANDARD
EXACTLY HAVE TRANSITION DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME AND FRANKLY
IT MEANS THAT THE SKILL JOURNEY
PERSON ANGLE IN. ALLOWS FOLKS
NOT TO BE SKILLED AND TRAINED
RIGHT AWAY AND HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM THAT THEY CAN GET
CREDIT FOR PAST HOURS WORKED IN
THE INDUSTRY EXCELLENT SO. THAT
SHOULD THAT SHOULD SOLVE ALL
WELL DOCTOR NOT APPRECIATE HIS
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND
SOME HAPPY TO THINK WHAT THE
BILL THAT I THINK. THANK YOU.
THIS ARE YOU. CALLING ME YES
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. SO
SORRY I WAS LATE TO THE PARTY
HERE- BUT- I'M STRUGGLING WITH
HIS BILL AND THE REASON I'M
STRUGGLING WITH IT IS BECAUSE
THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A
PROBLEM IN FACT THERE SEEMS TO
BE THE OPPOSITE OF THE PROBLEM
IN THIS PARTICULAR FIELD IN
THAT PARTICULAR AREA- THE
PEOPLE THEY'RE WORKING THEY'RE
HAPPY- THE- THERE DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE A SAFETY ISSUE IN FACT
JUST THE OPPOSITE THEY'RE SAFER
THAN ANY OTHER INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA BASICALLY- WERE.
THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL. TO
DISPLACE WORKERS THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY HAVE BEEN ALL
ABOUT TRYING TO HELP. IN THE
LAST YOU KNOW THE FROM SINCE
I'VE BEEN HERE AND- SEVEN
MONTHS THAT'S ALL I'VE HEARD IS
WE'VE GOT TO HELP PEOPLE THAT
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY BEING
AFFECTED BY. YOU KNOW WHATEVER
IT IS HEARING IN CALIFORNIA
THAT IS THAT WE'RE DOING- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RECIDIVISM AND
YET WE HAVE. AB 830% POPULATION
WHERE PEOPLE THAT USED TO BE IN
PRISON CAN ACTUALLY GO. GET A
JOB. AND ACTUALLY. TAKE CARE OF
THEIR LIVES. REYES FAMILIES GET
STRAIGHT N. AND STAY THAT WAY-
MINORITY POPULATIONS WHO
ORDINARILY MIGHT NOT HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO HAVE WELL
PAYING JOBS. AND HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS AND SEND THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL AND WATCHING GRADUATE
WITHOUT HAVING- LOANS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. THIS SEEMS TO
BE ABLE TO FOR THEM TO DO THAT
SO I'M KIND OF CURIOUS WHY
WE'RE EVEN GOING THERE WITH
THIS PARTICULAR SECTOR IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA. BECAUSE THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A SAFETY
ISSUE AND IF THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. WHY. IF A
MANAGER JUST VERY BRIEFLY- I DO
THINK WE HAD SAFETY ISSUES I
WOULDN'T I THINK WE'VE WE'VE
LOST LIFE- IN OUR PIPELINE
SYSTEM- I KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE INDUSTRY WIDE DATA BUT
YOU KNOW I WENT THROUGH THE
EARLY SO CANYON GHASTLY CAN HAD
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE POISON
IN MY BACKYARD AND PEOPLE ARE
STILL DEALING WITH ALL KINDS OF
INCIDENTS FROM- INADEQUATE
MAINTENANCE- AND A LACK OF
COMMITMENT ON THE SAFETY SIDE
SO AND I THINK THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE REAL AND- THAT THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM IS WHEN YOU'RE
SUBCONTRACTING OUT AND YOU'RE
NOT USING YOUR NOT PAYING
PEOPLE PREVAILING WAGE. WHICH
YOU CAN HEAR FROM THE GOOD
TESTIMONY OF FOLKS WHO ARE
PAYING PAYING THOSE WAGES BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF SUB STANDARD-
PAYMENTS GOING ON OUT THERE AND
SO- IT'S NOT SO MUCH THAT-
WE'RE SEEKING A PROBLEM WE'RE
TRYING TO SORT IT UP LIFT ALL
THOSE SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
WORKERS IT'S NOT NOT TRYING TO
SEND AN INDUSTRY ELSEWHERE
WE'VE BEEN WORRIED ABOUT THE
TURNAROUND JOBS COMING IN FROM
OUT OF STATE AND WE'RE WORRIED
THAT AMONG SO SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND IF THEY DON'T HAVE
STABLE EMPLOYMENT AND THEY'RE
GONNA SUBCONTRACTED JOB TO JOB
AND THEY'RE NOT BEING PRIVY TO
PAY PREVAILING WAGE DRIVE
ACCESS TO LONG TERM BENEFITS OR
PENSION OR RETIREMENT. THEN
THEY'RE GOING TO THEY'RE GOING
TO RISE AND FALL DEPENDING ON
WHAT OPEC OR PUTIN DOES AND I
DON'T THINK THAT'S A SAFE WAY
TO SET THAT WHOLE SECTOR
WORKERS UP FOR SUCCESS SO THIS
IS THIS IS REALLY SUPPOSED TO
STABILIZE- MAN ASSIST. NOT NOT
TO BE- AN IMPEDIMENT. IF YOU'RE-
THANK YOU THANK. YES KEEP HER
BRING IT FOR IT I THINK M. YOU
SAID EXACT WHAT I UNDERSTOOD
THE PURPOSE OF OUR PORTIONS OF
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL TO BE
AND THAT IS- TO UP LIFT A GROUP
OF WORKERS WHO MAY NOT HAVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
APPRENTICESHIPS OR TRAINING IN
THE PAST TO BE ABLE THEN OVER
THIS PERIOD TIME TO GET THOSE
AND THAT DOES HELP ACTUALLY NOT
JUST WITH THESE WORKERS BUT- AS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO A JUST
TRANSITION. IF WE LOOK AT WHAT
WILL HAPPEN TO A WORK FORCE AS
SOME OF THESE JOBS. MAY BE
PHASED OUT AND WHERE THEY GO
AND BE HAVING THAT ADDITIONAL
TRAINING SOME OF THEM WHAT
WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL TRAINING
PROBABLY HAVING THAT-
EXPERIENCE THAT CONNECTION-
QUITE FRANKLY TO A LARGER WORK
FORCE THAT THAT WE WILL THEN
HAVE TO UP THE STANDARD OF- OF
JOBS FOR ALL OF THESE FOLKS I
THINK THAT'S A POSITIVE THING
AND JUST LIKE IN CONSTRUCTION-
WE OFTEN HEAR FROM FOLKS WHO
WHO SAY WELL THIS IS GOING TO
DISPLACE THE WORKERS KNOW IT'S
GOING TO DISPLACE THE PROFITS
OF THE SUBCONTRACTOR. WHO
WASN'T PREVIOUSLY PAIN- THE
WORKERS ALL THE WORKERS
SOMETIMES YES WE HAVE YOU KNOW
GOOD CONTRACTORS ABOUT
CONTRACTORS BUT BUT THIS WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THE
SUBCONTRACTED WORKERS ARE
ACTUALLY PAID- APPROPRIATELY
WITH BENEFITS AND HAVE THE
TRAINING IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
SUCCEED NOT ONLY IN THIS- JOB
BUT ANY FUTURE JOB THAT MAY. BE
WHAT WE'RE TRANSITIONING TO SO
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL. I
THINK IT. AND THANK YOU AND I
HAVE TO SAY THE SAME CONCERN
AND ABSTRACT TO TALK TO SOME OF
THE WORKERS- ON AS SOON AND I'M
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT MR
TAYLOR MELINA VALDEZ OR IN OUR
PACKET THAT DOWN THAT THEY
DON'T LOSE YOUR JOB IN KERN
COUNTY IS REALLY IMPORTANT-
THAT WE DO THAT AS I CALLED THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS- WHO ARE
PART OF THE ELECTRICAL WORKERS.
A PLUMBER'S STEAM FITTERS
IRONWORKERS LABOR'S
PIPEFITTERS. UTILITY WORKERS
OPERATING ENGINEERS CARPENTERS
SHEET METAL WORKERS. JUST TO
NAME A FEW. THAT THEY COULD
TRANSITION AND COULD THAT WAS
THE QUESTION I ASKED. EACH OF
THESE. ENTITIES COULD WE
TRANSITION THEM OVER- AND STILL
WORK IN THE OFFICE BUT
TRANSITION INTO THESE TYPE OF
SKILLS AND IS A WAY TO DO IT.
IN FACT THEY SAID. MONEY OFF
SHORT SIDE THEY WERE. THEY WERE
ABLE TO DO THE SAME THING AND I
WANT TO DO THE SAME THING. AND
IN LINE IN ON SHORE AND SO WITH
THE WITH THE GUARANTEE AND THE
BEST A GUARANTEE YOU CAN GET.
THAT NO ONE WOULD LOSE THEIR
JOB- I'M GOING TO MOVE FORWARD
AND VOTE FOR THIS CADETS. FOR
ME THAT IS AND I THINK WITH
EVERYBODY BACK FROM SPEAK FOR
EVERYBODY ON THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT THAT- NO ONE LOSES A
JOB A HOUSE THE KANSEN THEIR
KIDS TO COLLEGE ALL OF THAT IS
REALLY REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND SO- WITH ADAM MOCO HEAD
BOTH FOR TODAY AND THEN.
HOPEFULLY IT'LL WORK OUT YOU
KNOW JUST SOME LAG TIME. WE GOT
TO GET THEM INTO
APPRENTICESHIPS AND- AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE- LET'S GIVE THEM
THAT TIME BECAUSE THAT IT AT
THE END OF THE DAY- EACH OF THE
SKILL SETS. IN EACH OF THESE
ARM TRADE UNIONS. THEY WANT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN. AS PART
OF THEIR UNIONS I. IS NOT LIKE
THEY WANT TO THROW THEM AWAY
IMPACT. AS A MEMBER OF A UNION
THAT'S THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
HOW GENES WORK WE WANT TO BRING
IN EVERYBODY IN. UNDER ONE TENT
ITSELF THANK. YOU THANK YOU AND
YES I HAVE SEEN SOME OF THE
WORK THAT THE SENATORS AND
PUTTING IT IN TERMS OF. MAKING
SOME MODIFICATIONS AND WORK
WITH OPPOSITION ON THAT.
ESPECIALLY ON THE TIMELINE. OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS
NATURAL RESOURCES WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE UNDER START. I
APPRECIATE- DEPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES REMARKS- FROM THE
SET THE SOUTHERN PART L. A. AND
YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T JUST A KERN
COUNTY ISSUE THIS IS OUR
BACKYARD ISSUE TOO I KNOW YOU
KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT IN A LOT OF
PARTS OF THE STATE BUT YOU DO
HAVE MY COMMITMENT THERE AND I
MADE THAT SAME COMMITMENT TO
ALL MY COLLEAGUES LIVE ON THE
FLOOR AS WELL SO- YET THIS IS
NOT- NOT SUPPOSED TO BE PUTTING
ANYONE OUT OF WORK IS SUPPOSED
TO BE UPLIFTING EVERYONE IN
WORK AND MAKE THIS WHOLE
ECONOMY NOT SO VOLATILE MORE
DURABLE SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY
RAISE A FAMILY IS AND NOT WORRY
IF YOUR JOB IS GOING TO GO
AWAY. YOUR TO THE NEXT SO- WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. PHONE THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER FOR MANUFACTURING CAN
CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS
TO NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
KALRA HI KALRA I FLOOR GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER FIVE
TUNES WERE IRATE. REYES ICE
SAILOR. NO THERE ARE NO. WORDS
WORD I DON'T THINK SO DOUBLES
UP. SB SIX SIX FIVE AUBURN MONA.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
RIGHT THANK YOU GOT. SHARE I
LEARNED A LONG TIME AGO HAT
WHEN THE GOING IN YOUR FAVOR
YOU DON'T TALK HER OUT OF IT
SO- THANK YOU A COUPLE COUPLE
COMMENTS THIS IS THE BILL'S
BEEN SUPPORTED BEFORE IT'S MUCH.
LESS BROADENED IN ITS IN ITS-
COVERAGE I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR THOUGH PERSONALLY AND I
THINK OF MEGAN LANE FOR THEIR
WORK THAT YOUR WORK ON THIS AT
SOME. THREATENS PERSONAL SAFETY
BECAUSE SEVERAL TIMES WE TALK
ABOUT WHEN YOU WERE ON THE WHEN
YOU WERE DRIVING. ON BLUETOOTH
THAT'S RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR RISKING YOUR LIFE FOR
THIS BILL- THE LET ME JUST
DESCRIBE THE CONSTRAINT THE
BILL DOESN'T PROVIDE THE-
PREFERENCE FOR VETERANS- BY
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYERS-
ANALOGOUS TO WHAT. PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYERS CAN DO IN THE
FIFTY STATES AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- THERE'S A SUNSET IT
WAS REDUCE FROM SEVEN TO SIX
YEARS. THERE'S ALSO PROVISION
AS IS CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE
THAT THOSE WHO WERE DISCHARGED
FROM THE MILITARY ON THE BASIS
OF THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION BE
CONSIDERED VETERANS FOR ALL
PURPOSES THOUGH THEY HAD BEEN
HONORABLY DISCHARGED- TODAY.
AND ALSO REQUIRES EMPLOYERS BUT
PROVIDE A PLAN- THERE'S ANOTHER
AMENDMENT THAT WE HAVE WORKED
ON AS RECENTLY AS TWO DAY. THAT
WE TAKEN VETERANS COMMITTEE-
WITH RESPECT TO ENSURING THAT.
THERE'S NOT DISPARATE IMPACT
AMONG THOSE WHO ARE PROTECTED
CLASSES WHO ARE VETERANS AND
PURPOSES SO THAT IF SOMEONE
USES AS A SUBTERFUGE FOR
EXAMPLE JUST TO HIRE. BOB WHITE
VETERANS TO USE AN EXAMPLE THAT
THAT IS IN VIOLATION OF BOTH
FIANNA VIOLATION OF BOTH
PURPOSE INTENT OF THIS BILL. SO
HAVING SAID THAT I WOULD URGE
MY VOTE I ALSO HAVE. ON THE
LINE- AS WITNESS. WE HAVE-
MISTER MICHAEL CALLED WHO WILL
TESTIFY IN BRIEF THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF WITNESSES
UP. TO TWO MINUTES WE HAVE
MICHAEL CALLED ON THE PHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR KALRA
NUMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL CALL
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY FOR HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT AND ITS
AFFILIATES THE SOCIETY FOR
HUMAN ESOURCE MANAGEMENT. WE
ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT SB SIX SIX FIVE WE WANT
TO THANK CHAIR KALRA AND
MEMBERS LARA CAN DOLLARS JONES
SAWYER AND GóMEZ REYES FOR
YOUR PRIOR SUPPORT OF THE SAME
BILL IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
RENEWED SUPPORT TODAY. EVERYONE
WANTS TO THANK VETERANS FOR
THEIR SERVICE. SB SIX SIX FIVE
WOULD GO BEYOND THE VERBAL
THANK YOU AND ONE MATERIALLY
ASSISTS VETERANS AND FINDING
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS
CRUCIAL TO THE VETERANS LONG
TERM ECONOMIC AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
BENEFIT. MANY EMPLOYERS HAVE
EXPRESSED AN INTEREST IN
ACTIVELY RECRUITING. VETERANS
BUT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LAWSUIT. ACCORDINGLY AT THE SIX
SIX FIVE WOULD ENABLE EMPLOYERS
WHO WISH TO PROVIDE INVOLUNTARY
HIRING PREFERENCE TO DO SO.
PROVIDED THEY ADHERE TO SB SIX
SIX FIVE REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE
IS NOT USED IN AN IMPROPER
MANNER. SUCH A VOLUNTARY HIRING
PREFERENCES ENTIRELY LAWFUL
OVER FORTY STATES WHAT THE RED
BLUE AND PURPLE HAVE ENACTED
SUCH PREFERENCES. ALWAYS
OVERWHELMINGLY AND OFTEN
UNANIMOUSLY. IS ALSO CONSISTENT
CALIFORNIA LAW WHICH ALLOWS THE
TIRING PREFERENCES IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR. INDEED
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAVE A
PREFERENCE PROVISION FOR
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS AND SB SIX
SIX FIVE SIMPLY MODERNIZE THIS
PREFERENCE TO BE USED FOR
VETERANS WHO SERVED AFTER THE
VIETNAM WAR. BEYOND BEING
LAWFUL IS FAIR. VETERANS BRING
UNIQUE SKILL SETS THAT RENDER
THEM QUALIFIED FOR THE POSITION
THEY SPEAK. EVEN IF THE RESUMES
PROPS LOOK DIFFERENT THAN THOSE
WHO TOOK A MORE TRADITIONAL
ROUTE. TO THE EXTENT OF HE TIE
BETWEEN CANDIDATES IS NOT
UNFAIR FOR EMPLOYERS TO BREAK
THAT TIE IN FAVOR THOSE WHO
ELECTED TO SERVE THEIR COUNTRY.
AND DELAYED THERE PRIVATE
EMPLOYMENT CAREERS. LASTLY IS
NOT DISCRIMINATORY SB SIX SIX
FIVE INCLUDES NUMEROUS
PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO ENSURE CANNOT BE USED TO
INTENTIONALLY DISCRIMINATE.
AGAINST A PROTECTED GROUP. SB
SIX SIX FIVE OPPONENTS WILL
EXPRESS CONCERN ABOUT A
POTENTIAL DISCRIMINATORY
IMPACT. RESPECTFULLY THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY SUCH UNFAIR
IMPACT IN THE FORTY STATE TO
RECENTLY ENACTED SUCH
PREFERENCE PROVISIONS. MOREOVER
AN UNFAIR IMPACTED INCREASINGLY
UNLIKELY SINCE THE CURRENT
MILITARY FIGHT VERY DIVERSE.
WITH MEMBERS OF PROTECTED
GROUPS THANKS LITTER THE. HIGH
RATE AND POPULATION. AND WE
HAVE A WEEKLY THING YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND WE PATRONIZED
THANK YOU THANK FOR SHARING.
ANYONE ELSE IS. THE IN THE-
WILL GO TO RIPPLE TESTIMONY.
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX
FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO APPEARANCE
SUPPORT OF SB. SIX SIX FIVE.
AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE ONE IN
Q. AND AGAIN WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX SIX FIVE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ANDREA
ABOUT HER LINE OF EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MAN CARE
NUMBERS KELLY MAY DOUGLAS WITH
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
QUEUE AT TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION I
KNOW ON THE PHONE WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
UP TO TWO MINUTES MAXIMUM EACH
AND WE HAVE KEVIN BAKER. AND
JENNY- PEYSER SO KEVIN- BAKER
FOR THEIR YOU MAY BEGIN. YES
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS KEVIN BAKER DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR IS
HERE YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION.
INTEREST OF TIME I'M ALSO
TESTIFYING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
COALITION OF CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS REFLECTED IN THE
COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS. ANOTHER
ORGANISER TO OPPOSITION OF DONE
A LOT OF BAD BECAUSE HE ON
BEHALF VETERANS OVER MANY
YEARS. AND WE PLUG THE AUTHORS
KOLEJE ADVANCING OPPORTUNITIES
VETERANS. BUT IT DOES NOT UNDER
VETERANS TO PRACTICE
DISCRIMINATION IN THEIR NAME.
NOR. IS IT NECESSARY TO DO SO.
VETERANS AGENDA HIGH SKILLED
AND WELL QUALIFIED JOB
APPLICANTS. MANY OF WHOM LIKE
SENATOR ROBERT HAVE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR CAREERS IN
THE MILITARY. THEY ARE
PROTECTED AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AND THE PARENT
ONE HOUSING ACT. AND THEY DO
NOT NEED A LIFE LONG HIRING OR
RETENTION PREFERENCE TO PLACE
THEM IN JOBS THAT THEY CAN'T
OTHERWISE COMPETE FOR ON THEIR
MERITS. ANYMORE THAN SYNDROME
BURKE. CALL THIS UNITS AT THE
BILL COULD GO FORWARD AND STILL
ACCOMPLISH THE AUTHORS OBJECTED
WITH ONE SMALL BUT IMPORTANT
MEANT. TO SIMPLY NOT ALLOW
DISPARATE IMPACT DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST OTHER PROTECTED CLASSES.
THE PROHIBITION AGAINST
DISCORDANT ACTIVE BEEN THE
CONSISTENT POOL OF OUR CIVIL
RIGHTS LAWS FROM THE BEGINNING.
NEVER BEEN AN EXCEPTION IN FACT
EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS
DISCORDANT BACK DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST VETERANS. ALL REQUESTED
AMENDMENT WHICH SIMPLY ALLOW
THE GROUP TO HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTION AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION THAT VETERANS
HAVE AND PRESERVE EXISTING LAW.
ALREADY UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THEY
HAVE OPERATED UNDER THAT RULE
FOR DECADES. IT IS FRANKLY
MYSTIFYING TO US WHY THE AUTHOR
IS NOT EVEN BEING ABLE TO JUST
ONE CLARIFYING PRINCIPLE.
BEFORE YOU TO HOPE AND COULDN'T
BEFORE YOU GO TODAY I HOPE YOU
WILL HAVE THE ALL GOOD BACK
QUESTIONS AND RESOLVING YOUR
OWN LINES WHY CALIFORNIA SHOULD
NOT MAINTAIN HOW LONGSTANDING
AND CONSISTENT DISCRIMINATION
PROTECTIONS FOR EVERYONE. JUST
AS WE PROTECT VETERANS AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION. ALTERNATIVELY
IF THERE IS ONE OTHER QUESTION
I HOPE YOU WILL ASK. IF YOU
CONCLUDE THAT THE CONCERNS OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS ARE
MISPLACED DESPITE OUR- WORK IN
THIS AREA AND OUR KNOWLEDGE OF
THIS FIELD. WHY NOT ALLOW THE
BILL TO GO FORWARD FOR SOME
REASONABLE THREE YEAR TIME
PERIOD FOR EXAMPLE AND HAVE THE
DFG H. STUDIED THE IMPACT OF
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE IT BECOMES
PERMANENT. IN CLOSING I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS REFLECTED IN
ANALYSIS AND ONE DESCRIBED BY
FOUNDER ON BURKE. NOT
MEANINGFULLY ALTER THE BILL
WOULD MITIGATE THE DISPARATE
IMPACT ON PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED AMONG VETERANS
WHICH IS OUR CONCERN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. TWENTY
MEASURE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON-
JENNIFER PEYSER JUNIOR
COUNSELORS LEARNED A LEGAL AND
EXPLAINED IN OUR LETTER WE
RESPECTFULLY DO OPPOSE THIS
BILL I REQUEST TODAY IS THAT
YOU HIT PAUSE AND GATHER
INFORMATION ABOUT THE AFFECTED
POPULATION BEFORE CHANGING
CALIFORNIA LAW THREE POPULATION
COULD BE ESPECIALLY BURDEN IF
THIS BLL BECOMES LAW JUDGES
WERE EMERGING FROM THE COBIT
PANDEMIC EITHER WOMEN
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
LIVING WITH A DISABILITY WOULD
SUGGEST AN APPROACH BETTER
CALCULATED TO HELP THOSE
VETERANS WHO DO NEED HELP.
FIRST ABOUT WOMEN THE PANDEMICS
ECONOMIC IMPACT HAS BEEN
ESPECIALLY SEVERE FOR WOMEN IT
INCREASED POVERTY FOR WOMEN AND
CHILDREN AND IS EVEN MORE
SEVERE HOLDEN OF COLOR BECAUSE
THE MILITARY HAS BEEN AND
REMAINS OVERWHELMINGLY MALE
THIS BILL WOULD WORSEN THE
CHALLENGES FOR WOMEN SEEKING TO
REENTER THE WORKFORCE NOW ABOUT
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE TO LARGEST
SURVEY OF TRANSGENDER PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA FOUND THAT ONE THIRD
LIVE IN POVERTY ONE THIRD
REPORTED BEING HOMELESS IS
PREJUDICED AGAINST THEM IF THE
POLLING AND PRESIDENT BIDEN
ONLY JUST LISTED THE MILITARY'S
BAN. IT'S AFFECT WILL DISSIPATE
BUT ONLY WITH TIME THIRDS THE
MILITARY'S BAN ON SERVICE BY
PEOPLE WITH A DISABILITY
REMAINS IN PLACE I'M TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO CAN DO AN
EXCELLENT JOB DOING ALL SORTS
OF THINGS BUT A BARGE MILITARY
SERVICE OFTEN FACE UNINFORMED
PREJUDICE WHICH IS WHY
CALIFORNIA LAW PROTECTS AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION LET ME BE CLEAR
OF COURSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
APPRECIATE OUR VETERANS BUT THE
BETTER WAY IS TO CHECK WITH
THEIR NEEDS ARE SOME ARE DOING
WELL FOR THOSE WITH NEEDS WHAT
WOULD HELP HIRING ADVANTAGE
LIKE THIS OR TRAINING FOR THOSE
WHOSE MILITARY ROLE WITH LESS
SKILLED OR MORE MILITARY
SPECIFIC OR OTHER THINGS. AND
FOR VETERANS WHO ARE WELL
EDUCATED OFFICERS HAVE
TRANSFERABLE SKILLS NOT ONLY DO
THEY NEED LESS HELP THEY TEND
TO BE MORE MALE WHITE STRAIGHT
AND NOT TRANSGENDER THEY DON'T
NEED ADVANCED AT THE EXPENSE OF
THOSE WHO ARE OR HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED OR WHO JOINED THE
MILITARY IN FAR FEWER NUMBERS
FOR OBVIOUS REASONS.
RESPECTFULLY INSTEAD OF
APPROVING THE STILL PLEASE CALL
US AND FOCUS INSTEAD ON HOW TO
OUR STATE PEOPLE RECOVER FROM
THIS TERRIBLE PANDA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF THOSE ONE IN THE
ROOM WILL GO ON THERE'S NO ONE
AT REMOTE STATION. A MODERATOR
IN ON THE PHONE. IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX FIVE. THANK YOU FOR
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SIX
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
OPPOSITION ™SB
SURE WE HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY- WE HAVE A
MOTION. A COMMON QUESTIONS.
THIRTY AS A MOTION ON THE TABLE
YEAH. THAT'S AFFIRMATIVE
COMMENTS YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
TO A CENTER AND- I DO HAVE A
LOT OF VETERANS IN OUR AREA-
YET TO COME BACK AND DO NEED-
DO NEED JOBS AND THEY NEED. I
THINK THEY NEED THIS BOOST ARE
YOU TAKING ANY OTHER CO AUTHORS
ON THIS BECAUSE IF YOU ARE I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS COLLATERAL
THANK YOU SOMEONE- THIS BILL
WILL BE AMENDED SO BE TAKE
OFFICE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU- THANK YOU
CENTER OF. THE NPS. THANK YOU
SENATOR- FOR WORKING VERY CLOSE
WITH OUR OFFICE AND- WE DID-
REQEST IN AND CAME TO
AGREEMENT ON A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS INCLUDING. REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS REPORTING FROM
DIVA DLPH AND- I DO TAKE.
SERIOUSLY THE CONCERNS
OPPOSITION. I THINK THEY'RE
LEGITIMATE I THINK THAT WE HAVE
TO BE VERY- IN A- CAUTIOUS AND
I WOULD JUST ASK. THAT YOU.
WORK WITH THEM THE BEST ABILITY
TO VISIT TO ALLAY THEIR
CONCERNS ANOTHER VERY SPECIFIC
REQUESTS. THAT ARE IN THERE.
AND I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO BE
GOING TO AT LEAST ONE OTHER
COMMITTEE- AND SO I WOULD- YOU
KNOW- YOU DO HAVE. TO WORK WITH
THEM TO UNDERSTAND- THAT THE
FEAR IS VERY REAL- BASED UPON-
THE DISPARATE IMPACTS THAT DO
OCCUR- IN EMPLOYMENT. AND TO
THAT- IT'S NOT A UP BUT I MEAN
I DON'T. SO IF MONSTER TAKE AS
A SLIGHT AT ALL. ON VETERANS
QUITE THE OPPOSITE I THINK THAT
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT-
EVERYONE. INCLUDING VETERANS
GETS. TREATED WITH EQUITY AND-
WE TRIED TO ADD SOME ELEMENTS
TO IMPROVE UPON IT AND I KNOW
THAT WE HAVEN'T. NECESSARILY
SATISFIED. THE CONCERNS THE
OPPOSITES COMPLETELY START
ASKING TO CONTINUE. THAT WORK.
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND- AS
WELL AS- WITH THE TRANSPARENCY
IN REPORTING THAT WE- ALREADY
HAVE PUT IN PLACE TO SOME
EXTENT. SO OF WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE- THANK YOU MISTER.
MEMBERS THANK AGAIN FOR YOUR
PRO WITH THE BILL- THANK YOU
MISTER BAKER FOR THAT SHE OUT.
A COUPLE OF THINGS BOB. THERE
THERE. THE ARGUMENT THAT THIS
IS BASICALLY ILLEGAL- IS
REFUTED BY THE FACT THOSE
THIRTY NINE OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE JUST THE SAME KIND OF
PREFERENCE FOR VETERANS FIFTY
STATES HAVE THAT PREFERENCE IN
THEIR GOVERNMENT AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- I WOULD
EXPECT THAT THAT THE FOLKS WHO
ARE OPPOSED WOULD SUGGEST WE
ROLL BACK THOSE BENEFITS THOSE
PROTECTIONS AS WELL THERE'S A
DISPARATE IMPACT IN AND THAT
UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT SOMETHING
WE CAN GET PAST OF THE MILITARY
HAS A DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER
OF LATINOS COMPARED TO THE
GENERAL POPULATION MILITARY IS
A DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS. AS COMPARED
TO THE GENERAL POPULATION IN
THE MILITARY AS A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF POOR
PEOPLE AS COMPARED TO THE
GENERAL POPULATION THERE ARE
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE TO JOIN THE
MILITARY JUST LIKE ME BECAUSE
THEY WANTED A COLLEGE EDUCATION
AND SO YOU DON'T HAVE MANY
PEOPLE FROM NEWPORT BEACH
FRANKLY THAT JOIN THE MILITARY
YOU DON'T HAVE MANY PEOPLE FROM
BEVERLY HILLS THE JOINT
MILITARY BUT YOU DO A LOT OF
FOLKS IN SANTA ANA THE JOIN THE
MILITARY. AND AS SUCH- THIS
BILL PROVIDES SEVERAL THINGS
ONE IT PROVIDES AN INDUCEMENT
BY THE WAY TO JOIN THE MILITARY
BUT BUT TO ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
SERVICE AND THREE ALLOWS
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYERS TO
ALSO BENEFIT JUST LIKE WE DO IN
GOVERNMENT BY PROVIDING A
PREFERENCE TO VETERANS WITH
RESPECT TO A DISABILITIES- IT
INDEED IN FACT THERE ARE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO BECOME DISABLED
BECAUSE OF THEIR MILITARY
SERVICE AND SO I AM SENSE OF
THE FACT THAT THE MILITARY IS
DISCRIMINATING THE PAST
DISCRIMINATE PARTICULARLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
AND WE TRY TO PROVIDE SOME
REMEDY TO THAT OF THE REMEDY AT
LEAST AN EQUALIZATION BY SAYING
THAT THOSE WHO ARE DISCHARGED.
ON THE SAME FOOTING AS THOSE
WHO ARE HONORABLY DISCHARGED AS
VETERANS- THE OPPONENTS WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT THE- BASICALLY
THAT THE UNIVERSE OF THOSE ARE
ELIGIBLE BE EQUAL BETWEEN MEN
AND WOMEN AND- YOU KNOW SADLY.
WHILE THAT UNIVERSE IS
INCREASING DRAMATICALLY WITH
RESPECT TO WOMEN IT IT'S NOT
CLOSE TO BEING EQUAL- IT'S
INCREASED FROM THE TIME I FIRST
JOINED THE MILITARY BY PROBABLY
THREE HUNDRED PERCENT. BUT
THERE'S STILL A LONG WAY TO GO
SO HAVING SAID THAT- GINGIVAL.
THANK THANK YOU SENATOR OF WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE TABLE.
OVENS OF MADAM SECRETARY CAN
TAKE ROLL ON SB SIX SIXTY FIVE.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO MILITARY AND VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE KALRA. FIVE
ALL RIGHT LORD. GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ HI JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I REYES. REYES FIVE ZERO
NINE ALL RIGHT LORD. YOUR I.
THANK YOU MAY THANK YOU WAS- WE
HAVE. TWO BILLS ON CALL WE HAVE
WE HAVE ONE ONE MORE ARE THROWN
AWAY WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON CALL
ITEM S. B. FOR. YEAH THIS IS
THE ONE YOU WANT TO ON CALL
FIRST. SB THREE THIRTY ONE
LEYVA. SB THREE THIRTY ONE
LEYVA. FLORIDA JONES SAWYER-
JONES SAWYER ANDREAS REYES EYES
ZERO NUMBER ZERO NOT VOTING
WARD WARD I WAS OUT M. SB FIVE
TWENTY THREE LEYVA. FLORIDA
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRATE.
REYES EYES ZERO NUMBER IN THERE
THOUGH NOT VOTING BECAUSE THE
BILL IS OUT OF THIS IS DUE OF
TWO CLICK ADD ONS- SB. SIX
SEVEN FOUR. FLOOR GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ ALL RIGHT ZERO NINE
VOTING HERE DOES NOT VOTING SB
SEVEN HUNDRED. FLORIDA GONZALEZ
FIVE GONZALEZ I SCARED OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED. NOW THERE AGO NO
CABLE COME BACK TO THE ISLANDS
OF AFTER WILL GO TO ITEM
THIRTEEN SB EIGHT OH FIVE YEP.
THANK YOU SENATOR. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS THE
WHOLE. WHATEVER YOU KNOW PUT
PLEASE- TAKE YOUR TIME PRESENT.
THE BILL. WE'LL TALK VERY FAST
THANK. HELLO EVERYONE I KNOW
IT'S LEADING BEEN HERE FOREVER
BUT FOR HAVING ME HERE ALSO
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AT TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT WITH A LOT OF HARD
WORK IS THE ALL KNOWING A LOT
OF COLLABORATION AND A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS THROUGHOUT THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS I THINK WE'RE
IN A GOOD PLACE. AND DIED AS OF
TODAY I'M ALSO WANTED TO HAVE A
LETTER OF SUPPORT FROM THE
NATIONAL UNION REPRESENTING
ACTORS AND STAGE MANAGED
MANAGERS ACTORS EQUITY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT I WOULD BE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS.
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
JUST TO BE CLEAR THIS IS NOT AN
AB FIVE CARVE OUT BUT IT WILL
HELP ON THESE COMPANIES COMPLY
WITH AB FIVE THESE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING AS YOU KNOW. UP TO
SEVERAL FACTORS BUT PRIMARILY
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC AND SO
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO GIVE
THEM A LIFELINE TO STAY OPEN
AND CONTINUE TO BE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL ALLOWS
FOR SMALL NONPROFIT PERFORMING
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS WITH BUDGETS
UP TO ONE POINT FOUR MILLION.
TO APPLY FOR GRANTS PENDING
APPROPRIATIONS OF COURSE UNDER
THIS PROGRAM THE FOCUS IS ON
HELPING THE SMALLEST OF
BILLABLE PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE BY
POP COMMUNITY WHICH WAS
IMPORTANT TO ME THIS BILL ALSO
CREATES AN INFRASTRUCTURE TO
HELP WITH PAYROLL PROCESSING
SERVICES. ONCE THE PYRAMID
STRUCTURE IS ESTABLISHED
PARTICIPATING ORGANIZATIONS
WILL BE ABLE TO CUT DOWN. ON
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. CAN I
WANTED TO SHARE CALL THAT.
THERE'S A- STORY TO THIS AND- I
KNOW THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
TO BENEFIT FROM THESE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS IN PARTICULAR.
CHILDREN LIKE MYSELF WHO GREW
UP IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES AT A
TIME WHERE DRUGS VIOLENCE AND
GANGS IS VERY PREVALENT AND I
WAS JUST A CREATIVE CHILD
HAVING TO BE CREATIVE VERY
ENERGETIC AND THE THEATRES
REALLY DID GIVE ME AN OUTLET TO
EXPRESS AND BE ABLE TO DO
POSITIVE THINGS. AND SO THROUGH
THE PERFORMING THAT I DID FOR
SEVERAL YEARS INVOLUNTARY ISN'T
I WAS ABLE TO SEE FIRSTHAND
JUST HOW BENEFICIAL THEY ARE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES I WAS AROUND
WHEN POSSIBLE SETTLED FEDERAL
STARTED IN BOYLE HEIGHTS NEARLY
TWENTY YEARS AGO. AND I DID SEE
FIRSTHAND HOW THE EMBRACED.
PEOPLE WITHOUT EXPERIENCE AND
REALLY OPEN THEIR HOUSE TO KIDS
THAT WERE SOMEWHAT LOST AND
WANTED TO JUST THE PLACE TO BE
TO BE CREATIVE. AND ALSO SERVE
AS INCUBATORS SOME OF OUR KIDS
IN OUR INNER CITY COMMUNITIES
NEVER GET THE OPPORTUNITY STEP
OTHER MORE AFFLUENT. IT'S DEAD
AND STILL THAT GAVE THEM THE
PLATFORM AND THE ABILITY TO
PRACTICE AND HONE IN THEIR
SKILLS AND POTENTIALLY MOVE
ONTO BETTER BIGGER THINGS- I
WANTED TO ALSO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THIS IS NOT JUST. ABOUT
PERFORMING ARTS BUT IT'S REALLY
IS ABOUT EQUITY IN ACCESS AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE HISTORICALLY
THEATER HAS BEEN USED TO
HIGHLIGHT ISSUES OF IMPORTANCE
TO CERTAIN COMMUNITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE OTHER COMPASS HE
NOW USED ARTS THEATER TO REALLY
MOBILIZE THE ARM FARMWORKERS
AND TO HELP THEM FIGHT FOR
BETTER WORKING CONDITIONS. IT
IS INDISPUTABLE THAT PERFORMING
ARTS GO HAND IN HAND WITH
SOCIAL MOVEMENTS AND PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE AND SOCIAL
SOCIETY NOT ONLY TO EDUCATE FOR
REALLY ELEVATOR COMMUNITIES. AS
A CLASSROOM TEACHER FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS I CAN'T SAY
WITH CERTAINTY THAT THE ARTS.
ARE DISAPPEARING IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND BE THEATERS. AND COMMUNITY
NONPROFITS ARE REALLY SUCH A
GREAT PARTNER STROLLER SCHOOLS
THEY CONTINUE TO INVITE OUR
CLASSROOMS IN. GIVE CLASSES IN
REALLY EMBRACE THOSE KIDS THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE ARTS. AND SO TODAY I HAVE
TO INCREDIBLE WITNESSES FIND ME.
FIRST UP I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE. MY DISTINGUISHED
GUEST AWARD WINNING ACTOR
PRODUCER DIRECTOR AND LONGTIME
ACTIVIST FOR THE ARTS EDWARD
JAMES OLMOS WHO WILL BE ON THE
PHONE. MY SECOND WITNESSES
BEATRICE BECAUSE THE GROUND SHE
IS A FOUNDING ARTISTIC DIRECTOR
OF THE FIA'S JOHN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WITNESSES HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES OF THE FEDERAL JAMES
ALMOST WILL BE ON THE PHONE AND
THEN YOU FOLLOWED BY. A BE A
THREE SO BECAUSE A GUN WAS HERE
IN PERSON SO THIS ALMOST
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE FOR THE LONG. PREVIOUS
WORK IT GOES ON TO RUNNING. OUT
COMMUNITIES AND OUR- COUNTRY. I
TAKE MY HAT OFF TO SPECIAL
SENATOR SUSAN MOBILE- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS TO
LIGHT. I'M CRYING RIGHT NOW.
I'M CRYING BECAUSE- I CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT WE GOT THIS
LETTER. WE ACTUALLY ARE TALKING
ABOUT SAVING THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THE OF THE-
ACTING. PRODUCING DIRECTING OR
WRITING. AFTER OF OUR ART
WORKS. WITHOUT A SMALL
THEATERS. I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CREATE. IT BUT TO GO
INTO THAT I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CREATE- LIEUTENANT
MARCUS STEELE IN MIAMI VICE I
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CREATE. A GAPS IN BLADE RUNNER
I WOULD NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO
STAND AND DELIVER AND RECEIVE.
I AM THE ONLY AMERICAN. OF
MEXICAN DESCENT THAT HAS EVER
RECEIVED. THE ACADEMY AWARD
NOMINATION FOR BEST ACTOR IN.
THIS COUNTRY IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY. I COULD ONLY
GOTTEN THERE COMING FROM TELL A
COMING FOR. BOYLE HEIGHTS. THAT
COULD ONLY HAVE GOTTEN THERE BY
THE HOW OF. A SMALL THEATER AND
NON EQUITY NINETY NINETY WAIT
REPEATERS THAT SPREAD ME THEY
GAVE ME LIFE THEY GAVE ME THE
ABILITY TO PRACTICE AND DO MY
CRAFT YES I WANT TO YOU KNOW
STANFORD MIGHT YOUR CLASSES IF
THEY WANT TO TELL ADWARE LATIN
DAHLE ANYTHING. OF THE ACTOR
STUDIO BUT NONE OF THAT WORK
UNLESS YOU WORK ON THE THEATER
STAGE YOU GET CLASSROOMS ARE
GREAT BUT NOW YOU HAVE TO GO
OUT INTO THE PUBLIC IN AND
PERFORM I COULD I DID ALMOST AN
EQUITY ACTOR I AM SO GRATEFUL
THE GALE GABLER GOT THIS.
LETTER OVER TO YOU GUYS FOR THE
ACTOR'S EQUITY ASSOCIATION THAT
APPLE ACTORS EQUITY ASSOCIATION
THE NATIONAL UNION REPRESENTING
ALL ACTORS AND STAGE MANAGERS
WORKING IN LIKE THE ADDED TODAY
RIGHT NOW AND THEY'VE BEEN
AROUND SINCE NINETEEN OH EIGHT
STUFF LIKE THAT NOT TELL YOU
THAT I COULDN'T GET INTO.
ACTIVE EQUITY BECAUSE I WAS IN
A PROFESSIONAL. HOW THE HOW DO
I GET INTO I DON'T GET THIS
CATCH TWENTY TWO COULDN'T GET
IN THE UNION COULD HAVE NEEDED
TO DO A UNION JOB I COULDN'T
GET A UNION JOB BECAUSE THEY
HAD NOT QUIT. SO WHAT DO YOU
GET YOUR CREDITS NOT A
PROFESSIONAL STAGE AND THE
SMALL THEATERS LADIES. AND
GENTLEMEN. OKAY PEOPLE ALL I
CAN TELL YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU MUCH. FOR BRINGING THAT UP
A TENER BEEN ALLEN. FOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH. SUPPORTING A
GENEROUS USER GROUP. AND SUSAN.
SENATOR YOU HAVE DONE SO. THAT
HAS NEVER BEEN DONE THE ANY. IN
THE COUNTRY NO WAY IN THIS
COUNTRY THERE A BILL LIKE AT B.
EIGHT OH FIVE. SO ON MY BEHALF
MY BEHALF. ALL TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT I BEEN.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT AN- I
THINK THANK YOU TO THE SMALL
THEATER THEY GAVE ME BREATH OF
LIFE THEY GAVE ME THE HEART AND
ABILITY TO STAND UP AND DO WHAT
I DO TODAY SO THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK THANK YOU I'M
WASN'T GONNA CUT OFF MR JAMES
EDWARD OLMOS. THANK THANK YOU
FOR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR GREAT
WORK OVER THE YEARS A
PARTICULAR TIME TO SPEAK TO US
WE DO APPRECIATE IT AND WE
HAVE. ANOTHER WITNESS HERE I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE UP. MAKE
PHONE BE THREES CLASSICA. I
TRYING TO I THINK BECAUSE HAVE
TO FOLLOW IT. IS ALMOST. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRPERSON CHOLERA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
BEATRICE CASSEGRAIN FOUNDING
ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF A TINY BY
POT THEATER. AND A RETIRED
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER WHO
TAUGHT ENGLISH AND THEATER FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS IN TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS TEACHING MOSTLY LATINO
CHILDREN AND THEN LATER ON
ASIAN CHILDREN. SMALL
PERFORMING ARTS ORGANIZATIONS
WITH REVENUES UP TO ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION MAKE UP OVER 90%
OF THE SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THEY HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDERFUNDED AND UNDERVALUED.
THIS IMPACTS REPRESENTATION
ONSTAGE AND ESPECIALLY HURTS
LATINO AND BIPAP ORGANIZATIONS
AND THE ARTISTS OF COLOR THAT
WE HIRE. THIS PAST YEAR SAW
ONLY THREE POINT 6% OF ACTORS
EQUITY CONTRACTS GET AWARDED TO
LATINO ACTORS. WITH SB EIGHT OH
FIVE WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE BOLD AND TRANSFORMATIONAL
CHANGES IN THE WAY THAT THE
STATE SUPPORTS THE SMALL
COMPANIES. AND THAT THAT THAT
MENTOR AT RISK YOUTH THAT
EMPLOYEE NEW ARTISTS AND
ARTISTS OF COLOR AND PROVIDE A
HOME TO ARTISTS WHO STORIES BIG
COMPANIES WILL TAKE A CHANCE ON.
AS A TEACHER I SAW THE
TRANSFORMATIVE EFFECT A
PERFORMING ARTS ON STUDENTS THE
STUDENTS I TAUGHT THIS
EXPERIENCE PROMPTED ME WHEN I
RETIRED FROM TEACHER TEACHING
TO FOUND A SMALL THEATER WHERE
I CONTINUE TO THIS DAY
PROVIDING TRAINING AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG ARTISTS.
HANG THEM ALL AT LEAST MINIMUM
WAGE WAS A DREAM. IT DID NOT
SEEM SUSTAINABLE UNTIL TODAY.
SB EIGHT OH FIVE WAS THE RESULT
OF MONTHS OF DISCUSSIONS WITH
ARTISTS AND PRODUCERS AND LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS GOD BLESS ACTORS
EQUITY FOR. FIND A FILING THEIR
SUPPORT TODAY. TO GATHER WAS
SENATOR RUBIO WE CAME UP WITH A
NOVEL APPROACH FOR FUNDING THAT
PUTS FUNDS WHERE THEY WILL HAVE
THE GREATEST IMPACT TO CREATE
NEW JOBS AND EMPLOYEE EMERGING
ARTISTS AND ARTISTS OF COLOR IT
CREATES A BRIDGE TO A HEALTHIER
MORE SUSTAINABLE MORE EQUITABLE
FUTURE. WE'RE SMALL COMPANIES
CAN HIRE MORE WORKERS INCLUDING
MORE UNION WORKERS SB EIGHT OH
FIVE AS A WIN WIN FOR WORKERS
FOR PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES PLEASE PLEASE
SUPPORT SB EIGHT OH FIVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND NEXT UP
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
WE WILL GO TO THEM WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONES ANYONE IN THE PHONES
WERE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OH
FIVE. YOUR PARENTS SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT OH FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
PAY OFF YOUR IN SUPPORT OF THE
S. P. EIGHT OH FIVE. AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF FOUR
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHARE MEMBERS PATHOLOGY DOT COM
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT OF THE
EIGHT OH FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF FOUR TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO AS
CHAIR PERSON KALRA AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MARTHA DENSON I AND THE BOARD
BECAUSE ISN'T OF THE THEATRICAL
PRODUCERS LEAGUE. OF LOS
ANGELES THE TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR SMALL THEATER PRODUCERS IN
LOS ANGELES AND HOPE TO THE
PROUD ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF THE
OPEN FIST THEATRE COMPANY A
SMALL COMPANY NOW THIRTY YEARS
OLD. WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS TRANSFORMATIVE
LEGISLATION THINK THE
PERFORMING ARTS ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AUTHORED BY SUSAN
RUBIO THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF- FOUR OH
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS THE NINETY
WILL BE OURS THANK YOU VICTOR
HALF OF TEIR ONE YEAR ONE AND
THOUGH WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF FIFTY TO FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF FOUR TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS CLARK
DR REPRESENTING THE ALLIANCE OF
DESERT SPEEDERS IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY URGENT SUPPORT
INVESTIGATOR FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF FOUR THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND WORD OF
MARTINEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION- THANKS FOR
THE WORK OF YOU WHEN YOU'RE
COMMITTEE WHERE POLICE TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANKS MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. GOOD PAYMENT
OPPOSITION IS ON HERE AS A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. THERE'S
NO ONE PRESENT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONES IN OPPOSITION AS PETER
FIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. EIGHT OH
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WHAT THERE APPEARED
OPPOSITION. SURE WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION TO GIVE AT THIS TIME.
SUMMER GONZALEZ THANK YOU- I
WANNA MAKE SURE BECAUSE I WAS
CONTACTED BY SOME SUPPORTERS
AND I WANNA MAKE SURE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WE ACTUALLY IN
CONSULTATION WITH- THE
SENATOR'S OFFICE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE WE PUT IN THE
SAME BUDGET REQUEST- AND WE ARE
GETTING THROUGH THE LANGUAGE WE
DO KNOW ARE WE DO THINK. I
SHOULD SAY NO TO WE ACTUALLY
VOTE ON IT THAT THERE WILL BE
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS. NOW
THE- FIFTY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET START
WITH THE CHANGING NUMBER
CONSTANTLY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET. HOWEVER
AS DESCRIBED IN THIS BILL.
DEPARTMENT F FINANCE WHICH IS
LIKE THE THIRD THE ASSEMBLY THE
SENATE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ALL KIND OF HAVE DIFFERENT WAYS
THEY WANT TO EAT. A LESS
PRESCRIPTIVE- PROGRAM BUT ALL
FOR- THEATERS UNDER TWO MILLION
DOLLARS- A BRAND NEW SO STILL
SMALL THEATERS BUT- IT WON'T BE
AS PRESCRIPTIVE AND I JUST I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO.
FOR THE SUPPORTERS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE AS
OPPOSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
LINE UP- BILLS WITH THE BUDGET
AND SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF IT'S NOT WE DID TRY TO GET
IMPACT OF THE- SCHEDULE THAT
WAS MORE. I'M FOCUSED ON THOSE
UNDER ONE POINT FOUR MILLION-
BUT THERE WAS A LOT OF BACK AND
FORTH THEY ALSO ARE NOT FUNDING
THE PAYROLL SERVICES SO I HOPE
WE CAN CONTINUE WORK TOGETHER I
HOPE. YOU CAN ACTUALLY. ARE I
CAN GO TO YOUR OFFICE AND
ACTUALLY WORK DIRECTLY WITH YOU
RATHER THAN THROUGH OUR STAFF.
TO WORK THROUGH HOW WE CAN GET-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON BOARD
WITH A PAYROLL SERVICE WHICH
MAY OR MAY NOT BE IN THE FORM
THE PAYMASTER FORM THAT
CURRENTLY IS BUT- I'M I'M
EXCITED THAT THAT WE GOT THE
BUDGET ALLOCATION WHICH MEANS
THE MONEY WILL ACTUALLY BE
THERE BECAUSE THE BILL IS NO%
GOOD. IF WE- DON'T ACTUALLY GET
THE MONEY AND- I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN FIGHTING ALL YEAR WE HAD
STARTED HOPEFUL OF A HUNDRED
MILLION AND I PROMISE YOU WE
WILL CONTINUE EVERY YEAR TO TRY
TO GET. A MONEY INTO ARTS
BUDGETS BUT- I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY STAFF AND- AS WELL AS-
THE LABOR COMMITTEE BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT SUPPORTERS
KNOW. IF THINGS CHANGE IT'S
ONLY BECAUSE THE IT THE MONEY
WILL BE THERE IT'S THE
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS HAS TO
LINE UP WITH THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND SO WE'RE KIND OF IN THAT
NEGOTIATED. ALMOST THE END OF.
THAT NIGHT AND GO SHE ATION
STAGE RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THEM. AND BEFORE I. HEADED
OVER CLOSE INCOME AS I WAS THAT-
IS MEMBERS CORRECT AND FIRST OF
ALL. THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
WORKING WITH OUR STAFF WORKING
FOR THOSE WITH THE LABOR FED AS
WELL- IN ORDER TO ALIGN- OF THE
BILL. BUT THE WORK HAS BEEN
ALSO BEEN HAPPENING WITH THE
SUMMER BECAUSE I REALLY WANT TO
THANK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ. BECAUSE SHE'S
CORRECTIVE THE MONEY'S NOT
THERE. THAN YOU ACTUALLY DON'T
GET THAT SUPPORT. FOR THE ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED. WORK
MOVING. FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET THIS TO THE- FINISH
LINE. AND SO- WITH THAT- CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES
THANK YOU WELL FIRST I WANT TO
THANK US REMEMBER. THAT AND I
DON'T FEATHER FLETCHER POOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND
REALLY TRYING TO COME TO. AN
AGREEMENT AND CONSENSUS ON THE
LANGUAGE- ALSO WITH ALL THE
LABOR UNIONS FOR WORKING SO
HARD AND I GET MANY. HOURS IN
CONVERSATIONS AND- AND I THINK
WE'RE IN A GOOD PLACE- I'M
STILL. HOPEFUL STERN
CONVERSATIONS WITH
ADMINISTRATION AND HEALTH. YOU
KNOW WE CAN. FROM OUR FUNDING
AND BUT- I JUST WANT TO LEAVE
US WITH THIS YOU KNOW EVEN
THOUGH HE COULDN'T TESTIFY
DANNY GLOVER AT THE ACTOR IS
ALSO STRONG SUPPORTER HE SAID
IN ONE OF OUR- PRESS
CONFERENCES YOU KNOW WE NEED.
SMALL THEATERS. WE NEED A SPACE
TO BE ABLE TO TELL OUR STORIES
NOT THEIR STORIES. AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I WILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE. HAVE A MOTION MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTIONS DUE PASS AS
A MAN. TO A- ALL. HI COLORADO
FLORIDA. FLOOR HI GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER HI
JONES SAWYER AYE REYES. YES I
ZERO I ZERO FIVE BOARD. WORD
ONLINE RIGHT THE BILLS I THINK-
THE KILLERS GO THROUGH- THE
BILL'S MAKING GO- ITEM BUT WHAT
WAS MORE THAN WILLING CONSENT
CALENDAR. YOU WANNA START
CONSENT GOTCHA CERTAINLY
CERTAINLY ONE OF NUMBER ONE SB
SIX TWENTY EIGHT WELL ONE.
FLORIDA ARE LARA ALL RIGHTS ARE
NOT VOTING. FOR A NOT VOTING ON
SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT ZERO NUMBER
ZERO NOT VOTING. ITEM TO SB
THREE TWENTY ONE LARA. LARA NOT
VOTING RAMOS HI REYES I DON'T
KNOW THERE DON'T KNOW. I AM
THREE SB SIX THIRTY TO RUSSELL
SIX THIRTY NINE LARA THIS IS A
NINE NO LARA NO RARE EARTH
ZERO. NOT VOTING ZERO NOT GOING
TOWARD OUR LORD HI. SB SIX
SEVEN FOR THE RUSSELL LARA.
FLORIDA NOT INCLUDING SB SEVEN
HUNDRED THE RUSSELL LARA NO
LARA NO SB THREE THREE EIGHT
GONZALEZ. LAURA LAURA NOT
VOTING. ZERO ZERO ZERO NO JONES
SAWYER FIVE JONES SAWYER HI. SB
SIX OH SIX GONZALEZ LARA. LARA
KNOWN THREATS HI WHERE SITE
ZERO ZERO ZERO NO. SB THREE
THREE ONE LEYVA LARA NO LARA NO
SB FIVE TO THREE LEYVA FLORA
FLORA NO SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN
LEYVA- YEAH YOU'RE CORRECT SB
FIVE TO THREE REYES NO RACISM
NINE OH SHOOT OKAY PARDON ME
PARDON YES RADIUS IS AN OFFICE
ON FIVE TWENTY THREE. THE
CORRECT SET OKAY- ITEM TEN SB.
SEVEN TWO SEVEN. THE FLORIDA.
FLORIDA NO ZERO NOPE ZERO NO
DOES SERVE A LOT. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN. MY APOLOGIES JONES
SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER HI.
THINK YOU'RE THAT SB FOUR ONE
NINE. FLORA FIVE LARA HI THE
CLASS WAS SB SIX SIX FIVE.
FLORIDA. FLOOR I. FOR CONSENT
HONOR THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU
FOR MONEY FLORIDA- LARA HI RAHA
HAI FEARS I SHARE HI. ZERO ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK EVERYONE
RETURNED THANK YOU VERY MILLION.